So, auf geht's.
Mal kurz gucken, ob das hier alles stimmt.
Ja, sieht gut aus.
Scheint zu funktionieren.
Moin.
Ach ja, Leute, ich bin ein bisschen später.
Das hat nur sekundär was mit der Zeitumstellung zu tun.
Na gut, ich meine, ich bin nicht ganz so früh aufgestanden.
Aber es hat nur am Rande was mit der Zeitumstellung zu tun.
Und zwar, ich habe hier ein neues Handy, weil ich jetzt...
Also, ich fange ja am 3.4. bei einem neuen Arbeitgeber an.
Habe ich euch ja ausführlich genug jetzt schon öfters mal erzählt.
Und ich habe ja aktuell ein Handy von der Firma, wo ich jetzt arbeite.
Das muss ich aber abgeben.
Aber ich habe jetzt die Rufnummer mitgenommen.
Ich habe die Rufnummer umziehen lassen und habe mir ein neues Handy gekauft.
Und eben ist mir eingefallen, Moment, du hast ja deine Banking-App noch nicht umgezogen.
Also, habe ich die 1822-App runtergeladen.
Und da hat die mir erstmal angezeigt.
Ich soll irgendeine QR-Code, frag mich nicht, eingeben.
Hatte ich natürlich nicht.
War auf noch einem alt-älteren Handy drauf.
Ich überweise mit dem Ding eigentlich so gut wie nie was.
So, hm, was machst du jetzt?
Bisschen drinnen rumgeklickt.
Auf einmal konnte ich mich gar nicht mehr einmelden.
Bin ich ein Rechner, habe ich mich angemeldet.
Und glücklicherweise haben sie sich selbst gebetet.
Normalerweise braucht man da auch eine TAN aus der App, um sich einzuloggen.
Aber glücklicherweise haben sie sich selbst gebetet.
Sie haben ein neues TAN.
Verfahren eingeführt, was man jetzt quasi einfach nur noch per Klick und ohne zu scannen benutzen kann.
Und deswegen haben sie das TAN-Verfahren resettet.
Und man konnte ganz normal nochmal über das Telefon das Online-Banking aktivieren.
Und das habe ich dann gemacht und habe jetzt die App runtergeladen für das neue.
Alter, das ist unnötig kompliziert gemacht.
Ich frage mich, was ist, wenn man, wenn man wie ich jetzt halt das alte Handy verloren hat, geklaut bekommen hat oder sonst was.
Also ich meine, ich habe das abgegeben und nicht daran gedacht, die App zu, damals irgendwie umzustellen.
Dann braucht man wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Fax oder so.
Dann muss man wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Fax hinschicken und man kriegt ein Einmal-Code oder sowas.
Alles ultra-Paintschampig gemacht, sage ich euch.
Extremely Paintschamp.
Ich muss gerade mal hier die Banking-Sachen wegmachen.
Ich schiebe mal auf den Haufen.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Also keine Ahnung, warum das so kompliziert sein muss wieder.
Aber gut, ich verstehe es in gewisser Weise schon, dass man für einen Login und so nochmal eine gültige TAN braucht.
So was.
Also es könnte sich ja jeder, der dann ein Online-Passwort irgendwo her hat, könnte sich ja einloggen.
Das ist natürlich auch nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Ich muss aber ehrlich sagen, seit ich Apple Pay verwende, ist meine Bargeldbenutzung und die Sparkassenkarte oder generell die Bankkartenbenutzung und so, ist schon ganz schön zurückgegangen.
Also es ist wirklich ganz nice.
Ich hätte das normalerweise wahrscheinlich nie gemacht, weil ich, ja weiß nicht, ich habe nicht gedacht, dass das irgendwie taugt.
Dass das nice ist, ja, ich weiß auch nicht.
Vor allem wollte ich nicht, dass Apple irgendwas da noch mehr damit zu tun haben soll, als es eh schon zu tun hat.
Und LeChuck, danke schön für den Sub.
Zumindest irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht, okay, als ich mal beim Lidl gewesen bin, habe ich mir gedacht, hey, die haben doch diese komische Lidl-App, mit der kann man doch auch bezahlen.
Das ist doch besser, als sie jedes Mal an der Kasse rumzustehen und rumzufuddeln und an das Geld rauszusuchen.
Also hatte ich die Lidl-App installiert und dann habe ich das mal mit Lidl Pay ausprobiert.
Und Lidl Pay ist halt schon mal besser als Bargeld, aber immer noch doof, weil man die App entsperren muss und dann in so einen komischen Scanner halten muss mit dem QR-Code und sowas.
Das ist ja alles nicht so geil.
Also habe ich mir überlegt, also wenn du jetzt schon mal Lidl Pay ausprobiert hast, dann nimmst du einfach jetzt auch mal Apple Pay oder halt das, man kann auch Google Pay nehmen, halt das, was im Smartphone native integrated ist.
Und dann habe ich das eingerichtet mit meiner Kreditkarte und easy.
Jetzt gehe ich sogar schon zur Eisdiele.
Und wenn die Eisdiele irgendeine Kartenzahlungsmöglichkeit hat, bezahle ich bei der Eisdiele auch mit Apple Pay.
Das ist sehr praktisch.
Klick, klick, dranhalten, bipp, geht.
Einzige, wo es nicht funktioniert hat bisher, die ein Kartenlesegerät hatten, ist das Amt.
Ich musste zum Amt, um ein polizeiliches Führungszeugnis zu beantragen.
Und da musste man, ich weiß nicht was es war, 10 Euro oder so oder 20 Euro, irgendwas, ich weiß nicht, oder 8 Euro, ich keine Ahnung genau.
Man musste ein bisschen gebühlt.
Man musste ein bisschen gebühlt werden, aber man musste ein bisschen gebühlt werden, aber man musste ein bisschen gebühlt werden.
Ist ja logisch.
Ich meine, man bezahlt Steuern, er ist fuck, aber das ist natürlich nicht umsonst, logischerweise.
Ich meine, wozu bezahle ich zehntausende Euro an Steuern, wenn natürlich dann ab und zu, wenn ich mal was will, das ist ja selbstverständlich, muss das natürlich Geld kosten, ist ja klar.
Naja, zumindest habe ich das beantragt.
Und da konnte ich auch Kartenzahlungen machen, habe ich probiert mit Apple Pay, aber das Amt war nicht in der Lage, Apple Pay kontaktlos.
Das ist NFC bezahlen zu processen, das ging nicht.
Da musste ich an diesen komischen Automaten.
Also ansonsten hat es überall funktioniert, bloß im Amt nicht.
Ja gut, es gibt noch mehr Sachen, die Arbeitsplätze abschafft.
Müssen sich halt was anderes überlegen, ist halt so, ist in der IT auch so.
Wenn du da nicht am Ball bleibst, kannst du halt bald nichts mehr gescheit, das was gebraucht wird.
Ist halt heute so, willst du machen.
Kannst nicht, kannst nicht einfach immer drauf hoffen, dass alles so bleibt.
Wie es vor 100 Jahren, vor 50 Jahren oder gar vor, jetzt teilweise vor 10 Jahren noch gewesen ist, es ändert sich halt.
Und es ist egal, ob das Arbeitsplätze abschafft oder nicht oder wie auch immer, es wird eh gemacht, weil es ist bequem.
Und das einfachste, was du machen kannst, wenn du eine, mal angenommen du willst irgendeine App raushauen oder irgendeinen Service raushauen,
aber es gibt da schon 1, 2 Leute, die quasi auch so einen Service machen.
Das einzige, was du machen kannst, ist, das muss einfacher sein.
Billiger geht.
Billiger geht auch, aber es muss einfacher sein.
Und sobald das einfacher ist, machen das die Leute.
Eventuell sogar, wenn es ein bisschen teurer ist.
Guckt euch das mal an.
WhatsApp.
WhatsApp ist das beste Beispiel für.
WhatsApp hat sich rasant, also wirklich mega, weiß nicht, ob es da irgendwelche Statistiken gibt, also WhatsApp hat sich rasant durchgesetzt.
Und WhatsApp war bei weitem nicht der erste Messenger-Dienst, den es aufgenommen hat.
Auf dem Smartphone gegeben hat.
Ich meine, das hat alles angefangen mal vor einer Weile, vor einer ganzen Weile mit OL-Messenger, Yahoo-Messenger, MSN-Messenger, ICQ, Skype gab es eine Weile.
Und vieles davon, gerade Skype und sowas, das gab es auch alles, das gab es auch alles auf dem Smartphone.
Und manche Leute haben das auch benutzt und fanden das auch ganz nice.
Aber warum hat sich WhatsApp durchgesetzt?
Genau, erstens, weil die Kack-Noobs es nicht gecheckt haben.
Aber wie kommen die Kack-Noobs überhaupt zu dieser Annahme, dass man mit...
WhatsApp kostenlos SMS verschicken kann?
Das liegt daran, weil sie das einzig Sinnvolle gemacht haben.
Sie haben gesagt, wir scheißen auf Datenschutz und wir scheißen auf irgendwie Money und sonst was.
Sondern, das hat ja glaube ich am Anfang sogar was gekostet, sondern wir benutzen die Handynummer der Leute anstatt noch eine zusätzliche Nummer.
Und das war halt ein Riesending, weil die Handynummer ist eh unique pro User.
Da brauchst du ja eine Handynummer für dich.
Also die hat eh jeder eine eindeutige Nummer.
Und weil WhatsApp die Handynummer genommen hat, hat es keine zusätzliche Nummer mehr gebraucht.
Und die Leute kamen dann so auf eine doofe Idee, ho, damit kann man ja kostenlos SMS verschicken.
Es ist halt keine SMS, aber das haben die Leute halt nicht gecheckt.
Die Leute haben gesehen, ah, ich installiere App, ah, ich habe meine Telefonnummer und mit der Telefonnummer kann ich jetzt Nachrichten verschicken.
Und das kommt dann bei den anderen an.
So, und deswegen...
Das hat sich rasend durchgesetzt.
Warum?
Weil sie es einfacher gemacht haben.
Keine extra Nummer, kein zusätzlicher Scheiß.
Einfach nur draufklicken, Scheiß auf Datenschutz, alles sharen, inklusive Telefonbuch natürlich.
Aber die Leute, wenn die die Auswahl haben, seriously, was meint ihr, Chat, was meint ihr?
Wenn so der 0815 die Auswahl hat zwischen Bequemlichkeit versus Datenschutz, was macht der?
Was macht der?
Was macht der 0815-Pepega am Handy?
Hat der Probleme damit, seine Telefonnummer zu sharen und sein Telefonbuch zu sharen?
Was macht der?
Dem ist doch scheißegal.
Der klickt auf alles except, weil er das eh hat, weil er das eh gewohnt ist.
Und es ist bequem und er freut sich danach noch, dass er jetzt quasi 60 Telefonnummern geshared hat.
Von Leuten, die das vielleicht gar nicht wollen, was ja auch ein bisschen problematisch ist, ehrlich gesagt, bei WhatsApp.
Aber okay.
Ich glaube, da gibt es mittlerweile sogar eine Option für, dass man das nicht mehr machen muss, oder?
Wobei ich glaube, in den WhatsApp-Bedingungen steht wahrscheinlich drin, dass man, also ich rate das jetzt mal, ich weiß nicht, ob das so ist,
wahrscheinlich steht in den WhatsApp-Bedingungen drin, dass man nur Nummern sharen darf, deren Erlaubnis man hat.
Und du bestätigst, dass du die Erlaubnis eingeholt hast oder so ein Shit, sodass WhatsApp schön raus ist quasi.
Hat natürlich niemand gemacht.
Und dann ist gut, deswegen hat sich das einfach rasant...
...durchgesetzt, weil es easy as fuck gewesen ist.
Und danach kamen dann die anderen auch auf den Trichter von Telegram und Signal und sonstige Geschichten.
Ja.
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist total...
Aber das interessiert die Leute auch nicht.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das so ist, aber das interessiert die Leute nicht.
Es muss möglichst easy und einfach sein.
Jaylee, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich zeige euch mal was, bevor der Stream so richtig anläuft.
Hallo?
Ich wollte eigentlich meine VM starten.
Ich habe gestern noch...
...kurz ein bisschen am VM-Champ rumgebaut.
Was ist das für Bettgemusik, ey?
Extrem Bettgemusik.
Bettgetime.
Dabei sind wir gerade aufgestanden.
Moment, Moment, wie brauche ich das?
Morning Music habe ich doch auch hier irgendwo.
Kommt besser.
Ja, okay.
Das geht besser.
Ja, das habe ich gemacht.
Kann ich löschen?
Hier unten hängt das Kommando aus.
Irgendwann...
Aus welchen Gründen?
Ich weiß nicht so genau, warum.
Hä?
Was genau hängt hier unten?
Irgendwas.
Docker PS hängt.
Warum auch immer.
Easy.
Ich mache jetzt einfach das ganze Terminal zu.
Lull.
Dead.
Docker restart.
So, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was.
Ich habe nämlich gestern noch weiter gemacht.
Ja, das brauchen wir jetzt alles nicht.
Was?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was es von mir will, aber okay.
Ja, ja.
Gibt es ja auch gar nicht mehr.
So, okay.
Nice.
So, und jetzt bilden wir das mal.
Bild.
Ah, keine Ahnung.
Irgendwas, egal.
So, das soll Output nach Repos.
Okay, ich lasse es mal kurz bilden und dann zeige ich euch das allerwichtigste Feature,
was ich gestern noch eingebaut habe.
Moin.
Ansonsten, ich überlege gerade, ist noch irgendwas Spannendes gewesen?
Ich glaube, wir gucken uns mal eine Runde GitHub Trends an.
So wie immer.
Und um festzustellen.
Und um festzustellen, dass es wieder genau der gleiche Shit ist wie letzte Woche.
Ein bisschen Krypto-Zeug.
Und der Rest AI, AI, AI, AI, AI.
Ohne Pause.
So, AI.
Ja, das war klar.
AI.
Nee.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was Alpaka-Lora sein soll.
Es klingt auch nach AI.
Lama.
Das klingt so nach AI.
Ja, natürlich.
AI.
Äh, AI.
Das ist irgendwas anderes.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Okay.
Irgendwas von Microsoft.
Integrating Cutting Edge LLM.
Ah, doch.
Machine Learning.
Das ist auch.
Das ist auch AI.
AI.
Comfy UI.
Ah, AI.
Natürlich.
Es heißt UI.
Warum auch immer.
Aber AI.
Äh, AI.
AI.
Alter.
los all da wird eine zeit für neues high performance okay es ist es es ist
tatsächlich was war eigentlich ei ei ei ei schuh chat gpt ei ei ei ei
wahrscheinlich keine ahnung neben team works das ist irgendwas animativen alle
leute leute ohne scheiß zwei projekte sind nicht er der vm champ der muss
integration haben dass es funktioniert a high performance zero overhead
extensiven peisen compiler ja der kann wahrscheinlich wieder die hälfte nicht
deswegen benutzen keiner oder ja mit zehn modulen funktioniert es doch dann
wieder nicht zusammen es ist wahrscheinlich das ding funktioniert
wahrscheinlich nicht wahrscheinlich funktioniert es bei den bei vielen
sachen nicht aber warum nicht kann dann übel mal was ist das moon ray
tricks open source und world running state of the art production mcrt
renderer ich weiß nicht was ein mcrt renderer ist aber irgendwelche
animations stilzeug alles klar also die hälfte wieder
ob das okay alles gut so ich habe das allerwichtigste feature eingebaut
gestern noch in den vm champ guck mal man kann das ding jetzt aufrufen
Es wird nicht in Help angezeigt, ja.
Man kann das Ding jetzt aufrufen mit
kekw.
Und dann gibt es den ASCII kekw.
Alle allerwichtigstes Feature.
Guck, so muss das sein.
Ah, ich habe überhaupt nicht mehr gemappt.
Ich sehe gerade, ich habe nicht mehr gemappt.
Schriftgrößer und kleiner machen im Terminal.
Wie viele Stunden hast du für die Implementierung gebraucht?
Easy, 5 Minuten.
Ich habe das, ich habe das, ich habe das, ich habe beschissen.
Passt mal auf.
Ich habe gecheatet.
Ich zeige es euch.
Wobblons.
WMChamp.
Ich habe, ich habe gecheatet.
Wobei, ich bin im Repo drin.
Ich könnte es euch auch einfach hier zeigen.
Egal, ich zeige es euch.
Kekw-Command.
Das ist alles.
Das Bild ist einfach embedded.
Als Shell-Escan.
Wie in den Cape-Codes.
Einfach riesenlanger, mehrzeiliger String.
Das ist das Bild.
Ihr erkennt es vielleicht nicht.
Jetzt so auf den ersten Blick.
Aber es ist das Bild.
Und es macht nichts anderes als das Bild ausgeben.
Obwohl, vielleicht wenn man es schnell bewegt erkennt man es dann vielleicht.
Und erkennt man es dann.
Ah, ne, geht nicht.
Ne, ne, nicht wirklich, ne.
Also das ist, das ist das Bild.
Was er, was er hiermit, was er hiermit ausgibt.
Deswegen ist es auch schnell.
Das ist so schnell.
Wollen wir mal, wollen wir mal checken wie schnell das ist.
Passt mal auf.
Wir testen jetzt wie viel Kekw pro Sekunde wir hinkriegen.
Ähm, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
While true.
Do.
Done.
Okay, ganz viele Kekw.
Und jetzt PV.
Nach Def 0.
Okay, Leute.
Kekw pro Sekunde.
Wie viele Kekw pro Sekunde?
Ah, das ist aber schwach.
Das ist aber nicht, das ist aber nicht viel.
Guck mal.
Wir schaffen nur 2,2 MB Kekw pro Sekunde.
Das ist aber schwach.
Also da habe ich gedacht, da geht ein bisschen mehr.
Aber das liegt auch daran, weil der jedes Mal das Ganze neu aufrufen muss.
Also ich bräuchte eigentlich noch einen Flag.
Printe unendlich in der Endlosschleife Kekw.
Das würde deutlich schneller gehen, als jedes Mal das Programm aufrufen.
Also das, das muss man sagen.
Das enttäuscht mich.
Das, das weiß ich gar nicht mehr Deutsch reden.
Das enttäuscht mich, dass wir nur 2,3 MB Kekw pro Sekunde packen.
Das ist schon nicht gut.
Das ist nicht gut.
Aber wenn ich PV weg mache, werdet ihr sehen, es ist immer noch ganz schön viel.
2,5 MB Kekw die Sekunde.
Seht ihr das?
Hört gar nicht mehr auf.
Sieht da so aus, als würde er lachen.
Guck mal.
Dabei ist, dabei printet er einfach nur möglichst schnell auf die Konsole.
So.
Excellent.
Die 2,5 MB Kekw pro Sekunde.
Das muss man sagen.
Die wichtigsten Sachen haben wir schon mal.
Ja.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist gecheated, weil ich habe das Bild, ja, weil ich habe das Bild
ja vor, vorrendert.
Wisst ihr was?
Wir probieren mal was aus.
Ne.
Weil ich kann das nicht in Twitch Chat posten.
Wenn ich in Twitch Chat poste, das ist ja Escape-Sequenz.
Da passiert nichts.
Ja.
Also.
Ich habe gecheated.
Ich habe das mit einem, hier, Renderer für die Commandline, habe ich das, habe ich das
rausgehauen ich glaube ich weiß gar nicht was ich dafür was ich dafür
benutzt habe keine ahnung ja so sieht's aus
w2,5 mb w die sekunde das sollte neue einheit werden ich meine real agents
mensch danke für den sub ich meine es gibt schon viele kack einheiten so
beispielsweise bbb btu pro stunde und sowas wo auch man sie wo man sich auch
fragt wer hat sich das das gibt das überlegt also wenn ich weiß was btu pro
stunde ist das ist die energiemenge die man braucht um ein britisches fund ein
britisches fund wasser um ein grad britisches fahrenheit zu erwärmen btu pro
stunde alles klar das ist essentielle einheit die braucht
man 2023 noch aber die stehen drauf bei zb usf bei
usv wird
btw
ganz viel in btu pro stunde angegeben ich weiß nicht warum vielleicht wie viel die usv
selbst an abwärme verbraucht anstatt an die geräte weiter zu gehen keine ahnung aber usvs wird diese einheit ganz gerne verwendet hier btu
btu pro stunde das ist wirklich best of kühlleistung berechnen okay best of
best of
bullshit einheiten
obviously hier na gut wobei das ist eigentlich sogar relativ relativ
klar
Ist gleich
4086,8 joules durch kilogramm mal was ist k leute
Ist das ist das wärme was ist k
Any any physics 5 kalorien ergibt keinen sinn an der stelle kelvin
dass die temperatur
ja okay
also 1000 btu pro stunde sind
ungefähr
293 watt alles klar
wisst ihr was man aber sehr schön daran sieht ist
was man
was ich was ich schon öfters mal irgendwelche leuten erklären musste obwohl ich jetzt nicht der ultra physics 5 hat bin aber immerhin
das watt pro stunde keinen sinn ergibt was man hieran wieder schön sieht weil 1000 btu pro stunde
sind
293 watt ohne zeiteinheit was bedeutet dass in dieser das in
dieser abkürzung watt also in dieser einheit eigentlich hat die zeit schon mit drin steckt
das heißt watt pro stunde und so macht überhaupt keinen sinn das kommt daher weil manche leute irgendwie auch immer noch denken dass kilo watt stunde
quasi so das gleiche wie km h ist also
kam heißt auch falsch aus ist ja auch falsch ausgesprochen also je nachdem wie man wie man sieht weil
die denken dann es ist quasi kilo watt durch stunde was ja gar nicht stimmt es ist ja kilo hat mal
stunde im gegensatz zu
kilometer durch stunde
ja die die einfachste die einfachste variante ist jules durch durch sekunde
dann hast du hast es das dann recht
wenn man da immer noch weiß ja aber zumindest
ist halt die zeit schon mit drin und deswegen macht es keinen sinn zu sagen was pro stunde watt pro stunde wäre so was wie
wenn wenn das irgendwie sich
wenn es so eine steigerung gebe oder sowas
dann vielleicht ja
dass man dann quasi sagen kann okay der verbrauch steigt an um
fünf watt pro stunde oder so und dann das brauchte das dann 15 dann 15 oder irgendwie so braucht ja dann könnte man das vielleicht
so angeben aber es ist auf jeden fall was anderes als kilo watt stunde
Nee als durchschnitt brauchst du das nicht als durchschnitt kannst du auch einfach kilo watt stunden angeben
verbraucht im durchschnitt so und so viel
also wenn du kannst hast du kannst das ausrechnen
dann ja du kannst die zeit dann einmal einmal teilen okay ja das macht schon sind was auch immer quick maps zu viel
zu viel quick maps
Weiß gar nicht wie ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin viel zu viel backofen und sowas in btu
Ich weiß nicht was wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich brauchst du da
bestimmt
bestimmt 4000 btu pro stunde mal mal stunden
dann noch
also also
4000 btu pro stunde mal 15 minuten
dann weißt du was du verbraucht hast oder was du für eine energiemenge brauchst so um
kbt und das ganze und das ganze mal stunde noch
Meine güte gut was auch immer
bin ich jetzt eigentlich darauf gekommen keine ahnung mehr man
gibt es irgendwas spannendes was was youtube heute empfiehlt
was verdient ein straßenreiniger
aktuell eindeutig zu wenig weil sie reinigen ja nicht mal die straße sondern die streiken
roboter ohne begrenzungsdraht das gucken wir uns an da bin ich auch da da da habe ich auch so ein auge drauf geworfen
sollten die irgendwann mal was taugen
mein garten ist wirklich nicht gut geeignet für roboter
also da hat der teilweise wurzel
und der hat einen teich und sowas also spricht das ding muss damit klar kommen
dass er darf nicht in teich fallen und der absaufen der darf auch nicht an wurzel hängen bleiben und seine seine
unten messer kaputt machen und sowas
genau um 44 wurde angekündigt tatsächlich hier da steht es ja auch moment das können wir uns nicht angucken
das ist wieder der dude der firefox nicht mehr verwenden will und jetzt wieder firefox verwendet der erste wirklich intelligentes
firetv
amazon fernsehen kommt mir bestimmt nicht in die bude
der ja nicht mehr
die haben ja geschrieben dass das ohne begrenzungsdraht ist
da muss man sich ja drum kümmern ohne begrenzungsgrad erster roboter ohne begrenzungsgrad
was stimmt über programmieren von den haben und von dem man schon ein paar videos angeguckt was haben wir da was hat er denn sonst noch
bevor du dual studierst schau dir dieses video ich will nicht du anstehend
Was 87 prozent aller menschen scheitern ohne diese fähigkeit beim programmieren okay
können wir uns nachher angucken wie das immer kurz und knackig
und dann haben wir uns dann auch noch mal angeschaut
und dann habe ich
87 prozent von 80 mehr menschen scheitern
87 prozent ist die redesignung weise
ich würde sagen 87 prozent der menschen scheitern schon auch generell am programmieren
BESIEGigen sollte man das machen
Das macht euch nichts
weitergehen dass das deutlich mehr höhere prozentsatz der welt der weltbevölkerung programmiert scheitert hat 87 prozent
fire sports kann ich mir aktuell gerade gar nicht vergeben feier profound ist im prinzip nur noch nur noch
guckt euch das mal an
Chat-GPT-Copilot, Chat-GPT-Pilot, na gut, ich versteh's ja, ich versteh das ja, guck mal hier, GPT, GPT, ich versteh's ja, der Kram kriegt halt einfach mega krass Views, ich versteh's aber insofern nicht so ganz, weil ich finde diese ganzen AI-Videos schon seit Monaten langweilig.
Da ist mal das ein oder andere Interessante dabei, aber zum größten Teil ist es einfach nur langweilig, weil es immer das gleiche ist, ja, Fireship macht die Videos gut, das stimmt, aber ich kann langsam wirklich keine AI-Videos mehr gucken, es ist immer das gleiche, ja, Chat-GPT wird irgendwas gefragt und die Leute sind immer furchtbar beeindruckt und ich hab den Eindruck, die Videos sind halt so gemacht, dass sie eben genau die Sachen so fragen, dass eben besonders coole Ergebnisse rauskommen.
Und wahrscheinlich sogar drei bis vier Mal noch aufgenommen, klar, ich sag doch gar nichts dagegen, dass das nicht cool ist, aber irgendwann ist auch mal gut, ich brauch ja nicht das 20. Video, wo Chat-GPT irgendeine billige App oder eine Webseite oder sonst was erstellt, es sollten viel lieber die Leute mal Videos drüber machen, da gibt's recht wenige, ob und wie sie Chat-GPT und AI im Alltag verwenden, das finde ich nämlich viel interessanter, ja, zum Beispiel zu sagen, man könnte Chat-Messages damit generieren, wenn man keinen Bock hat, dem Typ zu antworten oder E-Mails zu antworten,
E-Mail-Antworten generieren, wenn man da drauf keinen Bock mehr hat, da gibt's, da gab's von CT, von der CT gab's da mal ein Video zu und das ist dann teilweise schon auch ganz interessant, aber so dieses x-te Chat-GPT macht meine Webseite, Chat-GPT macht mich überflüssig, bla bla bla, Alter, das ist, irgendwann ist ja auch mal gut, ja, dann gibt es sicherlich auch wieder irgendwelche Videos, rate ich jetzt, weiß ich nicht, aber könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, wieder Chat-GPT ersetzt mich einen Tag am Arbeitsplatz,
dass die Leute merken, so nach dem Motto Videos und das wird dann so aufgebaut, so nach dem Motto, merken es die Leute, ah, nein, sie merken es nicht, obwohl es im Vorfeld und dann, ich habe niemand gesagt, dass das so ist, ja, ja, ist klar, das wussten im Vorfeld alle, ja, zur höflichen Mail-Generierung, dafür ist es gut, dafür benutze ich es auch, also ich benutze das, das ist tatsächlich sehr praktisch, ich benutze das, um auf E-Mails zu antworten oder ich benutze das auch ganz gerne, zum Beispiel, wenn ich an die Personalabteilung bei mir, beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber schreiben muss,
dann schaue ich dann auch in Chat-GPT rein, so nach dem Motto, äh, frag mal, wann, wann die endlich mein Zeugnis fertig haben und das aber in nett, dann, äh, sehr geehrte, da kann man auch die Frau, Frau von der Personalabteilung reinschreiben, sehr geehrte Frau XY, äh, ich melde mich bezüglich das bla bla bla bla bla, so, das Chat-GPT schwafelt dir dann eine halbe Seite voll und dann hast du nett gefragt, wann kriegen die endlich mal mein Zeugnis fertig.
Ey, übrigens, ich habe gehört, mein Zeugnis ist jetzt fertig.
Tatsächlich, kann ich, kann ich nächste Woche abholen, dann brauche ich nur noch, ich meine, die hatten jetzt, die, guck mal, Leute, die hatten nur drei Monate Zeit, das Zeugnis zu schreiben, da kann es schon mal ein bisschen dauern, das, das, das kann, das muss erst am letzten Arbeitstag fertig werden, letzte, nächste Woche Mittwoch ist mein letzter Arbeitstag hier, da, und genau da, da ist es fertig.
Stripes, die sind verpflichtet.
Die sind verpflichtet, dir eins auszustellen.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie Probleme hast, dass der neue Arbeitgeber sagt, du darfst da nur mit Zeugnis anfangen, dann kannst du die sogar verklagen, da müssen sie dir dann für Dienstausfall bezahlen.
Wenn dir natürlich kein Schaden entstanden ist, ist schwierig da, äh, aber, ähm, also sie sind verpflichtet, die müssen das, sind da gesetzlich dazu verdonnert.
Baldios, dankeschön für den Sub, massive Subscriptions heute wieder.
Nice.
Das kann auch, vor allem kann das nicht sein.
Warum braucht ein Arbeitgeber länger, als du noch da bist, um den Zeugnis auszustellen?
Das ist mit nem, das ist mit nem Zeugnisgenerator in der Viertelstunde passiert und danach noch ein bisschen schön machen und gut ist.
Die können sogar Chat-GPT fragen.
Das weiß ich gar nicht, ne, ich glaube nicht.
Man hat, man hat, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Man hat den Anspruch darauf, dass...
dass die das bis zum Ausscheiden aus dem Betrieb ausgestellt haben müssen.
Die müssen das, die sind verpflichtet.
Also du musst das noch nicht mal anfordern.
Die müssen dir das ausstellen, von sich aus.
Vielleicht verjährt das irgendwann, ja, okay.
Aber spätestens, wenn du nachgefragt hast und sie es nicht hingekriegt haben.
Du hast einen Zeugnisgenerator für zwei Firmen.
Moment, es gibt wirklich welche, die kaufen sich sowas noch mit Eigenentwicklung?
Ich meine, sowas gibt es doch schon zu hundert, tausendfach.
Naja, dafür gibt es ja Zeugnisgeneratoren.
Die schreiben der Personalabteilung fix und fertig so ein Zeugnis.
Du schreibst da Stichworte rein und das macht dann in Zeugnisspeak das raus.
Im Zweifelsfall kannst du sogar Chat-GPT mittlerweile fragen,
die wahrscheinlich noch ganz gute Arbeitszeugnisse erstellen kann.
Das würde mich nicht wundern.
Ich glaube, für sowas ist Chat-GPT wirklich ganz nice.
Wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte, die Personalabteilung macht es absichtlich nicht in Chat-GPT,
weil sie dann vielleicht feststellen, wie useless das ist.
Und manche, nicht alle, es gibt ja durchaus fähige Leute in der Personalabteilung,
da war ich auch sehr überrascht von dort, wo ich mich jetzt beworben habe,
dass die Personalabteilung dort sogar Ahnung hat von dem, was sie macht
und hilfreich ist und irgendwie den, soll ich sagen, einen kompetenten Eindruck vermittelt.
Das bin ich von meiner aktuellen Personalabteilung gar nicht gewöhnt gewesen.
Ja, die haben sogar, müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, die haben sogar eine Hotline,
bis 18 Uhr bei der Personalabteilung, wo man anrufen kann, wenn man Fragen hat,
zu seiner Abrechnung, zu irgendwelchen internen Abläufen und sonst was,
kann man bis 18 Uhr bei einer Hotline von der Personalabteilung anrufen,
wo dann immer einer besetzt ist, wo dann immer einer da ist.
Das habe ich so auch noch nirgendwo erlebt.
Mitten in der Nacht, ja, bis 18 Uhr.
Ja, das kriegen die sicherlich gut bezahlt.
Ich muss ja dann auch die ein oder andere Telefonerreichbarkeit haben,
das kriege ich auch äußerst gut vergütet.
Kann man echt nix sagen.
Also bezahlungstechnisch ist in dem neuen Laden wirklich astrein.
Wenn allerdings das mit der Inflationsrate so weitergeht,
dann ist das, wenn sich da die nächsten Jahre dann nix tut, bald normal.
Also vorausgesetzt bei den anderen geht ordentlich was.
Es muss ja theoretisch, dass es gleich bleibt, im Jahr fast 10 Prozent,
das wird im Leben bei vielen Jobs nicht passieren, ja,
es müsste ja fast im Jahr 10 Prozent mehr Geld geben,
dass das sich...
dass das sich aktuell halbwegs plus minus null ausgeht.
Das werden die wenigsten machen.
Aber kein Wunder, das wird die nächsten Jahre noch witzig werden.
Wir werden sicherlich noch deutlich mehr solche Streiks wie jetzt erleben,
sei es Bahn, sei es Post, sei es Müllabfuhr und sonst was.
Eventuell auch, keine Ahnung, Lehrer, wobei Lehrer, die sind Baramt, die dürfen gar nicht.
Nee, das ist eher nicht realistisch.
Realistisch ist alles, was du dich mit denen drauf einigen kannst.
Und dass sich da jemand zu automatischen, 10-prozentigen Gehaltserhöhungen im Jahr verpflichtet,
das, äh, glaube ich nicht.
Schau dir doch Amazon an mit den... Hä? Verstehe ich nicht. Was? Wie?
Ja, mal gucken, das heißt auch, wenn das jetzt weiter so bleibt,
dann muss das weiter Big Stonks-mäßig steigen, sonst wird das nix.
Wo ist eigentlich, jetzt mal eine ganz blöde Frage nebenbei, ja,
sagt, ich bin ja nicht so der BWL-Kenner, aber mal eine ganz blöde Frage.
Haben wir nicht eigentlich eine europäische Zentralbank?
Wo ist die, was machen die eigentlich gerade?
Ist die nicht dafür da?
Die haben doch damals auch bei Griechenland und so, so Riesenaktionen gemacht,
so nach dem Motto Griechenland, zu viel Schulden, zu viel Inflation und alles
und haben da irgendwie die, irgendwie so die Bankenaufsicht hingeschickt und alles Mögliche.
Man hört erstaunlich wenig von denen gerade, oder? Was machen die denn so?
Sind die nicht eigentlich genau dafür da, dass die Inflation nicht durch die Decke geht?
Und wenn ja, was machen die denn gerade?
Die drucken fleißig Geld, ist das nicht genau das Gegenteil?
Was?
Hast du gesehen, dass Linus Tech Tips Channels gehackt wurden? Was? Er auch? Na gut.
Das kann ich, das kann ich sogar nachvollziehen, bei ihm haben ja mehrere Leute Zugriff drauf und wenn dann einer seinen PC nicht richtig sichert, ist,
ist, Gachirol in den Account direkt.
Was ich nicht so ganz verstehe ist, warum YouTube es nicht schafft, guck mal, es wurden so viele,
der Emcore, das war einer der ersten, den ich kenne, den es da getroffen hat.
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum YouTube nicht dagegen was macht.
Ne, ich klicke nicht irgendwelche random Domains an.
Also, der Emcore war einer der ersten, das haben sie ja bei mir auch probiert,
das ist garantiert so einer der Mails, die ich auch bekommen habe, wo dann irgendwelche,
äh,
.NET-Programme in .NET-Programme drin sind, ja.
So, zumindest, ich find's, ich find's merkwürdig, dass da YouTube nicht was dagegen macht.
Ich meine, es ist auf den ersten Blick erstmal vielleicht schwierig, dagegen was zu machen, weil,
weil, muss man ja sagen, wenn der Rechner übernommen wurde und der Rechner quasi ferngesteuert wird,
dann bleibt die IP gleich, die Session-Cookies gleich und alles.
Wenn das allerdings die gleichen Session-Cookies sind,
die geklaut werden und von einer anderen Absender-IP kommen,
dann könnte man einfach mal eine neue Passwort-Eingabe fordern oder alternativ müsste man insgesamt,
ja,
oder müsste insgesamt restriktiver sein,
aber zumindest müsste YouTube sich dem Problem annehmen, ja.
Also, müsste, müsste öfters Authentifizierung fordern oder aber ich weiß nicht, was man da noch gut,
ähm,
was man da, ähm,
was man da, was man da wirklich gut dagegen machen kann.
Ich meine, Rechner-Fernsteuern hast du natürlich verloren.
Wenn du wirklich dir irgendeinen Trojaner eingefangen hast und jemand kann deinen Rechner fernsteuern,
dass du quasi direkt den gleichen Browser benutzen kannst, wo du eingeloggt bist,
gut, dann ist es ja für den Service dahinter nicht mehr zu unterscheiden,
ob der rechtmäßige Owner jetzt klickt
oder ob das in irgendeiner Art und Weise überfern- gesteuert ist.
Wenn die Session-Cookies abgegriffen werden und das Ding auf einmal mit den gleichen Session-Cookies von einer anderen IP kommt,
dann würde ich mir tatsächlich mal Gedanken machen, klar, dann hast du auch wieder Probleme,
äh, wenn du, äh, mobilfunktechnisch vielleicht unterwegs bist, was auch immer, das ist egal,
das könnte man mit der App irgendwie noch, noch anders handhaben.
Ja, genau, und spätestens, und spätestens, ohne Scheiß, spätestens bei sowas, bei,
ja, das ist, das musste, gut, du könntest ja ein Opt-Out machen, du könntest ja ein Opt-Out machen,
wenn die Leute das wirklich machen wollen.
Mach ein Opt-Out oder ein Opt-In.
Ich würde es auf jeden Fall angeben.
Ich würde es auf jeden Fall aktivieren und ich glaube, jeder größere Channel-Besitzer würde es auf jeden Fall, ähm, auf, auf jeden Fall aktivieren.
Und zwar, dass du zumindest mal, nee, das ist überhaupt nicht, das andere IP ist überhaupt nicht problematisch.
Wann ändert sich denn mal deine IP daheim am DSL-Anschluss?
Einmal am Tag am DSL-Anschluss, bei Kabel und bei anderem viel seltener, ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
So, und ich würde auf jeden Fall, jeder größere Channel-Besitzer würde, würde wahrscheinlich, würde wahrscheinlich Opt-In dafür machen,
dass zumindest mal Abfragen kommen, bei, sobald du in die Settings reingehst, quasi anklicken der Channel-Settings,
einmal Bitte, Passwort und Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Du gehst so gut wie nie in die Channel-Settings rein, also in die richtigen Channel-Settings.
Nicht in den YouTube-Video-Editor, in die Channel-Settings.
Genau, genau, richtig. Das ist eigentlich, genau das.
Bei, genau so denke ich mir das auch.
Bei GitHub musst du nämlich auch beim Löschen eines Repos SMS hin.
Oder SMS, äh.
Bestätigung angeben oder App, App-Code eingeben, sowas.
Genau das könnten die auch machen und ich verstehe nicht, warum YouTube das seit über zwei Jahren,
ich meine, das hat, das hat vor zwei Jahren oder so angefangen, nicht auf die Reihe bekommt.
Wie kann das eigentlich sein?
Wie, wie, wie kann man da YouTube, äh, wie kann man beziehungsweise Google da noch trauen,
Security-technisch was auf die Reihe zu kriegen?
Das, das sollte doch für YouTube, oder besser gesagt für Google sollte das doch überhaupt kein großartiges Problem sein.
Ja.
Zumindest wenn man in die Channel-Settings reingeht.
Von einer bisher nicht bekannten IP, das, zumindest dann, könnte man nochmal nachfragen.
Eventuell bringt das ihnen nichts, das bringt ihnen sehr viel.
Was meint ihr denn, kommt das gut an?
Wenn, wenn die großen Aushängeschilder-Channels einer nach dem anderen jeden Monat mal eins, zwei große Channels übernommen werden von irgendwelchen Krypto-Scammern?
Also sie sollten da großes Interesse dran haben.
Ist es nicht sogar so, dass bei einigen Vodafone-Anschlüssen, dass mehrfache Anschlüsse selber IP haben?
Doch, doch, das ist so.
DS-Line.
Aber selbst dann, ähm, dass sie den gleichen, die gleiche Absender-IP haben, das wäre dann umgedreht.
Ja.
Dass dann mehrere Leute die gleiche IP haben, nicht IP-Wechsel.
Das kann schon passieren, aber da müsste der Scammer nen, nen Vodafone-Anschluss haben, der zufälligerweise beim gleichen Endpunkt rauskommt.
Das ist ja unwahrscheinlich.
Außerdem würde ich generell sagen, bei, beim, beim Betreten der Channel-Settings, also der richtig, der richtigen Channel-Settings,
einfach nochmal zwei Faktor-Identifizierung fordern und gut ist.
Und das, und das alle, alle, äh, Viertelstunde.
Reicht doch, du musst ja da nie was machen normalerweise drin.
Das juckt die einfach nicht, das juckt die bestimmt.
Das juckt die bestimmt.
Guck mal, da sind riesen Channel, die da teilweise übernommen werden und Krypto-Scam, was, was, ähm, also, also die Erklärung, dass es sie nicht juckt und sie deswegen nix dagegen machen, das, äh, glaub ich nicht.
Das ist mir zu, zu simpel.
YouTube ist wahrscheinlich nicht in der Lage, sich was auszudenken, was sich gut in ihre Infrastruktur integrieren lässt, mit vertretbarem Aufwand.
Und man hört's ja immer öfters, dass Google mittlerweile ein so großer, komplexer Laden ist, dass sie sich gegenseitig behindern.
Und dass neue Features teilweise Wochen, Monate, Jahre brauchen, wenn sie überhaupt kommen.
Und, ähm.
Das durch so viele Stufen durch muss, dass die alles andere als agil sind.
Nee, genau, die, die, jeder Channel nennt sich zufälligerweise was mit, mit Tesla und Elon Musk.
Mach ich auch immer.
Ich, ich, ich, ich geh jetzt, ich geh jetzt auch auf YouTube und benenn' meinen Channel einfach in Tesla und Elon Musk, ähm, Krypto um.
Und das ganz legit.
Ich wollte schon immer, dass mein Channel Tesla, Elon Musk, Krypto heißt.
Leute, es wird mal wieder Zeit für ein neues Video, oder?
Es, es wird mal wieder Zeit für ein neues Video, oder?
Es, es wird, es wird übrigens langsam wirklich ernst, was den, was den neuen Job angeht.
Achso, ja, tatsächlich.
Äh, dritter, vierter, erster Arbeitstag.
Ich bin wirklich aufgeregt schon so ein bisschen, wie das ist.
Ich freu mich aber auch drauf, dass ich, dass ich so den aktuellen Laden jetzt los bin und, und neue Sachen.
Jaja, das ist, das ist bescheuert, dass Windows das nicht mehr anzeigt.
Kann man, hab ich das eigentlich schon eingestellt?
Ja, ich hab, guck mal, ich hab eingestellt, dass der bekannte Dateiänderung, Änderung anzeigt.
Das ist auch bescheuert.
Man muss sagen, diesen Scam mit Dateiänderung, mit Dateiänderung gibt es seit 20 Jahren.
Dass es immer noch geht, ist lächerlich, ja.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum die den Default nicht umstellen.
Vielleicht, weil dann die Oma verwirrt ist, wenn die in ihre, in ihre Dokumente oder in ihre Downloads reinguckt und sagt,
Höh, warum heißen die Dateien auf einmal alle E, X, E und, und J, was soll das, JPL?
Ähm, und, und ISO und was ist denn da los? Und JPG?
Im Video geht's um was anderes.
Hups, das wollte ich jetzt gar nicht anklingen.
Okay.
Dann gucken wir uns das jetzt an, weil der Chat das empfohlen hat.
Wenn der Chat das empfiehlt, muss das pfeifen.
Warte, ich hab ein Problem.
Wo ist meine Playlist mit dem, ah, hier war die Playlist an.
Es ist, es ist zu viel, ich hab zu viel, zu viel, zu viel Tabs offen.
Moment.
So.
Alter, gucken wir uns das, gucken wir uns das jetzt tatsächlich an.
This insane Virus, okay, insane.
Wo der, okay, auf geht's.
This Word Document File.
Nee, das ist kein Word Document, das ist ein Screensaver, der, ähm, ein Bild hat von einem Word Document.
Ich muss mir das Video gar nicht angucken, weil es schon um was geht.
Right here is not actually a Word Document.
Das hat ein, das hat ein Custom Icon, was aussieht wie ein Word Document, aber es ist ein Screensaver.
... Document at all.
And if you clicked it, you would actually be running a potentially malicious document.
You would actually be running a potentially malicious executable file, as you can see in the properties.
And for you computer experts, hold on, because I know you think you know what's going on here.
Okay, ja, ja, ich, ich, ich seh, ich sehke, dass ich know what's going on, aber okay.
But I guarantee you're wrong.
Some of you clever people may be saying, oh, it's obvious, you just have file extensions hidden, so the file must be called test.docx.exe, but the last part isn't showing.
Alright, so, let's go and toggle on file extensions.
And now we can see, ah, wait a minute, why is the file extension still docx?
And where did this exe in the middle of the name come from?
Okay, das ist, das ist, das ist tatsächlich wieder irgendein Windows-Scheiß.
That's what I'll be explaining.
And this is something I very recently found out about myself, and I was shocked, because it's a trick that I legitimately may have fallen for easily, if I ever encountered it.
Ja, aber mal trotzdem, also allein schon, allein schon, wenn da doc, doc...
Wenn da blubblubblub.exe.doc steht, dann würde ich mir auch Gedanken machen, auch wenn es in der falschen Reihenfolge ist, aber irgendwas ist da sass dran.
So, definitely pay attention.
Alright, I'm not gonna hold you in suspense any longer.
This trick uses a special invisible Unicode character called a white2f override, or rtlo character.
Ah!
It basically reverses any text that comes after it.
I'll show you how it works in a minute, but it's used for languages that are read from right to left.
And that lets you do some pretty funky stuff when it comes to file names and text in general.
Let me show you an example.
To use this character, we can open the character...
Ja gut, da hätte ich, wenn ich ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht hätte, hätte ich da wahrscheinlich auch drauf kommen können.
Ja, das macht, das macht ja durchaus Sinn.
...character map program that is built into Windows.
And then in the box that says go to Unicode...
Ja, das ist in Dateinamen erlaubt, es ist halt wieder...
Was heißt erlaubt?
Es ist nicht explizit erlaubt, es ist halt nicht verboten in Dateinamen.
Es ist halt einfach jedes Unicode Zeichen, beziehungsweise jedes...
Ja, wie auch immer intern Windows Unicode repräsentiert, UTF-8, keine Ahnung, Zeichen erlaubt.
Warum das nicht auf darstellbare ASCII Zeichen limitiert ist?
Naja, weil die China-Chinesen beispielsweise auch, oder die Russen beispielsweise auch...
...Windows verwenden.
...this character, which is...
Aber man könnte, aber man könnte es wahrscheinlich explizit verbieten im Dateinamen.
Dann müsste man sich allerdings hinsetzen und Schritt halten mit dem Unicode-Standard.
Beim Einführen solcher Zeichen, aber das könnte man ja von Microsoft eigentlich erwarten, dass sie das hinbekommen.
...02e.
And you'll see immediately that it jumped to it and at the bottom left it has been identified as the right-to-left override.
Then we just hit select, then copy.
And it is now in the clipboard.
I should point out though that there are several Unicode characters that cause this behavior.
And I'll just put all the codes of the ones I'm aware of here.
Now let's open Notepad and see how this works.
So first I can just type without the special character.
It works as expected.
But let's go to a new line and I'll paste the character.
And it looks like nothing is there, but let's try typing out...
Chat, chat, chat, chat, chat, chat.
Schwangere Frau Emoji is out.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Schwangere Mann Emoji is the way to go heutzutage.
Und wenn ihr mir nicht glaubt, das gibt es wirklich.
Regnant Man Emoji.
Das gibt es wirklich.
Das wurde eingeführt, glaube ich, mit dem vorletzten, mit dem letzten oder dem vorletzten Unicode Update.
Aber es unterstützen nicht alle.
Es unterstützen nicht alle.
Also es gibt durchaus, ja, es gibt durchaus Emoji Fonts, die es noch nicht können.
Aber die meisten können es mittlerweile.
Ehrlich gesagt, warum...
Hätten sie den Bauch ein bisschen, noch ein bisschen nach oben gemacht,
dann hätte man es einfach Fat Man oder sowas nennen können.
As you can see, the most recent character you type actually gets put on the left.
The letter order is reversed.
Though when the text is right justified like this, you may find it a little bit easier to understand and see how it works.
But now let's see what happens if I type something normally first and then paste the character.
Now everything we type is still reversed, but only...
Man könnte diese Charakter wirklich verbieten im Dateinamen.
Das ist eigentlich kein Ding.
Weil selbst, sagen wir mal, die Araber-Order, die ansonsten von rechts nach links schreiben,
das könntest du ja anhand des Language Settings vom Betriebssystem festmachen.
Das muss ja nicht wirklich anhand der Datei, des Dateinamens festgemacht werden.
Starting at the point that I pasted the RTLO character.
So all very cool, but here's the key.
Even though to the user the text is displayed in reverse,
to the computer in the background the text is still interpreted from left to right.
For example, if we go to save this text file and encode it with a limited character set
that does not include the RTLO character, such as ANSI,
first you'll see it gives a warning that there is a Unicode character that will be lost
and if we hit OK, now that RTLO character is replaced with a question mark.
Okay, hab ich kapiert, leuchtet ein.
In the order icon, I'll get to that, hold on.
Ja gut, dass es ein Custom-Icon ist, das war ja bei vielen Scams schon so.
... still had a Word-Document-Icon, I'll get to that, hold on.
So let's see what was going on with that first example file I showed you.
This time let's go into the command prompt,
and in the directory with that file we can use the dir-Command to list all the files.
And now we can see what was actually going on.
The RTLO character is just shown as a question mark,
and we can see the real file name is test.xcod.exe.
So if I were to actually type that out with the RTLO character working, it looks like this.
I should point out though that it's not necessary for there to be a second period here,
I just put it there to make it easier to see the real file extension.
In the real world it could look just like this, a weird file name with a normal looking extension.
And remember, the real file extension will appear reversed.
Ja, da sollte man eigentlich Smart-Screen-Warnungen bekommen, wenn man das ausführt.
Mal gucken, was sie dagegen machen.
... appear reversed, but that isn't as obvious here, since exe is the same forward and backward.
By the way, one thing to note is that to get the command prompt to show it like this, as a question mark,
you'll probably have to first change the command prompt to Legacy Mode in the settings
to limit the character set, otherwise it won't show as a question mark, but still might reverse the text.
Also, even though all these examples are...
80 Euro ist tatsächlich noch günstig aktuell, aber es ist viel zu teuer, das ist doppelte von dem, was er normalerweise kosten sollte.
... exe-Files, it isn't just limited to that.
This trick has been used in several real malware campaigns, sometimes with other file types,
such as .scr files, which are actually...
Ja, das kenne ich mit Screensaver.
... Screensaver files that can be exploited as malware, or also...
So war das bei mir, so haben sie es bei mir probiert.
... VBS scripts.
Now, like I mentioned before, you may have noticed that the icon on this file is like a Word document,
even though it's actually an executable file.
And that's because it's actually relatively simple to change the file icon of many different file types to whatever you want.
I won't get into all that for the sake of time, but you can see here,
I changed this exe-File icon to be an Xbox controller, just as an example.
But you can see how this could be used to not just spoof Word document files, but pretty much anything.
It could be a fake...
Da muss Microsoft aber echt was dagegen machen.
Also, ich mein, sollen sie sich halt was ausdenken.
Die können Datei, die können, die können die Datei...
Sie könnten, sie könnten das ordentlich machen und diesen ganzen Shit mit Dateiendungen wegschmeißen, ja?
Das macht Linux beispielsweise viel besser.
Aber gut, da gibt es bestimmt auch Probleme, ja?
Da kann man bestimmt auch was tricksen.
Also, Dateiendungen an sich ist schon mal bescheuert, so.
Dass Dateiendungen standardmäßig versteckt sind, ist bescheuert.
Also, Microsoft könnte sicherlich vieles dagegen machen.
Es ist wahrscheinlich ähnlich bei Microsoft wie bei Google mit ihren gehackten Accounts,
beziehungsweise bei YouTube mit den übernommenen Session-Cookies dann.
Die wissen nicht so genau, was sie, was sie machen sollen.
Oder brauchen zu lang mit allem.
Image-Extension, like JPEG, with an image icon, a PDF, whatever.
At this point, let's go over some ways you can spot this trick, if you ever happen to come across it.
First, I still recommend you enable file extensions in Windows Explorer.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall.
Which is off by default.
A malicious file may put a fake file extension without even using the RTLO character, but if you don't have...
Übrigens, soll ich euch den ultimativen Security-Hacker nennen?
...verraten, wie sowas schon zu 99% auszuschließen ist, einfach eine Linux-VM benutzen, für Interaktionen mit anderen Leuten.
Also, sei es jetzt beispielsweise E-Mail-Anhänge öffnen oder, ja, Discord-Messages oder sowas, wo Leute was wollen, dass man runterlädt.
Wenn man das in einer Linux-VM macht, hat man eigentlich gar keine Probleme zu erwarten.
...extensions showing, you won't see it either way.
Now, with file extensions enabled, you still have to be careful.
Be diligent, for all the reasons we just showed.
And now more than ever, it should be obvious, why it's extremely important to never run or open any kind of suspicious files, no matter how benign they appear.
But at least this way, it'll make...
Ja doch. Einfach eine Linux-VM.
...the trick possible to spot, if you know what to look for.
If the trick is being used, the letters of the real file extension should still appear somewhere in the file name, probably right before the fake file extension.
But for all I know, at this point, there might be other weird Unicode characters I don't know about that could hide other characters, or there might be in the future, so don't take all of this as gospel.
Still, don't run anything suspicious.
Anyway, it's still important to remember a couple things.
First, the real file extension is gonna be in reverse.
With an exe file, like in our examples, that is easy, because it's the same backwards.
But if it's a VBS script, then it would show as SBV.
Also, like I mentioned, I made these examples with an extra period here.
Just to make it easier to see.
Dann suchen sie sich als nächstes extensions aus, die vorwärts und rückwärts gleich klingen.
With file extensions enabled, it might just look like this.
Coq, zum Beispiel.
Also, CoC wär so eine Endung.
Die wär vorwärts und rückwärts gleich.
Exe auch, Exe auch!
So, even though the file name is weird, it wouldn't be so obvious that that's the real file extension.
Die Main-Defense ist Linux-4-Ams benutzen.
Ich auch nicht.
Okay, tja.
Also das meiste davon war klar, aber dass sie tatsächlich jetzt Hidden-Unicode-Characters reinhauen, war mir so noch nicht klar.
Ich meine, logisch, dass es funktioniert, aber daher habe ich jetzt so pauschal nicht dran gedacht.
Hat sich auch mal gelohnt, ja.
Welches Linux könnt ihr für Anfänger als VM auf macOS empfehlen?
Linux Mint? Ubuntu kannst du auch nehmen, Ubuntu ist auch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Wobei ich halt sagen muss, dass Ubuntu in der VM durchaus in Ordnung ist.
In Ordnung läuft, aber was minimalistisch ist, ich persönlich in der VM besser finde.
Es ist auch die Frage, wie gut der Kram in einer ARM-VM läuft, da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, wie gut das geht.
Ich meine, es gibt ja so gut wie alle Linux-Distributionen für ARM, aber keine Ahnung, wie gut das mit Virtualisierung unter macOS jetzt noch funktioniert.
Da bin ich überfragt.
Ja, sowas ähnliches hat er gerade gezeigt.
Dass man irgendwie das...
...ausschalten kann über irgendwelche Special-Optionen.
Keine Ahnung.
Weißt du eigentlich, ob sie mittlerweile die Sicherheitslücke bei Office behoben haben?
Du meinst die Sicherheitslücke?
Die einzige Sicherheitslücke, die es je in Office gegeben hat?
Oder welche Sicherheitslücke?
Okay, was können wir uns als nächstes angucken?
Wir gucken uns als nächstes, das interessiert mich ja nämlich persönlich auch...
...was der Mähroboter ohne Begrenzungstrat macht.
Da bin ich sehr interessiert dran.
Vielleicht...
...wenn das wirklich taugt und wenn er vielleicht einen ähnlich schwierigen Garten hat wie ich.
Was ja schon ein bisschen so aussieht mit dem Baum und den Wurzeln und dem Komposthaufen und allem möglichen.
Er hat wahrscheinlich keinen Teich, wo man das mal ausprobieren könnte.
Wo du letztens ein Video drüber gemacht hast.
Ich habe über eine Office-Sicherheitslücke ein Video gemacht.
Du meinst diese Geschichte mit...
Du meinst das da?
Das da meinst du?
Das war ja nicht wirklich eine Office-Sicherheitslücke.
Das war ein als Office-Dokument getarntes...
Also das ist genau das gleiche, wie die mich versucht haben hier reinzulegen, ja?
Das war ein Screensaver, das war kein Office-Dokument.
Ja?
Da wo wir reingeguckt haben.
Ja.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt das mit dem Mähroboter an.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das überhaupt noch da ist.
Ja.
Das ist auch keine schlechte Idee.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich habe tatsächlich ein Office 365 Abo mittlerweile.
Aber ich benutze das eigentlich so gut wie nicht offline, sondern nur online im Browser.
Ist teilweise doch ganz praktisch.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht.
Wir haben uns drauf verstanden...
Also er hatte irgendwie Probleme mit YouTube.
Anderweitig.
Also nicht das, was wir eben uns angeguckt haben.
Und dann wollten wir das danach machen.
Wir haben nicht mehr miteinander gesprochen in der Zwischenzeit.
Also...
Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich wird sich da auch in der Richtung nichts tun.
Vielleicht können wir noch ein anderes Video machen.
Mal gucken.
Gibt sich ja...
Gibt sich bestimmt was.
Okay.
Also, dann gucken wir uns mal an, was der Mähroboter macht.
Mähroboter ohne Begrenzungsdraht am Limit.
Der Ecovacs Goat G1.
Okay, mal gucken erstmal, was der Kram kostet.
Alter.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
Ja, dafür können die Kinder vom Nachbar das jahrelang machen.
Oh mein Gott, ein bisschen leise.
Wir richten den Ecovacs Goat G1 ein.
Meinen ersten Mähroboter ohne Begrenzungsdraht.
Ich zeige euch den Prozess, wie sich das Ganze zugetragen hat.
Wir hatten jetzt nicht das beste Wetter.
Leute, ich muss einen Mähroboter testen.
Ich kann keinen Schnee gebrauchen.
Also eigentlich hatten wir zwei Tage Zeit, das auszuprobieren.
Okay.
Deswegen hängt das Ergebnis nicht zu hoch.
Es geht vor allem um so einen ersten Eindruck, wie sich das Ganze darstellt.
Und dann...
Zeig her.
Da bin ich gespannt.
In der Zwischenanz habe ich da jetzt irgendwie zumindest Wochen draufgewartet, weil
da zu Hause rumstand.
Aber es musste ja die ganze Zeit noch Schnee fallen.
Der ist heute weggetaucht.
Morgen wird das Wetter wieder schlecht.
Wir haben also einen Tag Zeit auszuprobieren, wie das Leben ohne Begrenzungsdraht ist.
Und das machen wir heute.
Schauen wir uns das mal an, was wir hier haben.
Das ist ein Garten, der erinnert mich ein bisschen an meinen Garten.
Das heißt, das ist auch ein bisschen schwieriges, schwieriges Gelände.
Technologie.
AI Vision.
Ja, ja.
Bla, bla, bla.
AI 3D.
Safer und smoother.
Und intelligenter Gartenpfleger.
Wollen wir doch mal schauen.
Denn dieser Garten braucht auf jeden Fall Keeping.
Das ist mehr hier so ein Moos.
Ja, so sieht das bei mir auch aus.
Es gibt gar nicht so viel zu mieten, aber wir können anfangen.
Und ich bin extra zum neuen Haus gefahren, wo...
...noch absolutes Chaos ist.
Weil hier...
...der Rasen ein bisschen größer ist und ein bisschen mehr Herausforderungen mit sich bringt.
Mit den Bäumen.
Mit irgendwelchen Aussparungen.
Da bin ich gespannt, ob er das hinkriegt.
Wie zum Beispiel diese alten Räder.
Und dann gucken wir mal, wie er sich gleich schlägt.
Hier haben wir so eine Check-Übergabe.
Anleitung zum Auspacken.
Das rausheben.
Dann den Meer rausheben.
Indem wir ihn anfassen und dann hochheben.
Gut.
Dass das drinsteht.
Und dann haben wir noch die Bodenplatte für die Ladestation.
Wir haben eine Accessory-Box.
Die war in der Anleitung gar nicht drin.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich die hier rausheben soll.
Dann haben wir hier die Station.
Oh, mit Reinigung.
Aha.
Da ist auch so ein Gespenst hier versteckt.
Ist ja so groß wie unser anderer Garten.
Ich kann denn gestern eigentlich noch dick Schnee gelegen haben.
Und jetzt schwitze ich hier unter unserer komischen Doppelsteg-Brutstelle.
Ich guck erst mal in die riesige Anleitung.
Wir sollen die Station auf ein flaches Gelände ohne Steigerung machen.
So.
Ohne Steigerung und Steine stellen.
Zählen Waschbetonplatten als Steine?
Ich stell die einfach hier drauf.
Und WiFi-Signal ist auch ein Problem, weil wir hier noch kein Internet haben.
Aber ich hab was vorbereitet.
Eco-Werks hat zwar so ein Connection-Modul mitgeschickt.
Das wird irgendwo in den Meer gebaut und hat hier offenbar so einen SIM-Karten-Slot.
Aber das braucht man ja nur, wenn man große Gärten hat.
Ich will ja für euch testen, wie das realistisch passiert.
Wenn man irgendwie genug WLAN in der Nähe hat.
Also hab ich mir irgendwie so einen temporären WLAN-Access-Point mit LTE-Kram besorgt.
Und dann haben wir hier gleich sowas ähnliches wie stationäres Internet.
Naja, gut.
WLAN werde ich da hinten wahrscheinlich im Garten...
Wobei, doch, kriege ich da auch irgendwie hin, wenn's sein muss.
Ich weiß, es gibt jetzt 5G-Kram, aber es geht ja um Mähroboter.
Da, wo ich herkomme, blinkt mir ein gutes Zeichen.
Nicht so gut, ne?
Naja.
Äh...
Wird schon, ne?
Ich würde sagen, jetzt ist das Wichtigste, das noch professionell zu installieren.
So, siehste.
Stellen wir hier hin.
Das ist möglichst dicht an der Züge.
Aber wenn du dafür im gesamten Garten komplette WLAN-Abdeckung brauchst, ist schon mal nicht so einfach, ne?
Obwohl das Handy...
Ich habe im Garten, am Eingang habe ich WLAN, ansonsten nirgendwo.
Ich meine, wozu braucht man im Garten auch WLAN?
Da hast du dein Handy dabei und das hat Mobilfunk...
Ein Wunderwerk der Technik.
Äh, zurück zum Mähroboter.
Ich würde sagen, wir bauen den mal auf.
Ein...
Ihr wisst schon.
Bitte App benutzen.
So, ich habe den Roboter eingeschaltet.
Achso.
Hast du 5G im Garten?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Erstens, zweitens...
Achso, was sind die erweiterten Funktionen, die ich nur mit WLAN bekomme?
Ich kann nicht auf Audio und Video zugreifen, keine Firmware-Updates...
Ach, Audio, Video, man kann dem zugucken, wie er mäht.
Oh, das ist ja geil, Alter.
Da kann ich dem Mähroboter durch die Kamera zugucken, wie er mäht.
Das ist das...
Okay, das ist zwar auf den ersten Blick useless, aber auf dem zweiten ist das ein sehr nices
Gimmick und Spiel-Feature.
Man könnte theoretisch sogar damit in den Garten fahren, um kurz was zu gucken.
Und kein Realtime-Positioning.
Naja, wir haben ja das WLAN hier.
Ich würde sagen, wenn sie den schon Goat nennen, nennen wir den auch Ziege.
Eine Rakete...
Hab ich gedacht, das ist der greatest of all time.
Roboter.
In der Zwischenzeit...
Geht das über die China-Chinesen-Cloud?
Ist es schon?
Das ist alles hier Metall?
Also, es macht einen hochwertigen Eindruck.
Ja, es macht trotzdem einen hochwertigen Eindruck.
Gut, ich meine 1600 Euro, da ist auch ein bisschen was für drin.
Was kostet so ein normaler Rasenmäher? 150?
Das fühlt sich alles auf jeden Fall...
Was kostet ein normaler Rasenmäher?
Rasen...
Mäher...
Ja.
Geht von billig bis ein bisschen teurer.
Das sieht auf jeden Fall sehr wertig an.
So, hier vorne haben wir die Kamera.
Hier haben wir das Kamera-Cover, keine Ahnung.
Und unten drunter...
... auf dem Boden.
Achten Sie auf den Signalempfänger und die obere Kamera Ihres Goats.
Warum ist das immer das gleiche Text-to-Speech?
Das ist das gleiche Text-to-Speech, wie man Staubsauger auch hat.
Ist das das China-Chinesen-Text-to-Speech?
Was die alle benutzen in der gleichen Firmware, oder?
So, da haben wir ein Dreifachmesser, zwei Lenkräder vorne, hinten die Antriebsräder
mit den dicken Spikes und ein Fach für den Akku.
Soweit.
Erstmal nichts Außergewöhnliches, würde ich sagen.
So, jetzt müssen wir den Pin eingeben, weil ich den hoch...
Ähm...
Das heißt, dieser Mähroboter, der mäht ab und lässt das Zeug liegen, gell?
Was im Endeffekt heißt, du musst das wirklich regelmäßig machen, dass das schön kurz
bleibt?
Also, am besten wäre, einmal initial von Hand alles abmähen, sodass es schön kurz
ist, und dann kurz halten lassen vom Mähroboter.
Noch viel interessanter, Ecovacs Home Assistant Integration.
Goat.
Weiß ich nicht, ob es da...
Integrations gibt.
Das ist die Frage.
Also, wenn es sich nicht gescheit in die Heimautomatisierung integrieren lässt, ist ja schon mal doof.
Standardmodus.
Willkommen.
Legen Sie das Zubehör für die Installation auf einen ebenen Boden.
Der wird ja wohl eben genug sein.
Die werden wahrscheinlich in den Boden gelegt.
Was ist das?
Ah, das sind so Begrenzungsdinger.
Sind die Batterien rein?
Sind das...
Wahrscheinlich sind das für...
Für Begrenzung irgendwie, so Stangen.
Vielleicht.
Schrauben und Ersatzklingen.
Alles da.
Montieren Sie die Ladestation.
Das stecken wir da drauf.
Machen die Klappe auf.
Stecken den da rein.
Der kann nicht so schwer sein.
Ja, okay.
Wasserdicht.
24-Volt-Anschluss, oder was das ist.
So.
Setzen Sie das Netzkabel ein.
Das kriegen wir auch hin.
Wo ist das?
Da ist es.
Wo ist denn eine Stelle mit starkem Netzwerksignal im Garten?
Ich würde sagen, hier.
Das Gras um die Station ist weniger als sechs Zentimeter hoch.
Ah, interessant, interessant.
Ich habe den Mähroboter birnes Großvaters – Das war eine Husqverna, von 2017.
Letztes Jahr auf WLAN und Wettersteuerung per Internet umgebaut.
Größeren Akku gab es auch.
Das Addon hieß Robonıkt.
R strikt?
und ist eine
Eigenentwicklung eines KMU. Was ist denn ein KMU?
Jetzt wird es spannend.
Schrauben Sie die Navigation. Kleinunternehmen. Ach so.
Die haben was eigenes entwickelt.
Naja, wenn das Ding schon von Haus aus
damit kommt, ist es natürlich nice.
Aber deiner hat bestimmt noch
Drähte, die man legen muss.
Ich finde das hier eigentlich ganz charmant,
dass man keine Begrenzungsträte machen muss.
Navigationssender auf.
Navigationssender, okay.
Entfernen Sie das Schutzmaterial im Hindern und setzen Sie
an drei Trockenbatterien ein.
Moment, Batterien?
Oh ne, please.
Och ne.
Laden die sich irgendwie automatisch auf?
Ich hab keinen Bock,
dass ich dann laufend rausgehen muss und die Batterien
in den Sendern, das ist doch kacke.
Sehen Sie,
sind das hier die Sender
und das hier sind nur Hülsen,
um die im Boden zu halten.
Die Batterien sind doch wahrscheinlich laufend leer.
Ich mein,
würden die sich die Dinger wenigstens selbst aufladen,
dann wäre das ja noch
Wasser.
Schutzmaterial.
So, das Ding hab ich jetzt.
Sieht jetzt ein bisschen anders aus als auf der Zeichnung.
Es hat gepiepst.
Das machen wir jetzt mit den anderen auch nochmal.
Am liebsten würde ich den ganzen Tag nur diese Sender zusammenschrauben.
Montieren Sie den Sender in den Navigationsbaken Sockel.
Hör gut.
Wenn du das möchtest, hier bist du in der Navigation.
Das sind natürlich schon ganz schöne.
Navigationsbakensockel.
Ja.
Das ist schon ordentliches Ding.
So.
Fügen Sie mindestens zwei Navigationssender hinzu.
Scannen Sie den QR-Code.
Ja, und jetzt sag mir mal, was das für ein Garten ist.
Moment, was haben wir für Garten zur Auswahl?
Ja.
Einzelgarten, L-förmiger Garten, O-förmiger Garten.
Äh.
Moment, mein Garten sieht
weder so noch,
so noch,
so, noch so aus.
Ach du Kacke.
Also ohne Scheiß, mein Garten ist
deutlich länglicher
als
breit.
Und da steht eine Hütte drauf und ein paar
wo der Garten im Vergleich zum Haus
ist. Ja, das Haus,
ich würde das eh nicht ans Haus stellen,
ja, sondern
da muss er ja durch eine
Tür durch. Ich würde den schon
in Garten stellen
auf irgendwas Flaches zum Parken.
Dann ist der Garten
nicht U-förmig.
Okay, nehmen wir mal die Hütte.
Die Hütte wäre dann
in der hinteren Hälfte wäre die Hütte.
Also mein Garten sieht
ungefähr so aus.
Kann man die Size ein bisschen dicker machen?
Also mein Garten
ist ungefähr
ein bisschen, bisschen schräg.
So würde ich sagen.
Hier ist eine Hütte.
Und hier vorne ist der Eingang.
Ich meine, Leute,
warum male ich euch das überhaupt auf?
Endlich, endlich hat dieses Video
mal einen Sinn.
Endlich hat dieses Video mal einen Sinn.
Als Schnellstells-Video, hier sieht man es doch.
So, das ist ja nicht der Garten.
So, hier ist der Garteneingang.
Das sieht mittlerweile nicht mal ganz so aus.
Hier erkennt man es.
Hier ist der Garteneingang.
Also ich würde hier neben, guck mal,
hier neben ist ja so ein Gebäude noch.
Da würde ich ein Kabel rausmachen in den Garten,
um das anzuschließen, das Teil.
So, und dann, guck mal, also hier ist ein Fischteich.
Hier sind zwei Bäume.
Und hier hinten ist eine Hütte.
Also der Garten ist eher, der ist ein bisschen schräg
und länglich.
Jaja, Max, ist gut.
Viel sieht man hier nicht in dem Video, aber
ja.
Also hier,
da hat es halt hier,
der Mähroboter, wenn er hier dran hängen bleibt,
schon mal verkackt.
Einfach zwei Millionen Klicks, Leute.
Ich habe bis heute keine Ahnung, warum.
Ja, guck, hier hinten ist die Hütte.
Aber das reicht, der muss nur bis zur Hütte mähen.
Dahinter muss der gar nicht mähen.
Guck mal, da seht ihr den entwarnten Ofen,
den mein Opa da hinten gebaut hat.
Und was heißt Ofen?
Man kann doch hier irgendwie
den Kamin,
den er da gebaut hat.
Ja, hier hinten muss der eigentlich gar nicht hin.
Ja gut, so sieht er gar,
so sieht der Garten aus, also da hat er schon einiges zu tun.
Ja, und jetzt sag mir mal, was das für ein Garten ist.
So.
Wir haben hier so eine Fläche.
Das ist ja schon erstmal ein einzelner Garten, ne?
Ja.
Da hinten
würde ich den erstmal gar nicht hinlassen, da war Beet.
Ja, obwohl, warum eigentlich nicht, ne?
Ich muss ja gleich auf jeden Fall noch so ein bisschen Kram aufheben,
der ja noch auf dem Rasen liegt.
Aber ich würde sagen, wir machen das so.
Installieren Sie die Navigation,
bei dem alle Seiten kürzer
als 45 Meter sind.
Das ist hier gegeben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das kürzer als 45 Meter ist.
Gut.
Im Zweifel brauche ich mehr Navigationssender.
Ich habe einen rechteckigen Garten.
Ja, das ist ja nicht so.
Das ist gar keine Arbeit,
im Vergleich zum Drahtverlegen.
Und man hat natürlich diese Leuchttürme im Garten stehen.
Ja, das würde mich nicht sonderlich stören.
Das ist der Kompromiss.
Ja, ja.
Okay, er ist nicht angedockt.
Strom auf der Steckdose 11.
Bereiten Sie sich vor.
Was muss ich denn, was muss ich denn machen?
Bereiten Sie sich auf die Erstellung der virtuellen Grenze vor.
Das ist bestimmt einfach nur schlecht übersetzt.
Bereiten Sie sich vor.
Brace yourself.
Achtung, gleich wird die virtuelle Grenze angelegt.
Ein Kabel auf dem Weg.
Ja, was soll schon schief gehen?
Die Bluetooth-Verbindung.
Aha.
Ja.
Und wo fährst du jetzt lang?
Halten Sie den Joystick gedrückt, um Ihren Go zu steuern.
Eine Jugend voller Videospieler.
Ah, das heißt, man könnte auch ohne Navigationssender von Hand mähen.
Wenn man will, wenn man Bock drauf hat, könnte man von Hand mähen.
Auf diesen Moment vorbereitet.
Halt mit Kamera.
Jetzt finden wir gleich mal seine Geländegängigkeit raus.
So, hier musst du ja.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, er hängt.
Oder?
Ja, wahrscheinlich machen wir das dann irgendwann nochmal neu.
Wenn das hier so ein bisschen, vielleicht fräse ich das mal weg.
Leute, das Ding, das Ding versagt in meinem Garten 100 pro.
Das bleibt an der erstbesten Wurzel hängen.
Das geht für so englische, für so englische, also so flach, kurz, ohne Hindernisse funktioniert das.
Twitch-Chat-Integration, Twitch-Plays, Twitch-Plays-Mähroboter.
Das wäre so ein Moosberg.
Moment mal, das war der Chefredakteur vom Wall Street Journal, ne?
Wenn ich hier ein bisschen Eisen...
Das Ding, das Ding hat doch, guck mal, das Ding hat schon Probleme bei den kleinen Huppeln in seinem Garten hier.
...Düngerauslege.
Reduziert sich aber die Biomasse auf dem Planeten um die Hälfte.
Ja gut.
Ladevorgang.
Das ist alles nicht gegeben.
Ich bin mir ja durchaus bewusst, dass ich gerade versuche, alle möglichen Dinge zu machen, die der eigentlich nicht machen können soll oder machen soll.
Und ich mich einfach nicht an alle Vorgaben halte.
Aber das wäre auch langweilig, oder?
Wir versuchen herauszufinden, wo die Grenzen sind.
Mal sehen, wie lange, bis er sich verheddert in dem langen Gras.
Und dann kämpfte ich mich mit ihm zusammen über den Acker.
Vorher hatte ich noch kurz ein paar Ausnahmen für die Bäume und die Steindinge im Garten hinzugefügt.
Und mein erster Eindruck war, der Goat ist relativ groß, aber auch relativ leise.
Also ohne das jetzt irgendwie direkt verglichen zu haben, aber ich würde sagen, akustisch irgendwie auf...
Der müht sich schon ganz schön ab, der Goat, oder?
...Augenhöhe des Gardena Meeres aus dem letzten Jahr.
Und wir haben uns dann eine ganze Weile über das Moosfeld gequält und mir war völlig bewusst, dass er das eigentlich nicht will.
Von wegen Gras und unter sechs Zentimetern.
Das ist ja auch das, was seine Schnitthöhen-Einstellung hergibt.
Und bei mir ist er ja eher sechs Zentimeter ins Moos eingesackt.
Und dann kam obendrauf nochmal die Graslänge.
Und als wir fast fertig waren, fand ich in den Einstellungen dann die Option, dass er ein bisschen weniger genau arbeiten kann.
Und das war mir erstmal grundsätzlich sehr sympathisch.
Und eine Option für längeres Gras.
Und dann stellte ich fest, dass es offenbar gar nicht so sehr das Moos und das Einsinken war,
sondern dass seine Sensoren und Kameras...
...die sich von den langen Halmen und dem Einsinken erschrocken haben.
Seitdem ich die beiden Sachen auf jeden Fall umgestellt habe, fährt er offenbar weniger penibel.
Das ist mir jetzt noch nicht besonders aufgefallen.
Aber er ist auch schneller auf diesem etwas ungeeigneten Untergrund.
Und was natürlich schön ist, ist die Tatsache, dass er durch die Kameras und Sensoren auch Hindernisse erkennen kann und Menschen zum Beispiel ausweichen.
Ich habe hier zum Test mal meine Tochter auf die Gleise gewunden.
Das gibt mir natürlich ein ganz gutes Gefühl.
Wie gut auf deiner Seite das Gefühl ist, wenn dein Mähroboter auf Cloud-Server chinesischer Hersteller...
Ja, weniger.
...angewiesen ist, musst du dir selbst beantworten.
Vor allem Cloud-Server aus dem China-Chinesen Cloud-Server.
Man darf nicht vergessen, das Ding hängt in deinem WLAN und hat eine Kamera und kann Kamerabilder übertragen.
Also, das ist halt so ein Ding.
Das Ding muss ins WLAN.
Warum um alles in der Welt?
Muss das zwangsläufig?
Muss das zwangsläufig über chinesische Cloud-Server gehen?
Das könnte ohne Probleme auch alles lokal funktionieren.
Das ist überhaupt nicht erforderlich.
Das Einzige, wofür ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass es notwendig ist, dass Noobs ihn remote bedienen können, die nicht in der Lage sind sich in VPN einzurichten.
Ist ein Mähroboter mit einem verlegten Kabel ein bisschen unabhängiger auf längere Sicht?
Wobei du in den wenigsten Fällen um eine Hersteller-App rumkommst.
Also du bist immer von dem Hersteller eines Mähroboters auch softwareseitig angewiesen.
Oder zumindest in den meisten Fällen.
Zum eigentlichen Mähen kann ich auch noch gar nicht so viel sagen.
Aber am Ende dreht er so wie meine anderen Mäher auch bisher drei Rasiermesser-Klingen unter seinem Bauch.
Und die Besonderheit beim Goat G1 ist sicherlich die Navigation und das gesamte System an sich.
Und ich kann sagen, bisher klappt das eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass er irgendwann seine Grenzen verlassen hätte, die ich ihm gesteckt habe.
Jedenfalls nicht mit drehenden Klingen.
Um dahin zu kommen ist er schon einmal anders um die Säule rumgefahren.
Also ich sehe jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass der überhaupt was mäht.
Mäht der denn gerade überhaupt?
Aus meiner Sicht erstmal okay.
Und seine Bewegungen auf dem Feld wirken präzise und wiederholbar.
Der Rasen-Champ.
Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass wir hier irgendwie an Genauigkeit oder an Schutz von Beeten oder so irgendwas unbedingt direkt vermissen würden.
Dadurch, dass hier kein Kabel eingebuddelt ist.
Und bei den ersten paar Runden auf unserem Acker ist er auch ein paarmal stecken geblieben.
Aber was ich jetzt wirklich nicht als Vorwurf an diesem Meer sehen würde.
Das ist halt seit, weiß ich nicht, anderthalb Jahren verwilderte Fläche.
Guck mal, die Reifen ja.
Das Ding kann vier-, fünfmal fahren.
Dann ist er so voll wahrscheinlich mit Dreck an den Reifen, dass du ihn wieder sauber machen musst.
In den letzten Runden hat es immer tadellos funktioniert, dass er problemlos gemäht hat und den Weg nach Hause gefunden.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er langsam die Moosberge abgetragen hat.
Oder versteht, von welcher Seite er auf sie drauf fahren muss, um nicht stecken zu bleiben.
Oder er sich auch merkt, wo er stecken geblieben ist und die Bereiche dann anders anfährt.
Was noch ein Ding ist, die App wirkt noch nicht besonders poliert und ist auch noch einigermaßen eingeschränkt.
Mit dem Hinweis, dass ich das ganze vor Release getestet habe.
Und hoffentlich bis zum Erscheinen und bis die ersten von euch den Mähroboter in ihren Gärten haben, noch ein paar der leeren Textfelder gefüllt sind.
Und einige der chinesischen Texte übersetzt werden.
Aber grundsätzlich funktioniert alles.
Aber wie gesagt, hier ist noch eine ganze Menge Luft.
Ich habe zum Beispiel auch keine Möglichkeit gefunden, die Karte zu bearbeiten.
Ich kann sie speichern, ich kann sie neu laden.
Aber wenn ich irgendwas ändern will, dann muss ich offenbar alles neu abfahren und die Hindernisse neu einlernen.
Nur um vielleicht irgendwo eine Beule auszubügeln, die wir da gemeinsam falsch gelernt haben.
Oder wenn ich irgendwie ein Beet leicht verändere oder so.
Da wäre es natürlich ganz nett, wenn ich einfach...
Irgendwie eine neue Fläche umfahren und die dann als neuen Rand oder sie abziehen könnte von der bisherigen Fläche oder hinzufügen.
Ansonsten kann ich...
Ich glaube, ich bleibe weiterhin bei meinem manuellen Rasenmähen.
Einmal im Jahr, so nach dem Motto.
Oder zweimal im Jahr wird Rasen gemäht.
Vom anderen Ende der Republik, wenn ich will.
Jedenfalls dann, wenn es funktioniert.
Das hat jetzt nicht immer 1a geklappt mit dem Fernzugriff.
Ja, dafür braucht man die China-Chinesen-Surfer.
Aber selbst das würde lokal gehen, wenn die Leute sich ein VPN einrichten könnten.
Aber das verstehe ich, dass die Hersteller das über so einen kleinen Tunnel noch lösen, weil die meisten Leute das ja nicht hinkriegen.
Aber ich finde es halt doof.
Warum muss standardmäßig alles inklusive Bild und so von meinem Garten über China-Chinesen-Server laufen?
Es gibt auch eine Alarmfunktion, die die Kamera und die ganzen Sensoren nutzt, um eine abschreckende Wirkung zu haben.
Sieben Meter um die Station soll sie Menschen erkennen und aufnehmen können.
Und grundsätzlich stimmt das auch.
Also man hört dann diese Ansage.
Sie haben den überwachten Bereich betreten.
Aber mit dem Bildmaterial der Kamera, die in der Station steht und die dann...
Da siehst du ja nur die Füße.
Dadurch auch noch einen verengten Blickwinkel hat.
Darauf wäre meine Ehre.
Okay, da erkennst du wirklich nicht, wer das sein soll.
Erste Gameboy-Kamera damals nicht unbedingt neidisch gewesen.
Also viel Spaß hiermit irgendwie ein Verbrechen aufzuklären.
Aber die wichtige Frage ist ja, was haben wir heute über kabellose Mii-Roboter gelernt?
Die Einrichtung war auf jeden Fall ganz okay.
Selbst die halbfertige App hat mich da ganz gut durchgeleitet.
Die Installation war klar und ich habe recht schnell den Mii-Roboter auf meinen Acker bekommen.
Jedenfalls nachdem wir gemeinsam herausgefunden haben,
wie er die Moosschwelle überwindet.
Um da erstmal wirklich physikalisch drauf zu kommen.
Was mich dann aber doch ein bisschen nervt, sind die Beacons,
die man da irgendwie am Rand der Rasenfläche in den Boden...
Ja vor allem, also die Beacons stören mich weniger,
dass ich da drinnen öfters mal die Batterie wechseln muss.
Das würde mich stören.
Und die Tatsache, dass diese Torpfosten recht präsent sind...
Ach, das würde mich jetzt nicht so stören.
Aber dass man da Batterien drin wechseln muss.
Hätte man da nicht irgendwie noch was mit Solar machen können?
Die Dinger, die müssen ja gar nicht so oft senden.
Die müssen ja nur senden, wenn der Roboter fährt oder so.
Keine Ahnung, das könnte man doch bestimmt schöner machen.
Da helfen die beiliegenden grauen Aufkleber auch nur so mittelfiel.
Aber was mich noch mehr nervt, ist die Tatsache, dass man da drin Batterien wechseln muss.
Die sollen zwar mindestens ein Jahr halten,
aber es ist eben eine Sache, die du managen musst.
Fairerweise ist es auch eine Sache, die ich beim Draht managen musste,
weil ich den ja nicht eingegraben habe.
Und vielleicht das ein oder andere Mal mit dem Spaten durchgehauen.
Auf jeden Fall lässt es sich in der Summe einfach schneller einrichten,
als ein Draht zu verlegen.
Und theoretisch lässt es sich dann auch danach leichter anpassen.
Ich hoffe auf jeden Fall, dass für die begrenzungsdrahtlosen Mähroboter
da softwareseitig noch ein bisschen nachgelegt wird.
Also ich werde auf jeden Fall noch abwarten,
mir sowas in der Richtung zu kaufen.
Das macht jetzt aktuell noch keinen Sinn.
Ich mache eine halbe Stunde,
wird mal zweimal im Jahr Rasen gemäht, das reicht.
Oder naja, eher eine Stunde.
Ist schon ganz schön groß.
Ich schaffe den Garten auch nicht in einem Durchgang.
Das macht der Rasenmäher auch gar nicht mit.
Der ist auf jeden Fall hochwertig verarbeitet.
Aber das ist auch alles für draußen.
Man muss da den Witterungen und den Gezeiten
und weiß was ich, den Gezeiten eigentlich nicht,
der Witterung und den Jahreszeiten standhalten.
Und die Tatsache, dass der in den Einstellungen sagt,
dass wenn du den Regensensor ausschaltest,
der Mäher beschädigt werden könnte.
Was?
Da kann ich nur zu sagen...
Warum gibt es denn einen Knopf zum Ausschalten?
Upsi.
Und zweitens, ich hoffe, dass das nicht so ist.
Denn ich möchte bei einem Mähroboter ja kein Gerät,
was ich irgendwie babysitten muss
oder was ich reinholen muss,
wenn es dann doch mal noch im Frühjahr
einen kalten Tag gibt
oder er im Regen stehen geblieben ist.
Und es ist zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
für mich einfach noch zu früh,
dass ich den Mähroboter einschalten kann.
Das war alles mehr so ein erster Eindruck.
Es ist ein super Gerät zum rumspielen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein super Gerät ist
auf Dauer, um seinen Garten in Schuss zu halten.
Und ich kann sagen,
insgesamt fühlt sich das alles ganz gut an.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
die Navigation mit dieser Art Begrenzung
funktioniert mehr als gut genug.
Er schneidet unser Moos so weit.
Zeitpläne lassen sich gut einstellen.
Schneidet das Moos schweißfrei.
Wie die Winkeleinstellung der Mähbahn,
die er fährt.
Er lässt ein bisschen zu großzügig Bereiche aus.
Wie gesagt,
auch hier ist es ein bisschen zu voreilig zu sagen,
wie sich das dann wirklich in der Praxis darstellt.
Denn wenn er einfach jeden Tag
ein paar kleine andere Bereiche auslässt,
dann wird das egal sein.
Und es ist auch noch Vorab-Software.
Aber ich bin gespannt,
wie er sich dann wirklich im Alltag
über einen längeren Zeitraum in der Praxis schlägt.
Und ich werde auf jeden Fall berichten.
Ich erwarte auch noch
den kabellosen Mäher von Segway
für einen Face-Off.
Aber ich will ihn auch noch ein bisschen
mehr herausfordern,
sodass er um das Haus herum
und bis in den Vorgarten fährt.
Dafür werde ich noch ein paar weitere Beacons besorgen
und in den Boden rammen
und sehen, wie er sich dann schlägt.
Ist der Goat G1
den doch eher etwas höheren
Anschaffungspreis wert?
Den Mehrpreis?
Das ist wie immer schwer pauschal
zu beantworten.
Wie er sich im Dauereinsatz schlägt.
Ich bin nicht überzeugt.
Ich kann mir das Ding nicht kaufen.
Ich gehe zweimal im Jahr
mit dem normalen Rasenmäher durch.
Das ist gut, es reicht.
Okay, jetzt wird es teuer.
Jetzt wird es teuer.
Ach, easy.
Easy money, easy.
Du kriegst ja schon ein Auto für, Mann.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Nice Preis.
Schnapper, ein richtiger Schnapper.
Was?
Off topic, wie kann man Docker Volumes
Backupen ohne Cron?
Mein NAS löscht periodisch Cron-Shops.
Hä?
Das eine hat doch mit dem anderen
jetzt gar nichts zu tun und was, wie, hä?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keinen Schimmer, was dein NAS da macht.
Du kannst eher synchen.
Dein Docker-Verzeichnis irgendwohin.
Gar nichts anderes geht.
AI-Anti-Gene.
So, was haben wir sonst noch?
CT-Stellens?
Gnome-Review?
Nein, nein, das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Job ohne Ausbildung?
Reicht das geil als Straßenreiniger?
Okay.
Chat-GPT-Klon läuft auf lokalem...
auf jedem...
Läuft lokal auf jedem Rechner.
Alpaka-Lama ausprobiert.
Okay, komm.
Ein AI-Video pro Stream
können wir uns geben.
Mehr muss nicht sein.
Docker vs.
Kubernetes.
Was ist besser im Homelab?
Ich würde sagen, es hängt davon ab,
was man machen will.
Das ist so ein Ding, das kann man so pauschal
nicht wirklich sagen.
Lokal auf dem...
Lokal auf der VM oder lokal auf dem Rechner
eindeutig Docker.
Zum Hosten von irgendwelchen Sachen
kann man sich fragen, ob es sinnvoll ist,
Kubernetes zu betreiben lokal.
Ja, aber meistens...
Ja, keine Ahnung, meistens eher nicht.
Spricht nichts dagegen,
das nicht zusammen zu betreiben.
Das sind ja zwei unabhängige Sachen.
Ist nur die Frage, worauf lässt es laufen?
Lässt es auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen
und dann K3S oder sowas drauf?
Kannst du auch Docker-Container drauflaufen lassen
oder auf irgendeiner...
auf irgendeinem Unraid-NAS oder so in einer VM?
Ja, ich auch nicht. Man kann einfach beides
verwenden, da wo es sinnvoll ist.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Kubernetes daheim ist meistens...
Also, ich wüsste persönlich nicht,
für was ich jetzt daheim irgendwie Kubernetes
brauchen würde. Wenn ich jetzt
der Meinung wäre, ich möchte
lokale Services
so laufen haben,
dass sie weiterhin zur Verfügung
stehen, selbst wenn ich ein Backend
runterfahre, also das heißt, wenn ich jetzt
irgendwie Services
auf drei Raspberry Pis betreiben
will und
sie dann Failover machen und sowas...
Ja, gut. Aber ich habe das mal
meistens eh auf meinem NAS laufen und
das ist halt eine Kiste und dann ist es eh egal.
Da macht es keinen Sinn.
Wobei, es durchaus Sinn machen
könnte, sich ein Kubernetes draufzuhauen,
wenn man eben so dieses Kubernetes
Ökosystem mag.
Wie man da drauf Apps deployt, wie man Manifests
anlegt, wie man das managt.
Ja, das ist ja schon ein bisschen...
ein bisschen schöner
als jetzt Docker und Docker
Compose-Files, gerade wenn
sich öfters mal was ändert.
Ja, na egal. Wir gucken uns jetzt aber
erstmal, hups, das nicht. Wir gucken uns jetzt aber
erstmal an, was
CT, was die CT sagt
zu...
Was sind wir denn überhaupt?
Was die CT sagt zu Lama und
Alpaka?
Das ist ein ganz normaler Rechner, der übrigens
nicht mit dem Internet verbunden ist.
Aber bestimmt mit ordentlicher Grafikkarte.
Ich stelle jetzt auf Englisch die Frage, warum ist der Himmel
blau? Tja, und sofort kommt die korrekte Antwort.
Was ist die Hauptstadt von Tansania?
Yo, Dodoma. Richtig. Schreibt ein Gedicht
über Artischocken. Zack. Wenn ihr jetzt denkt,
pff, ist doch nichts besonderes, dann
liegt ihr völlig falsch, denn das ist etwas,
was noch vor ein paar Wochen völlig
undenkbar gewesen wäre. Ein ausgewachsenes
KI-Sprachmodell
läuft lokal auf... Mein Windows-Terminal
ist Standard. Komplett Standard.
Ich wollte mir sogar Westterm draufmachen,
weil ich das Windows-Terminal immer noch kacke finde.
Es ist zwar DEUTLICH besser, DEUTLICH besser
als... also, ne? Seriously.
Das hier überhaupt Terminal zu nennen, ist
ja schon... Moment. Gibt's das alte
gar nicht mehr? Leute,
gibt's das alte nicht mehr?
Und das ist nicht das alte.
Das alte hat doch keine Tabs, man.
Das ist nicht das alte.
Leute, sag mal. Das ist nicht das alte.
Das ist eindeutig das neue.
Hier. Windows-Terminal.
Guck. Das ist das neue.
Ja, PowerShell ein. Das ist auch das
neue. Ich glaub, die haben das alte
runtergeschmissen. Kann das sein?
Conhost. Ah.
Ja,
das hab ich gesucht.
Okay.
Also, seriously.
Das hier überhaupt Terminal zu nennen,
ist schon lächerlich.
Das kann ja gar nichts. Das neue ist
halbwegs erträglich. Aber ich glaube, ich hau mir auch
Westterm unter Windows drauf.
... nur auf immens teurer Server
Grafik-Hardware. Und mit immens teuer
meine ich Hardware für so ungefähr
80.000 Euro. In diesem Video erklär ich euch,
was der Unterschied zwischen Lama
und Alpaka ist. So heißen nämlich die
Sprachmodelle, die ich benutze. Warum das
wirklich, ehrlich, ein historischer Moment
ist. Und vor allem, wie ihr das selbst
auf euren Rechnern installiert kriegt.
Es reicht theoretisch sogar ein Raspberry Pi.
Was ein Intro,
Alter.
Was ein Intro.
Meine Güte.
Herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Oh Mann.
Dieses Video
wird gesponsert von Seasonic.
Ach von denen.
Die machen gute Netzteile.
Wieder ein KI-Video. Aber leider musste das
sein, weil ich einfach wirklich komplett
umgehauen war davon, dass ich auf meinem
kleinen Kartoffelcomputer hier ein
ausgewachsenes Sprachmodell laufen lassen
kann, das quasi das Weltwissen
beinhaltet. Oder etwas
weniger dramatisch ausgedrückt nahezu
das gesamte Wissen, was man im Internet
findet. Also das Ding läuft wirklich komplett
lokal im Vergleich zu beispielsweise
GPT, bei dem der Informatik-Professor
Tom Goldstein davon ausgeht, dass
man, nur um das zum Laufen zu bekommen,
5 Nvidia A100
Server-GPUs braucht, mit jeweils
80 GB RAM. Den günstigsten
Preis, den ich für eine dieser Karten gefunden
habe, waren 16.6...
Ah, easy.
694 Euro. Mal 5
sind wir also bei über 83.000
Euro. Schnapper. Und klar, solche Hardware
kauft man gewöhnlich nicht, sondern man mietet sie in
der Cloud. Aber insgesamt ist das alles
nix, womit man zu Hause rumspielen könnte. Nicht nur
wegen der Hardware, sondern auch, weil die
Macher hinter ChatGPT und GPT3
und GPT4, nämlich OpenAI,
eben gar nicht mal
so open sind, sondern einem nur
das Ergebnis verkaufen wollen, aber
nicht die Technik dahinter. Die ganzen
großen OpenAI-Produkte sind nämlich
Blackboxes. So, und jetzt ist
aber neulich Meta, also Ex-Facebook,
um die Ecke gekommen und hat
Lama veröffentlicht, mit 2L. Nicht
zu verwechseln mit Lambda von Google.
Lama ist ein mit GPT vergleichbares
Ne, ne, ne, Lambda ist AWS.
Modell
nur eben DEUTLICH offener.
Anders als OpenAI sagt Meta
zum Beispiel ganz genau, mit welchen Daten sie
das Modell trainiert haben. Den größten Teil,
nämlich 67%, machen 5
englische Common Crawl Dumps aus,
die jeweils den Inhalt von, Achtung,
3 Milliarden Websites
beinhalten. Also, da hätte so ein Mensch
so 1-2 Stunden dran zu lesen.
4,5% der Lama-Trainingsdaten
sind Code von GitHub,
weitere 4,5% Wikipedia-Dumps
in unterschiedlichen Sprachen,
4,5% Bücher von
Project Gutenberg und Book3 und
noch ein paar andere Sachen,
insgesamt 4,7 Terabyte reiner Text.
Ich verlinke euch das Meta-Paper
mal in der Beschreibung, das ist nämlich wirklich
einigermaßen verständlich, fand ich,
und sehr interessant. Ja, und Lama
ist nicht nur offener, was die Quellen angeht,
sondern Meta sagt sogar ganz genau,
wie viel Energie das Training
von Lama gekostet hat. Laut Facebook haben
User schon erwähnten 80 Gigabyte
A100-Karten fünf Monate lang
Das ist einiges an Rechenleistung,
was da am Start ist.
Das hat 2.638
Megawattstunden
Energie gekostet und
1015 Tonnen CO2 ausgestoßen,
also so viel wie 267
Leute, die von München nach New York fliegen.
Kostenmäßig rechnet man so ungefähr
einen US-Dollar für eine
A100-Stunde in der Cloud,
und das ergibt...
was es jetzt in BTU ist, ja?
5,3 Millionen US-Dollar,
also so viel hat das Training gekostet.
So, aber Meta gibt nicht nur diese
Hintergrundinfos raus, sondern auch
die Software selbst. Allerdings nicht zu
100 Prozent, denn wer Zugriff auf
die sogenannten Models haben will, also die
benötigten Daten, muss das manuell beantragen.
Und wenn Meta findet, dass man die
haben darf, kriegt man sie kostenlos. Ja,
Meta will das halt gerne entscheiden.
Jo, nun, aber ein paar Tage später
fanden sich die Daten dann als
Torrent im Netz. Ja, wer hätte das
nur denken können? Und ja, dann
war die Katze aus dem Sack, und jetzt
konnte also quasi jeder auf die Software
zugreifen. Das war doch Taktik, oder?
Damit haben die doch gerechnet. Das haben die doch nur
gemacht, um den Hype etwas zu schüren.
Das ist doch bestimmt... Damit
müssen die doch gerechnet haben. Ob
Meta das nur wollte oder nicht.
Es haben dann natürlich sofort ganz viele Leute
angefangen, damit herumzuexperimentieren.
Und das meiner Meinung nach beeindruckendste
Projekt haben fünf Stanford-
Forscher durchgezogen. Sie haben das Lama
Sprachmodell genommen und ist Richtung
Chat-GPT fein geteilt.
Ja, oder sie durften es nicht veröffentlichen,
weil legal
reasons, so. Und da haben sie halt einfach
gesagt, wir veröffentlichen es nicht, und haben halt drauf gewartet,
dass es jemand liegt, dass sie sagen können,
hups, da kann ich ja auch nichts machen.
Alpaka heißt das Projekt, ne, checkt
ihr, ne? Lama, Alpaka,
denn das Problem ist, dass Lama
out of the box nicht so gut Fragen beantworten
kann, sondern nur Sätze
vervollständigen. Statt also zu fragen,
was mache ich an einem Wochenende in
Hannover am besten, muss man hier etwas mehr
nachdenken und sowas schreiben wie, ein
perfektes Wochenende in Hannover besteht aus
... und das wird dann vervollständigt.
Ja, und das krasse ist, dass die halt einfach
100 Dollar genommen haben und dann
bei OpenAI über die API-Schnittstelle
GPT-3 Textzugang
gekauft haben und da dann
52.000 Frage-Antwort-Paare
abgeschnorchelt haben.
Geil!
Pfeiffer-Time!
Und die Fragen haben sie sich nicht mal selbst ausgedacht,
sondern sie haben 175 Fragen
vorgegeben, mit denen GPT-3
gefüttert und ja, dann hat GPT-3
dann halt zehntausende neue
Fragen ausgespuckt. Das ist ja geil!
Also hat quasi die eigene Seele freigelegt
oder den eigenen Kern. Ja, und dann haben
die Stanford-Forscher nochmal 500 US-Dollar
in die Hand genommen und damit in der Cloud
Rechenleistung gekauft und dann mit
den 52.000 Frage-Antwort-Paaren
das vorhandene Lama-Modell
feingetunt. Das, was dann rauskam, war
Alpaka. Und das soll laut Stanford-Forschern...
Also siehste, jetzt
sind wir schon kurz vorm Weltuntergang.
AI trainiert AI.
...hinsichtlich seiner Fähigkeiten mit
Text DaVinci 003 vergleichbar
sein, einem der besten
GPT-Untersprachmodelle von OpenAI.
Und das mit nur 7 Milliarden
Parametern. Text DaVinci 003
hat 175 Milliarden.
Also die haben für 600 US-Dollar
ein State-of-the-Art
KI-Sprachmodell trainiert,
beziehungsweise geklont. Bis vor kurzem war das
absolut undenkbar,
dass sowas immer billiger wird. Das
haben in der Vergangenheit Leute anhand
von Moore's Law zwar prognostiziert,
aber dass das so schnell geht,
das hätte niemand erwartet. Alpaka kann man
sich Stand heute einfach herunterladen.
Man braucht da nicht mal mit Torrents herum
hantieren oder so. Einfach nur ein Befehl auf
der Kommandozeile reicht. Aber es bewegt sich
natürlich in einem rechtlichen Graubereich.
Schließlich nimmt es als Basis
Lama von Meta, was ja eigentlich nur Leute
haben dürfen, denen Meta den Zugang erlaubt hat.
Und es wurde halt auch das
Closed Source GPT-3 Sprachmodell
von OpenAI genutzt, um
Alpaka fein zu tunen, was laut
OpenAI auch nicht rechtens ist.
Bislang haben sowohl Meta als auch
OpenAI noch nicht auf Alpaka reagiert.
Ich würde aber sagen, dass man Alpaka
definitiv nicht für kommerzielle Anwendungen
benutzen sollte. Das könnte nach hinten
losgehen. Ob man als Privatmenn...
Naja, muss dir erstmal einer beweisen,
dass du in deinem Backend Alpaka verwendest, ne?
...probleme bekommt,
wenn man damit herumhantiert, weiß ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich würde vielleicht ein bisschen
zur Vorsicht raten, guckt euch das Video an,
vielleicht reicht euch das dann schon.
Aber sehr schlag davon aus, dass die
Büchse der Pandora jetzt eh geöffnet
ist und sich aus diesem ganzen
Tohuwabohu vermutlich bald
eine echte 100% offene
und legale Open Source Lösung
herauskristallisiert. So ähnlich
wie kurz nach dem Release von OpenAI's
Bildgenerator DOL-I2 ja auch
Stable Diffusion auf der Bildfläche
erschien. Und ja klar, können
intelligente Sprachmodelle für böse
Dinge eingesetzt werden, aber ich sehe das ähnlich
wie die Alpaka-Entwickler. Die schreiben
nämlich in der Dokumentation, dass ihnen natürlich
bewusst ist, dass Risiken bestehen, aber
ihrer Auffassung nach die Vorteile
für die Forschungskommunity schwerer
wiegen als die Nachteile. Oder?
Wie seht ihr das? Wird aus solchen Sprachmodellen
jetzt Skynet und unter Joch
die Menschheit? Wird das Internet in Text
Schrott und Spam ertrinken?
Das Zweite ist teilweise
schon so, dass
Diskussionsplattformen, Reddit und
beispielsweise auch das Home Assistant Forum
und sowas voll gespammt
werden. Oder auch
teilweise Stack Overflow mit AI-Antworten.
Wobei Stack Overflow
weiß ich nicht, ob es da verboten ist.
Ich vermute einfach mal, dass
reine AI-Antworten nicht
gewünscht sind.
An allen Ecken und Enden siehst du es.
Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben und natürlich gerne
abonnieren, dann freuen wir uns. Aber, dass
das Geschäftsmodell von Home AI
gerade ganz schön wackelt, das
dürfte auf jeden Fall klar sein. Ja, aber
wie installiert man den Kram denn jetzt?
Also vorgewarnt über die unklare
rechtliche Situation habe ich euch ja schon.
Meine Empfehlung wäre generell, wartet noch
ein bisschen ab. Das ist alles noch ziemlich
buggy und instabil. Also jetzt
fernab von der rechtlichen Situation.
Wenn ihr aber hart drauf seid und das unbedingt
versuchen wollt, am einfachsten fanden wir
die Installation mit Dalai.
Checkt ihr? Alpaka, Lama, Dalai,
Dalai Lama.
LOL. Das läuft über
die JavaScript Laufzeitumgebung
Node.js und macht ein...
Was sonst, Leute? Es ist natürlich
JavaScript. Wie könnte
es auch anders sein?
... einen lokalen Webserver auf, dann lässt sich das über
einen Browser bedienen. Und das Beste,
das Ganze funktioniert egal, ob ihr Windows,
Mac oder Linux verwendet. Ich habe
auf Twitter auch Leute gesehen, die sich schon auf dem Android
Handy installiert haben. Und natürlich auf einem alten
Windows-Rechner, moderneren PC
und einem MacBook mit M2 Max.
Zuerst müsst ihr euch Node.js und Python
installieren, falls ihr das nicht... Aber bei 1 reicht
es nicht, oder wie? Ja, bei Windows nutzt ihr am besten
Visual Studio, da kommt Node.js
und das benötigte Python direkt mit.
Diese drei Optionen hier müsst ihr bei der
Installation angeklickt haben. Bei einem
unserer Windows-Testrechner musste ich danach nochmal
manuell Node.js installieren,
und zwar die 18er LTS-Version,
damit die Installation funktioniert hat.
Bei Windows müsst ihr dann die Kommandozeit...
Keck! Keck! Windows,
Leute! Bei Linux wäre das
alles deutlich einfacher.
... aufmachen, also CMD...
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass Windows jetzt endlich
ein Windows-Emoji hat in Windows 11?
Woher gab's das nicht?
... einfach das Terminal. Und dann gebt ihr da
den Befehl npx
dalai-alpaca-install
7b ein. Bestätigen.
7b, obviously!
Kurz oder lang warten, und dann
npx dalai-serve.
Und das war's. Dann könnt ihr einfach
den Browser aufmachen, localhost
.3000, und dann kommt ihr direkt auf
die grafische Oberfläche. Ja, und ab jetzt
braucht ihr kein Internet mehr, das läuft alles
lokal auf dem Rechner. Wenn übrigens irgendwas
nicht richtig funktioniert, dann könnt ihr hier
debug anklicken. Da seht ihr noch ein paar Details,
was da im Hintergrund passiert.
npredict am Anfang, das ist voreingestellt
auf 200, das ist einfach die Anzahl
der Tokens, die da ausgegeben
werden. Ein Token sind vier
Buchstaben, also das könnt ihr dann erhöhen, wenn ihr
längere Texte haben wollt. Und wichtig ist
noch temp, das ist die Temperature.
Je mehr ihr Richtung 0 kommt,
desto statischer und langweiliger,
aber auch korrekter werden
die Ergebnisse. Und je mehr ihr Richtung 1
kommt, also 09 zum Beispiel, das
bedeutet, dass das System
kreativer wird. Es fängt ein bisschen
mehr an zu freestylen, und die Fehler,
die ja sowieso solche Sprachmodelle machen,
nicht vergessen, die werden dann auch mehr.
Aber damit kann man auf jeden Fall viel
rumexperimentieren, ganz anders als mit den
anderen Sprachmodellen, wo man ja viel weniger
Einflussmöglichkeiten hat.
Dalai bietet auch so Templates an,
also so voreingestellte Modi, wenn man
zum Beispiel hier Translate ist zum
Übersetzen, Rewrite ist zum
Umschreiben, und da klickt man dann
einfach drauf, und da, wo Prompt steht,
gibt man dann einfach ein, zum Beispiel
hier, was man übersetzt haben will.
Und alle Befehle für die Installation schreiben
wir euch auch nochmal in die Videobeschreibung.
Und ansonsten steht das alles auch auf der
Videobeschreibung.
So sieht das jetzt aus.
Nur unter Windows 11 gibt es das.
Nur unter Windows 11.
Unter Windows 10.
Windows 10 hat noch kein Fenster-Emoji.
Unter Windows 10 geht das nicht.
Nur unter Windows 11. Warum auch immer.
Ein exklusives Windows 11 Feature.
Ein Fenster-Emoji.
Warum braucht man so ein Emoji?
Das musste die Unicode-Standard-Leute fragen.
Aber das Windows-Emoji
gibt es seit 10 Jahren
oder so. Nur Windows hat es bisher
nie dabei.
Die verlinken wir euch natürlich auch in der Beschreibung.
Da sind auch die Befehle, die ihr braucht, um
euch die größeren Modelle auf euren
Rechner zu laden. Also sowohl Alpaka,
da gibt es mehrere, als auch
von Lama. Und wenn ihr das installieren
hinter euch habt, sieht es dann so aus.
Und hier rechts könnt ihr das Sprachmodell
auswählen. Das fetteste Modell
Lama 65B braucht
32 GB Speicher,
Alpaka 7B... Hey!
Endlich mal was!
Wo sich's lohnt, dass ich
64 GB im Rechner hab!
Lass doch schon mal was!
... nur 4 GB.
Und übrigens nicht Video-Speicher, sondern
Dalei läuft auf der CPU, also
einfach System-Speicher. Der Trick,
dass das mit zu wenig Speicher zurechtkommt,
ist übrigens die Quantisierung auf 4-Bit.
Dadurch nehmen die Modelle deutlich
weniger Speicher ein, aber ob die
Quantisierung zu einer Qualitätsverschlechterung
der Texte führt, ist bislang auch der
Forschungsgemeinde noch so ein bisschen unklar.
Und wie gesagt, das ist alles noch
total Work in Progress.
Ich würde sagen, wir sollten das mal ausprobieren.
Ich würde sagen, wir sollten's wirklich mal ausprobieren.
Mal gucken, wie gut's
in der VM läuft.
Und die Modelle machen auch grob
das, was ChatGPT auch kann,
sind aber in vielerlei Hinsicht
zumindest bei unseren Tests deutlich, deutlich
schlechter. Das mittlere Lama
30B Modell hat hier
zum Beispiel nur sowas produziert.
Ich hab nur zu viel Leitpaste getrunken
da in meinem Rechner, keine Ahnung.
Also ihr solltet nicht denken, dass ihr damit ChatGPT
und ChatGPT 4 sofort
ersetzen könnt. Auf gar keinen Fall.
Aber wie gesagt, dass es überhaupt schon einigermaßen
geht, das ist halt krass und zeigt,
mit was für einer Geschwindigkeit sich das
KI-Thema gerade weiterentwickelt.
Und zwar jetzt auch außerhalb
der etablierten Tech-Unternehmen.
Ich glaube, wir müssen uns wirklich anschnallen.
Das wird zwar aufregend, aber auch
holperig.
So wie fast alles.
C.U.
Ahem.
Interessante Sache.
Ich schreib mir das mal auf.
Alpaka.
Ach ja,
weil jetzt jemand sagt, diesmal
die VM nicht zu klein machen,
hab ich euch überhaupt schon das neueste
Feature vom VMChamp
gezeigt. Also
neben dem, dass es jetzt KW
ausgeben kann. Man kann jetzt sagen,
VMChamp
Ups. Man kann jetzt sagen, VMChamp
Run. Kecke.
Minus. Minus. Disk Size.
Local Image
kann man angeben oder Memory.
Also ich kann jetzt quasi sowas angeben wie
10 GB
Memory
4 GB
und
OS
Nehmen wir jetzt mal
Debian 10.
Zack. Und gleich
hab ich eine VM. Moment,
ich löscht es nochmal ab.
Ich löscht nochmal kurz alle
und
ich muss gucken, dass mein Interface oben ist,
weil ich die VM gerade neu gestartet hab.
Bevor das
funktioniert.
So.
Guck mal, ich kann jetzt sagen, Run VM
Disk 10G
Mit was hast du Autocomplete im Terminal?
Das ist eingebaut. Du kannst
sagen, VMChamp
Completion ZSH
und dann gibt er dir was aus, was du in deine
ZSH RC machen kannst oder
du kannst es auch so
einfügen in deine Shell.
Und dann hast du
Autocomplete.
Es ist ein bisschen primitives Autocomplete,
aber es reicht.
Da kannst du zum Beispiel auch List
oder SSH auf die
VM. So. Seht ihr?
Wir haben eine VM hier oben am Start.
Jetzt innerhalb von 20
Sekunden oder so. Eine VM
mit 10 GB
Festplatte und
4 GB RAM. Also genauso, wie es sein soll.
Lokale Test-VM,
die ich easy innerhalb von
paar Sekunden wieder
wegschmeißen kann. Alles ist weg.
Habe ich gestern noch erweitert.
Und man hat
ja auch immer hinten noch Hilfe
Text und hier steht drin, was man
eingeben kann.
Das ist alles lokal.
Komponente-Stells haben wir gar nicht mehr so viel
gemacht.
Das ist alles lokal. Das ist aktuell.
Die VM in einer VM, ja.
Aber dafür muss man sagen, geht es doch
verhältnismäßig schnell, oder?
Guck mal hier. So.
Gucken wir mal kurz.
Wie lange das
braucht, bis die VM da ist.
Das meiste bei der VM
ist übrigens, dass er auf Netzwerk
DHCP wartet.
Die möglichen Disk-Sizes sind fest
vorgegeben. Ne, das sind nur Vorschläge.
Du kannst so viel eingeben, wie du willst.
Du kannst auch 30 GB
eingeben.
Guck, so.
25 Sekunden hat es ungefähr gedauert.
Dann ist die VM da.
Ja, du kannst auch hier
du kannst auch sagen, keine Ahnung,
5 GB und
11 oder irgendwie 17
17 GB Disk geht genauso.
Und schon hast du eine
VM.
Das läuft, wie gesagt, alles lokal
über KVM.
Und hier kannst du dir auch auflisten lassen, was du alles laufen hast.
Das läuft lokal
über KVM. Ich habe das Tool gebaut,
weil ich manchmal
mehr brauche als Container.
Ja, sei es, wenn
du ein Kernel-Modul brauchst
oder wenn du Docker in Docker machen willst,
wo es manchmal Probleme gibt und sowas.
Also Docker in Docker in Docker.
Dann ist manchmal
eine ganz schnell lokal
erstellte VM
zum Ausprobieren
und danach wieder wegschmeißen das Beste.
Und ich habe keinen Bock erst
Betriebssystem-Installationen in einer VM
durchzuklicken.
Ja, also
ich habe jetzt irgendwas ausprobiert in einer VM,
bin fertig
und dann kann ich sagen clean
und dann wirft er alle aktuellen VMs und Images wieder weg.
Ist alles sauber
und gut ist.
Geht über KVM lokal.
Man braucht KVM, QEMO wird
installiert. So die Standardsachen, die man
für Virtualisierung braucht.
Will auch, dass das Dateisystem automatisch angepasst.
Ja, weil die ganzen Cloud-Images
automatisch einen
Crow drinnen haben beim ersten Boot.
Der lädt sich
das ISO runter.
Was heißt das, das ISO?
Das gibt es auf GitHub.
Ja, habe ich gestern
gepusht.
KVM Champ.
Kannst sogar die aktuelle Version runterladen schon
als Binary, wenn du willst.
Ja.
Kannst aber auch selber bauen. Das Bauen ist auch ziemlich simpel.
Also ihr könnt
mal angenommen ihr wollt das, ihr wollt das
selbst kompilieren.
Dann geht ihr einfach hier hin.
Dann gehen wir mal ins Temp Verzeichnis.
Können wir übrigens löschen.
Wobei, weiß ich noch nicht.
Können wir das löschen? Ja, das können wir löschen.
Wobei, weiß ich nicht.
Klont einfach das Repo.
Den Preisschamp gibt es nicht mehr. Geht da rein.
Und dann führt ihr das Build-Skript aus.
Da braucht ihr lokal Docker installiert.
Führt ihr das Build-Skript aus.
Denkt euch die Versionsnummer aus.
Sagt wohin das Binary kommt.
Führt Build aus.
Okay, der ist jetzt schon fertig mit dem Build.
Weil er schon alles da hat.
Ich habe nichts geändert.
Normalerweise dauert das Build ein bisschen länger.
Ich kann es euch auch zeigen.
Ich werfe mal alle Docker-Images weg.
So, Build.
Dann dauert das jetzt ein bisschen länger.
Der lädt im Hintergrund.
Baut er das Docker-Image.
Lädt sich .NET runter.
Lädt sich ein CentOS 7 runter.
Baut das Ding im Docker-Container.
Und dann...
Wirft ihr euch das Binary raus.
Wann gibt es das für Windows und Hyper-V?
Sollte die mal irgendwann libvirt unterstützen,
dann geht das einfach.
Was sie nicht machen.
Ja, das Dateisystem wird automatisch angepasst.
Klar, installiert ihr gleich den Trojaner mit.
Das Schöne ist aber,
dass ihr nicht mal mir einfach vertrauen müsst,
dass da keine Sachen drin sind.
Ihr könnt es euch, wie gesagt,
hier selbst from source bilden.
Über den Container.
Ist eigentlich relativ simpel.
Braucht halt Docker installiert.
Auf eurer Kiste.
So.
Ist das statisch gelinkt?
Ja, soweit wie möglich.
Das einzige, was nicht statisch gelinkt ist,
ist libc, logischerweise.
Das lässt sich nicht gescheit statisch linken.
Deswegen baut der Docker-Container auch.
Pass mal auf.
Wo ist das Docker-File?
Deswegen baut der Docker-Container auch
mit CentOS 7.
CentOS 7 ist die älteste
libc-Version,
die von .NET 8,
von der .NET Alpha unterstützt wird.
Deswegen baue ich das auch im Container.
Dass es wirklich überall
auf Linux-Systemen der letzten 8 Jahre
einfach läuft. Der Rest ist statisch drin.
Ich mein, CentOS 7
hat
libc, glaube ich,
2017 oder sowas.
Ja. 2017.
Das Ganze kam raus.
2012!
Hahaha!
Ups, falsch!
2012!
Also,
das müsste lauffähig sein
auf quasi allen Linux-Systemen,
die
seit 2012
Also, ich glaube,
ich glaube,
das ist durchaus
in Ordnung.
Wie rückwärtskompatibel das ist.
Also, wenn ihr den Linux der letzten
10 Jahre einsetzt,
dann sollte der VM-Champ lauffähig sein.
So, Binary gebildet.
Und das Schöne ist,
guck hier,
hier ist das,
ich zeige euch mal,
hier ist es doch.
Das ist auch nur 12 MB groß, das Binary.
Also, das ist im Prinzip
nicht so viel größer wie ein Go-Binary.
Und warum?
Warum geht das Ganze?
Weil, das ist ein .NET 8 Projekt,
da ist jetzt die Alpha-Version,
rausgekommen, vor 2 Wochen.
Die haben ihren Compiler
optimiert, dass der jetzt kleinere
self-contained binaries raushauen kann.
Was cool ist,
wenn die so weitermachen in der Richtung,
wird das wirklich nochmal auch in diesem Fall,
also in diesem Feld, kleine,
halbwegs selbst-contained binaries,
zu einer ernsthaften Konkurrenz zu Go.
Weil das ist das, was Go wirklich aktuell
konkurrenzlos gut macht.
Relativ kleine statische binaries,
die überall ohne Dependencies laufen.
Solange man kein C-Go
so Zeug macht, dann sieht es vielleicht wieder anders aus.
So ist es, Leute.
Tja, jetzt habe ich euch das auch mal gezeigt.
Und nur mal so, dass ihr seht, dass es auch
wirklich halbwegs...
Oh, was habe ich denn hier noch?
Da ist noch von gestern übrig, glaube ich.
Den sollte ich jetzt mal...
Die Images sind auch
alle schon weg.
Nur, dass ihr seht, dass es auch
halbwegs performant ist.
Wir können jetzt mal
hier VMs erstellen.
Wir erstellen jetzt mal 10 VMs
im Hintergrund.
Einmal, ich muss ein Image runterladen,
dann lässt er sich das...
Ja, wir haben kein GitHub Actions Build.
Ja, das machen wir noch.
So, einmal runtergeladen, guckt.
Jetzt erstellt er im Hintergrund 10 lokale VMs.
Ihr seht, das braucht ein bisschen CPU
und das braucht auch ein bisschen RAM.
Wenn wir jetzt mal im Wirt Manager gucken,
da seht ihr aber, er erstellt jetzt hier 10 VMs.
Die jetzt auch booten.
Mein Rechner ist jetzt halt ziemlich ausgelastet gerade.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Die CPU-Last von QEMU.
Aber gut,
da kann man ja mit leben.
So, jetzt hat er die VMs erstellt.
Jetzt haben wir 10 lokale VMs.
Ne, sogar 11, weil es bei 0 anfällt.
11 lokale VMs,
die jetzt alle
gleichzeitig booten
und meinen Rechner ziemlich
in die Knie zwingen, aber okay.
Und ihr könnt auch mit
VMChamp List gucken, ob die Dinger schon ready sind.
Vielleicht sollte man noch
bei List noch sowas wie
Running
oder so noch als Status
Routing oder Running oder so, falls
man das irgendwie rausbekommt, den Status
noch einfügen.
So, und jetzt wird es nicht lange dauern,
dann sind die ersten am Start mit einer IP.
Sobald die ersten gestartet sind,
werdet ihr sehen, da tauchen jetzt die IPs
von den VMs auf.
Guckt da, die ersten haben schon IPs.
So, und wenn ihr euch jetzt verbinden wollt
auf eine VM, könnt ihr entweder sagen
ssh user add ddr
oder ihr macht einfach
die Kurzfassung vmchamp
ssh vm
guck mal shell completion
vm5
und schon seid ihr drauf.
Sehr praktisches Tool, oder?
Wenn man schnell lokale Test-VMs
braucht und Container ist halt
nicht cutten oder nicht ausreichen
für den Testfall, man hat sogar bei
ssh autocomplete.
Finde ich schön. Finde ich praktisch.
So, und mal angenommen ist man jetzt fertig mit testen.
Also man könnte
einzelne
VMs löschen, wenn man das will. Wenn man sagt, die hier
braucht man nicht mehr, dann ist sie weg. Man könnte
aber auch sagen, okay, ich bin jetzt fertig testen.
Sag clean
und dann schmeißt er alle weg.
Wann hattest du Zeit, das zu machen?
Freitag im Homeoffice.
Freitag im Homeoffice habe ich das
gemacht.
Es ist, ne, es ist nicht so
advanced wie Vagrant. Vagrant kannst du ja auch
automatisieren noch verschiedene
Sachen, was es macht.
Aber ich finde Vagrant
zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt ein bisschen hakelig.
Du hast so
ein Config-File pro Box,
pro VM, also einfach mal
10er starten ist da nicht.
Und das ist
uraltes Ruby-Zeug. Es unterstützt
out of the box nur
nur Virtual Box
und nur über Third-Party-KVM.
Ich finde es für so
kleine Werkweise,
ne,
welche Images verwendest du? Einfach manuell
geladen von allen Distros.
Du kannst lokales Image, also du hast
die Möglichkeit, RAM,
du hast die Möglichkeit, ein lokales Image
zu verwenden. Wenn du minus minus
OS weglässt, kannst du Local Image
angeben. Funktiert dann zum Beispiel
so, ich zeige es euch mal.
Ich lade das jetzt hier mal runter.
Das aktuelle Debian Image.
Also wenn du lokales
Image verwenden willst, kannst du sagen
minus minus Local Image.
Ups, passt.
Äh,
Debian? Warum Auto
completet er das nicht? Okay.
Es sollte sein Auto
completen. Dann kannst du so angeben.
Dann nimmt er das lokale
File, startet damit
die VM. Oder aber
du kannst zurückgreifen auf die
Images,
die hier hinterlegt sind.
Da sind die üblichen
Verdächtigen halt schon dabei.
Immer die aktuellste Debian
11.10.9 Version.
Die muss er sich dann halt einmalig runterladen
und casht sich das Image.
Und die aktuellen Ubuntu-Version. Man könnte auch noch
Fedora oder sowas reinmachen.
Wenn du wissen willst, was unterstützt
ist, wenn du wissen willst, was
unterstützt ist, kannst du einfach sagen,
VMChamp US.
Und dann kannst du dir ja anzeigen lassen,
was du willst. Oder wie gesagt, du kannst auch
jedes x-beliebige, es muss
aber ein QCOW2-Image sein,
kannst du auch jedes x-beliebige lokale
Image nehmen.
Arch, ja Arch fehlt noch.
Arch, by the way.
Können wir auch noch einbauen. Fedora,
CentOS und so.
Können wir auch noch einbauen.
Mache ich vielleicht später.
Können wir vielleicht nachher im Stream noch machen.
Da haben wir was zu tun, Leute.
Noch ein bisschen den VMChamp erweitern im Stream.
Jetzt ist ja auch Wachen-Stream eigentlich kein
Hackerman-Time-Stream.
Aber was sagt ihr? Also ich finde das Tool
enorm praktisch. Ich habe es jetzt schon ein paar Mal verwendet.
Ich habe
das auch nur entwickelt, weil ich nichts gefunden
habe, was sich ähnlich
hierzu bedienen lässt. Das Beste, was ich gefunden
habe, ist noch KVM-Instagrams.
Vom GeoTorres.
Das ist aber ein Bash-Skript,
was zwar ein bisschen mehr Optionen hat, aber
ich finde, sich nicht so schön
bedienen lässt wie der VMChamp.
Sehr praktisch, wie ich finde.
Und wir müssen noch
ein GitHub-Actions-Bild machen. Ganz
wichtig. Ja, wenn man
Test-VMs braucht, ist das sehr nice.
Und es geht halt auch wirklich
schnell. Ne, ne, ne, das taugt nix. Das
habe ich ausprobiert. Das taugt nix.
Das ist hauptsächlich für Desktop.
Für Desktop. Leute, ihr müsst nicht
googeln und mir dann den erstbesten Google-Link posten.
Ich habe das meistens schon selbst gemacht. Das habe ich
natürlich auch ausprobiert. Das ist hauptsächlich
auf Desktop-Systeme optimiert.
Es startet nicht ohne
30 Milliarden Abhängigkeiten, wie zum Beispiel
Pipewire und sonst was.
Alles nix
gescheites. Ja,
also wenn du wissen willst, was ich für
einen PC habe, mach mal Ausrufezeichen PC.
So, dann kannst du den Geizhals-Link
anklicken, den übrigens alle anklicken können.
Das ist RevLink.
Big Stonks.
Ausrufe. RevLink. Geizhals-RevLink.
Und
da siehst du meinen aktuellen PC.
Oh, guck mal, der ist billiger geworden.
Ach so, weil er das Netzteil nicht mehr
findet und weil
er... Warum ist das
so viel billiger geworden?
Ich habe noch 5000 Euro dafür bezahlt. Warum ist
das so viel billiger?
Warum ist das jetzt... Okay, das Netzteil
fehlt. Das Netzteil kostet mal 200 Euro.
Aber warum ist das jetzt 800 Euro?
Die hatte ich noch übrig. Die lohnt
sich nicht wirklich. Die hatte ich noch übrig.
Die 4090 ist ein bisschen
günstiger geworden. Ja, die 4090 ist
400 Euro billiger geworden und das Netzteil ist
nicht dabei. Okay.
Ja, dann
ist es das Netzteil und die
400 Euro für die Grafikkarte.
Warum die AI heißt, keine Ahnung.
Weil die sich gedacht haben,
es wäre eine coole Idee, die Festplatte AI zu nennen.
Stonks. Ja.
Komm, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt noch an?
Eins, zwei Sachen gehen doch noch.
Was verdient ein Straßenreiniger?
Okay, ihr könnt es euch aussuchen, Leute.
Wollen wir uns angucken?
Wahrscheinlich sagt ihr eh beides.
Wollen wir uns zuerst angucken,
Docker versus Kubernetes, was ist besser
für das Homelab? Ich würde sagen,
die Antwort ist, es hängt davon ab, was man
machen will. Oder gucken wir uns den
Straßenreiniger zuerst an? Straßenreiniger,
okay.
Ja, dann gucken wir uns den...
Wie gucken wir uns den Straßenreiniger zuerst an?
Mein Nas läuft.
Ah.
Ach so, vielleicht soll ich die Musik ausmachen.
Was verdient der Straßenreiniger?
Es ist ein krisensicherer Job.
Ja, Müll gibt es immer und hoffentlich nicht so viel
Monka-Toss-Musik.
Das ist natürlich immer ein wichtiger Faktor, aber für mich
ist die Sicherheit wichtig bei der Stadt.
Ich habe natürlich schon ein enormes Pensum an Arbeitsstunden
in der Woche, aber für mich ist das machbar.
Mein Nas läuft, ja, korrekt.
Drei, zwei, eins und Pause.
Jawohl, sehr gut.
Hi, ich bin der Daniel, ich bin 30 Jahre alt.
Geflext.
Ich komme aus Nürnberg.
Und arbeite als Straßenreiniger und Fitness Trainer.
Haben wir sowas nicht schon mal geschaut?
Das letzte Mal haben wir einen Typ geschaut, der Züge kontrolliert hat.
Der hatte auch so eine Warnweste an, aber den haben wir noch nicht geguckt.
Sobald es sehr kalt ist, fahre ich mit dem Auto.
Sonst fahre ich mit meinem Roller immer.
Einfach der Parkplatzsituation bei mir zu Hause geschüttelt.
Rollerstelz.
Von den Touren, die ich jetzt heute habe, könnte es sein, wenn wir die Altglas-Touren
zum Beispiel fahren, dass die Altglasbehälter nicht geleert wurden.
Das bedeutet dann, dass sehr viele Gläser außenrum stehen, worum ich mich kümmern muss.
Also an meinem Job nervt mich das.
Dass man manchmal natürlich dann Negatives zu hören bekommt.
Ich hatte dann schon mal die Fälle, dass er mich im Sommer angesprochen hat, ob ich Sozialstunden
leiste aufgrund meiner Optik mit den vielen Tattoos.
Tja.
Und dementsprechend kann das von...
Das war bestimmt irgend so ein Opa.
Junge, Mann!
Komplett positiv zu komplett negativ gehen.
Genau.
Blöde Sprüche musst du dir überall anhören.
Ja, aber gut.
Wenn Dienstbeginn ist, fahren wir dann mit den Autos auf unsere jeweiligen Touren raus.
Das war der Azubi, oder?
Das war der Azubi.
Das ist der Azubi, oder?
Der Linke.
Wir fahren jetzt die erste Straße an, bei der ich die Abfallbehälter lehre.
Azubi-Straßenreiniger.
Und wenn wir da dann fertig sind, dann zum nächsten Standpunkt.
Das heißt ja dann nicht Azubi-Straßenreiniger.
Das heißt dann Fachkraft für Straßenreinigung oder sowas.
Oder Straßenreinigungs-Fachkehrer.
Wir haben ja so...
Das braucht ja Pfeilfeld-Berufsbezeichnung.
So arbeiten wir immer.
Müllentsorgungsentwicklung.
Müllentsorgungsexperte.
Ey, das erinnert mich...
Kennt noch einer Ben Laxxer?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das noch gibt.
Der hatte doch auch irgendwie den...
Den Teppichboden-Verlege-Experte und so ein Stoss.
Das ist echt eine performede Ausübung.
So...
Das ist echt...
Ja, da hat sein Channel irgendwann verkauft, der Typ.
Die Teile von Fürth ab dann.
Das war schon der erste.
Und jetzt geht's weiter.
Und das ist jetzt den ganzen Tag.
Boah, da hätte ich ja auch Bock.
Ohne uns wäre die Stadt natürlich sehr vermüllt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und dementsprechend würden sich die Leute auch weniger wohlfühlen, nehme ich mal an.
Ja, mit Sicherheit.
Oder wir machen es wie in Japan.
Die Leute schmeißen ihren Kram nicht einfach mitten auf die Gas.
Körperliche Arbeit ist da schon.
Sehr anspruchsvoll.
Auch natürlich ein gewisses Geschick dafür haben.
Aber es ist halt auch viel Routine.
Umso öfter man das macht, desto besser klappt es auch.
Aber vor Bücken, Heben, Tragen sollte man keine Scheu haben.
Also heute werden es dann ca. 60 bis 70 Mülleimer, die wir dann anfangen und auch leeren werden.
Da musst du auch ganz gut trainiert sein.
Ich habe noch nie Kaffee probiert tatsächlich.
Erstmal Monster Energy Boys.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie es schmeckt.
Immer Energy Drinks.
8,80 Cent.
Oh, jetzt fällt das ins Gewicht.
Ich mache immer alles komplett leer.
Und wir sind auch dafür zuständig, dass 7,50 Meter rechts und 7,50 Meter links von der Busseite gehört auch dazu, wenn da was liegt.
Das muss ich dann auch mitnehmen.
Aha.
Also wenn die Leute da Dreck hinschmeißen, muss das auch aufräumen.
Danach fahren wir in die Innenstadt.
Also das sind die wichtigsten Mülleimer für uns.
Paper, please.
Es ist auch so, dass man eigentlich oft ein Danke hört.
Danke für die Arbeit.
Vor allem nach Silvester war das sehr, sehr häufig.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Aber es gibt halt eben auch wieder andere Leute, die sich ein bisschen beleidigt haben.
Das ist Abfakt, das nach Silvester aufzuräumen.
Sich drüber lustig machen und ja, das Ganze ein bisschen ins Negative ziehen.
Ich sehe es nicht so.
Ich habe einen sicheren Job und ja, fühle mich da auch wohl und habe da auch keine Berührungsängste zwecks dem Müll.
Der Job ist auch morgen nicht weg.
Ich meine, Müll gibt es immer und überall.
Man hat immer Handschuhe an.
Klar kann man ein bisschen was auf die Hose gehen oder so, aber ja, also danach duscht man sich und dann ist es auch wieder gut.
Jetzt haben wir die Innenstadt-Tour praktisch fertig gemacht.
Jetzt fahren wir zum ersten Altglas-Container.
Habt ihr mitgekriegt, um wie viel Uhr er angefangen hat?
Stand da irgendwas von der Uhrzeit?
Das muss doch wirklich mitten in der Nacht gewesen sein.
Irgendwie drei Uhr oder so.
Sechs Uhr erst?
Bei den Altglas-Containern?
Bei den Altglas-Containern nehmen wir alles mit, was außen rumsteht, außer an Klamotten und wenn Glasscherben etc. sind oder sonstiger Schmutz, kehren wir den natürlich auf.
Das Problem ist jetzt immer nur, dass viele Leute auch ihren Hausmüll hier abstellen, was sie ja eigentlich nicht dürfen.
Aber alles, was halt hier steht, müssen wir dann immer mitnehmen und ja, das nutzen halt die Leute sehr, sehr oft aus leider.
Das wird immer.
Es liegt aber auch ein bisschen daran, also das muss ich jetzt auch mal aus eigener Erfahrung sagen.
Nein.
Ich habe noch nie.
Ich habe noch nie meinen Müll irgendwo random auf die Gas gestellt, aber die Stadt ist da teilweise auch ein bisschen selbst dran schuld.
Also er kann ja da gar nichts für, er muss den Scheiß dann am Ende wegräumen.
Bei uns hattest du früher fast jede zweite Straße oder jede zweite Siedlung oder irgendwie so, stand ein großer Sammelcontainer für Flaschen und Altpapier.
Und es gibt jetzt hier im gesamten Ort noch zwei Container.
Früher waren das irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 15.
Und jetzt gibt es nur noch 10.
Zwei.
Und was machen die Leute, wenn ihre Tonne voll ist?
Die laufen keine drei Kilometer da zum nächsten Altmüll.
Die stellen das irgendwo in die Ecke.
Ja, das dürfen sie nicht.
Aber da fragt man sich halt auch, was soll das Scheiß, ja?
Also warum macht man aus 15 Containern nur noch zwei fürs ganze Ort?
Müll geben, dementsprechend ein krisensicherer Arbeitsplatz.
Also ist jetzt nichts, was man als Kind direkt auf dem Schirm hat.
Das kam auch erst, sage ich mal so, vor zwei, drei Jahren.
Ähm, doch, ich wollte früher Müllmann werden.
Ohne Scheiß, das war das Erste, was ich mir, also weißt du, wenn du so kleine Kinder fragst, was wollt ihr mal später werden?
Ich wollte Müllmann werden, weil ich es immer damals furchtbar interessant fand.
Also ich meine, ich mache jetzt wirklich was ganz anderes als Müllmann.
Aber ich wollte Müllmann werden, weil ich es immer super interessant fand, was die anderen Leute alle wegschmeißen.
Und dass da bestimmt noch cooles Zeug dabei ist, was man mitnehmen kann.
Das waren meine Gedanken früher, als ich klein war.
Da wollte ich Müllmann werden.
Ich bin jetzt nicht Müllmann geworden und ich mache auch nichts mit Holz.
Weil ich sonst immer nur im Fitnessstudio gearbeitet habe.
Also Hauptjob und dann noch Personal Trainings plus eigenes Training.
Dann war ich auch 14 Stunden im Studio.
Und irgendwann macht es dann keinen Spaß mehr, das Hobby.
Und ja, bin dann halt eben auf die Idee gekommen, mich bei der Stadt zu bewerben.
Da musst du fit sein.
Fitnesstrainer, 14 Stunden im Fitnessstudio.
Meine Güte, Alter.
Da hast du was zu tun, ne?
Das ist nicht ohne.
Würdest du es genau so wieder machen?
Nein.
Ich würde versuchen, früher zur Stadt zu kommen.
Zum einen ist mir Sicherheit immer sehr wichtig.
Und das ist eben ein sehr, sehr sicherer Arbeitsplatz.
Die Aufstiegsmöglichkeiten sind gut.
Ich bin schon sehr, sehr froh.
Echt? Zu was kann man da aufsteigen?
Das würde mich jetzt tatsächlich interessieren.
Machen zu dürfen, weil es trotz meines optischen Erscheinungsbildes dann oft schon auch Probleme gab bei anderen Jobs.
Das dann eben ausführen zu dürfen.
Damals wollte ich die Ausbildung als Justizvollzugsbeamter machen.
Allerdings wurden die Fingertattoos sehr kritisch angesehen und dadurch meine Korruptionsgefahr angeblich höher ist.
Aha.
Da haben sie eben abgelehnt.
Ist das nicht heutzutage gleich Diskriminierung, Racism und sonst was?
Wenn du wegen sowas abgelehnt wirst, kannst du bestimmt gegen klagen.
Wir fahren jetzt in die Pause.
Ist immer alles abgewogen mit 150 Gramm Reisflocken, 300 Gramm Königer Frischkäse und Geschmackspulver.
Boah.
Ich bin so appetit...
Uuuh.
Igitt.
... appetitlich aus, aber schmeckt.
Eigentlich kann man sagen, 0 Cent im...
Oh, please. Was ist das denn?
Okay. Das einzige, was das macht, ist wahrscheinlich satt.
... für unterwegs essen.
Außer zumindest aus der Arbeit nicht.
Das ist eher so eine ungünstige Arbeit.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das ist nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Du klagst, du verklagst nicht den Arbeitgeber, der dich nicht genommen hat, dass er dich nimmt.
Das wird nicht passieren.
Du kriegst dann aber drei bis vier Monatsgehälter.
Vielleicht etwas, was dir entgangen ist.
Und in Zukunft wird es dann vielleicht weniger passieren.
Auf der anderen Seite...
Vielleicht gibt es ja da auch genaue Regelungen, das ist doch rechtlich zulässig.
Ich will das jetzt mal gar nicht so sehr in Frage stellen, dass es da vielleicht doch...
... triftige Gründe gibt, das nicht zu machen.
So bin ich ja in dem Thema nicht drin. Vielleicht...
Aber weil du dich halt dauernd bücken musst und alles einzeln aufheben musst.
Weil innen kann man halt schlecht kehren.
Deswegen ist schon jetzt das etwas, was ein bisschen mehr nervt.
Manche machen das auch wirklich aus...
... trotz, dass sie dann vor uns noch mal was hinwerfen.
Boah, das ist ein Spaß.
Und ja, da muss man halt drüberstehen, lächeln.
Ich bedanke mich dann.
Wegen ihm darf ich den Job machen. Und dann ist das auch wieder gut.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das Beste, was du machen kannst.
Wenn du sagst, ja, dankeschön, nice, Job gesichert.
Ich bin im Tarifvertrag...
... drüberstehen, lächeln.
Ich bedanke mich dann.
Ja, ich meine, was willst du auch sonst machen?
Kannst du ihm ja schlecht aufs Maul hauen oder so.
Dann ist das auch wieder gut.
Dann ist recht der Job los.
Ich bin im Tarifvertrag angestellt.
E3 ist die Gruppe. Das ist aktuell 2.418 brutto.
Dann habe ich noch mal gewisse Schmutzzulagen bei uns.
Aufgrund des Jobs.
Und da komme ich dann eben immer auf circa insgesamt 2.600 brutto.
Was dann circa...
Okay.
Reich wirst net.
... 1,8 netto sind.
Also reich wirst du net.
Alles, was wir jetzt auf dem Müllauto haben, kippen wir jetzt in unsere Multe.
Da wird es gepresst.
Und wird dann immer zweimal in der Woche von der Firma abgeholt.
Wo dann der ganze Müll ansorgt wird.
Auto ausmachen.
Scheiben zu.
Und dann war's das.
Jetzt sind wir 14.20 Uhr.
Jetzt gehen wir uns langsam umziehen.
Und dann ist der Feierabend endlich da.
Wie viel Uhr? Wie viel Uhr ist Schluss?
Ist alles da?
Zuhause ist für mich das Wichtigste tatsächlich.
Ich bin zwar meistens immer dann eben morgens und abends nur daheim.
Aber wenn ich dann daheim bin, bin ich dann auch sehr, sehr glücklich.
Das ist mein Hund.
Das ist der Kai Uwe.
Der Kai Uwe.
Der ist jetzt genau acht Jahre alt.
Mein Ein und Alles.
Mein bester Freund.
Mein Ruhepol auch.
Ich habe zwar eigentlich nie schlechte Tage.
Aber wenn es doch mal alles ein bisschen negativer ist, bringt er mich auf jeden Fall immer zum Lachen.
Komm, Kuss.
Und hoch.
Na, hier stehe ich.
So ist gut.
Ach, der hat mehrere Jobs.
Ich habe einmal noch eine Nebentätigkeit im Fitnessstudio.
Da habe ich dann eben auch 500 Euro netto circa.
Am Ende des Monats immer.
Dann bin ich noch selbstständig als Personal Trainer.
Das sind auch circa vier bis ...
Oh, das läppert sich.
Gut, dafür bist du auch den ganzen Tag am Arbeiten, ja?
500 im Monat.
Und nebenbei spende ich noch Blutplasma.
Alter, der ist wirklich 24, 24,7 am Start, ey.
Also fix bekommt man immer 25 Euro.
Mit der Plasma-Spende ist es meistens so, dass ich da meine Fitnessprodukte im Monat circa wieder plus minus drinnen habe.
Und was bei mir immer noch wichtig ist, dass ich Parfüm drauf habe.
Ja, ja.
Muss ja, muss ...
Ja, ist ja gut, Mann.
Alter.
Boah, was ein Tier, Alter.
Das Training ist für mich schon sehr wichtig.
Das hat man ihm gar nicht so krass angesehen in seiner Warnjacke.
Da hast du schon gesehen, dass der gut gebaut ist.
Aber das ist echt richtiges Tier.
Der Mülleimer hat keine Chance, nee.
Aber das ist ...
Routine.
Da überlegen sich auch irgendwelche Dummschwätzer zweimal, ob sie dem doof kommen, wenn er da gerade am Müll wegmachen ist.
... die ich eben fünf bis sechs Mal die Woche mache dann.
Für mich ist das ein guter Ausgleich.
Das ist ein enorm wichtiger Bestandteil meines Lebens.
Jetzt mache ich mir kurz mein Essen.
Was Kleines vor der Arbeit.
Und dann ziehe ich mich um und dann startet schon die nächste Arbeit.
Also nahtloser Übergang.
Moment. Wie viele Arbeiten hat er denn noch?
Praktisch.
Die Tattoos vom ganzen Körper jetzt.
Das ist natürlich schon ein sehr gutes Auto, was da innen steckt.
Ich hatte jetzt zum Beispiel letztes Jahr im Sommer zehn Tattoosessions in einem Monat.
Also in dem Monat waren es knapp 5000.
Okay, also ist wohl noch Platz.
Jetzt ist Schichtbeginn.
Und kommt gleich der erste Termin dann.
Ah, Personal Trainer.
Gut, noch fünf.
So ist gut.
Komm.
Sehr schön.
Letzter.
Was kostet denn so ein Personal Trainer?
So ist perfekt von dem Ellbogen.
Zusätzliche Anspannung.
So ist gut.
Perfekt.
Wenn man dann manche hat, die nach einem halben Jahr kommen, die sagen, die haben 20 Kilo abgenommen,
ist das meistens sogar ein bisschen mehr wert als Geld, muss man schon sagen.
Sehr gut. Hälfte hast du.
Komm.
Sieht sehr gut aus.
Wenn man es insgesamt betrachtet, lohnt sich das für mich schon.
Ich sehe das meiste eben sowieso als Spaß und mache das nicht, weil ich muss, sondern weil ich möchte.
Ich gehe auch nie persönlich in den Urlaub.
Ich brauche Beschäftigung.
Ich brauche einen Rhythmus.
Ich brauche Struktur.
Weil sonst lohnt sich das für mich eben nicht, wenn ich einfach in den Tag hinein lebe.
Wie viel kostet ein Personal Trainer?
Na, 100 Euro die Stunde kann nicht sein.
Da macht der nur fünf Stunden im Monat.
Ach, Moment, das ist netto.
Ja, doch.
Also, der ist wirklich gut beschäftigt.
Ich meine, er hat zwei bis drei Jobs.
Oh, Toss-Musik.
Das war's von mir.
Ich hoffe, ihr hattet genauso viel Spaß wie ich.
Wenn ihr sehen wollt, wer das Ganze gefilmt hat, klickt einmal hier.
Für weitere Videos hier.
Und wenn ihr selber einmal dabei sein wollt, dann schreibt einfach eine E-Mail an lohnt-sich-das-at-br.de.
Aber richtig tierter Typ.
Okay, ich muss jetzt mal gucken.
Was kostet Personal Trainer kosten?
Was kostet denn so was?
Was kostet ein Personal Trainer?
Im Schnitt kostet er nur rund ein bis zwei Euro.
Rund ein bis zwei Euro?
Was?
Puh.
Ordentlich.
Lohnt sich, lohnt sich das.
Oh, das.
100 Euro pro Stunde?
Da musst du...
Ist schon, ist schon ordentlich.
Nee, der hat ja auch gesagt, er hat keinen Bock drauf in Urlaub zu fahren.
Nur gut.
Ähm.
Haben wir sonst noch was, was wir angucken können?
Natürlich sind...
Also, Schweiz ist mega teuer.
Deswegen ist es ja auch so, dass mein Gehalt für deutsche Verhältnisse...
Ja.
Dass er auch für deutsche Verhältnisse relativ gut ist.
Für Schweizer Verhältnisse eher so, so nur nach fünfzede.
Das ist halt anderes Umfeld.
Was richtig pfeifert wäre, wenn man die Möglichkeit hat, wahrscheinlich in Deutschland leben und
in der Schweiz Geld verdienen.
Was?
Nein.
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Ja, wenn das Gehalt stimmt, dann muss, die müssen halt ordentlich, ordentlich draufhauen,
dass sich das lohnt.
Ja.
Aber wenn er auch in der Schweiz lebt, muss er ja auch aktuell mehr bezahlen.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Haben wir noch irgendwas Spannendes hier? Zeig mal her.
Deutsche Meisterschaften, Tennisbund.
Nein, das interessiert mich jetzt nicht.
Christian Lindner interviewt sich selbst.
Guck mal, mein Serverraum-Video
wird mir vorgeschlagen.
Was haben wir denn noch? Kubernetes vs.
Docker. Eigentlich habe ich da noch nicht so viel Bock drauf.
Okay.
87% aller
Menschen scheitern ohne diese
Fähigkeit. Punkt 1, Punkt 2,
Punkt 3. Okay, okay.
Gucken wir mal. Die meisten sind
wahrscheinlich einfach zu blöd oder
zu unwillig oder zu unkreativ
oder haben da kein Händchen für.
Keine Ahnung, mal gucken.
Für Fähigkeiten als Softwareentwickler benötigt.
Vielleicht fallen dir hier die Klassiker ein, wie Probleme und Bugs lösen.
Five Hat sein muss man.
Five Hat sein und Wubblos auf Twitch gucken.
Und am besten noch Prime subscriben.
Das in Kombination ist eigentlich
sichere Jobgarantie.
Kann man auch in die Bewerbung schreiben.
Ich gucke regelmäßig Wubblos.
Five Hat Time.
Kommunikationsfähigkeiten oder auch einfach nur
Mathe. Es gibt aber einen weiteren Skill.
Wenn du den nicht beherrschst, dann wirst du definitiv
scheitern. Googeln. Ja, das ist
richtig. Das habe ich ja auch schon gesagt in meinem Video.
So Tipp zur Ausbildung.
Googeln können ist eines der wichtigsten
Skills. Nicht nur eines
Programmierers. Von jedem, der was
mit Technik zu tun hat.
McFly, dankeschön für 16 Monate.
Prime Subscription.
Geht ja selbstverständlich vom Refactoring.
Also alten Programmcode so umzuschreiben,
dass er besser ist.
Und was das eigentlich genau bedeutet und
wie es dir auch als Nicht-Programmierer
Leute, wer macht denn so? Moment.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Keck JavaScript.
So was macht man heutzutage nicht.
Man verwendet NPM is even.
Natürlich.
Und NPM is odd.
Damit man auch
das halbe Internet runterladen muss.
Nur wenn man checken will, ob
eine Zahl gerade oder ungerade ist.
Und was das eigentlich genau bedeutet
und wie es dir auch als Nicht-Programmierer weiterhilft,
das wollen wir uns gleich in drei praktischen Tipps anschauen.
Das ist Tim. Hochmotiviert dabei, programmieren zu lernen.
Und heute geht es darum, seine erste eigene API zu schreiben.
Das ist letztendlich einfach nur eine Schnittstelle,
mit der andere Programme quasi auf sein Programm zugreifen können.
Aus diversen Online-Tutorials hat er schon die meisten Infos gesammelt
und weiß auch, was eigentlich schon eine REST API ist
und wie man diese aufbaut.
Aber nicht jeder soll Zukunft auf Tims Programm haben,
sondern nur vertrauenswürdige Personen.
Es muss also eine Authentifizierung her.
Nutzer müssen also jetzt nachher auf die REST-API aufbauen.
Nachweisen, dass sie dafür berechtigt sind,
auf Tims Programm zuzugreifen.
Die Logik dafür ist relativ simpel und unsicher.
Ähm, doch, es geht schneller als Modulo.
Man kann...
Kann man nicht auch shiften?
Kann man nicht Bit-Shiften und angucken,
ob das letzte Bit 1 oder 0 ist?
Ja, ich glaube, das geht noch einen Ticken schneller.
Und wahrscheinlich wird in vielen Sprachen Modulo sogar so,
also Modulo 2 zumindest,
ja, so implementiert sein.
Oder und.
Ja, und mit 1 geht auch.
Ups, Falsches.
Also muss immer stehen geblieben.
Aber erfüllt alle Anforderungen.
Nur mittlerweile sieht unser Programmcode relativ unübersichtlich aus.
Es gibt tausende Wiederholungen
und das muss doch auch irgendwie besser gehen.
Ja, man muss das dry machen,
wie das die coolen Leute nennen.
Weil nur wenn ein Code dry ist, dann ist er... dry.
Ein Senior-Entwickler erkennt sofort, dass dieser Code nass ist.
Auf Englisch wet.
Das write-everything-dry-Prinzip führt dazu,
dass du unübersichtlichen Codes und schlechten Codes schreibst.
Und jetzt muss das dry machen.
Wie ich wusste, was kommt.
Müssten wir jetzt hier das Passwort ändern,
müssten wir das auch an zwei Stellen ändern,
anstatt nur an einer.
Wir trocknen jetzt gleich den Code ab,
machen ihn also dry und wenden dabei
das don't-repeat-yourself-Prinzip an.
Die Authentifizierung kommt jetzt also einfach in ihre eigene Funktion
und dadurch können wir das Verhalten
einerseits zentral steuern
und andererseits wird unser Code deutlich besser lesbar.
Ähnlich kannst du es auch im echten Leben angehen.
Anstatt nach meinen Videos zu suchen,
kannst du einfach abonnieren.
Sehr gute Überleitung.
Das ist eine gute Überleitung.
Also dry gibt es aber schon ewig,
die Abkürzung.
Aber ich gebe dir insofern recht,
es wird teilweise schon extrem übertrieben.
Wie gesagt,
heutzutage bist du ja auch nicht mal nur Admin,
du bist auch nicht mal nur devops,
du bist bis,
sec, def,
finops, du bist alles in einem.
... und bekommst sofort
eine Benachrichtigung.
Unsere Memes sind jetzt vor ungewolltem Zugriff geschützt,
aber ich will es noch ein bisschen nutzerfreundlicher machen
und eine kleine personalisierte Botschaft hinzufügen.
Zum Glück gibt es jetzt eine Nutzer-ID,
die mich eindeutig identifiziert.
Und, und, und,
87%?
Also ich habe jetzt den Titel noch nicht so genau
dem Inhalt des Videos zuordnen können.
Aber was ist jetzt eigentlich,
wenn eine falsche ID mitgegeben wird,
irgendwie kein Nutzer abgerufen werden kann
oder unser User einfach gar keinen Nutzer hat?
Defensiv mit If-Statements programmiert
sieht unser Programm doch
recht unübersichtlich aus.
Und jetzt? Okay, okay, ich weiß,
ich weiß was kommt. Jetzt kommt Early Return.
Oder sowas.
Ich bin mir definitiv nicht dabei,
den Code schnell und einfach zu verstehen.
Und kommt jetzt noch mehr Logik dazu,
puh, dann ist Feierabend.
Daher bin ich ein Freund von Early Returns,
...
Null! Er nennt es auch noch genauso.
Leute, ich schwöre euch, ich habe das Video nicht
geguckt im Vorfeld.
... mehr Logik dazu, puh, dann ist Feierabend.
Daher bin ich ein Freund von Early Returns,
was uns hier zumindest die ganzen Eindrückungen spart.
Anstelle zu überprüfen, ob etwas
existiert, überprüfen wir jetzt,
ob etwas nicht existiert.
Anstatt der ganzen Else-Statements gibt es jetzt
immer nur noch ein Return, und Fehler werden
früh und strukturiert abgefangen.
Alles in einer schönen Spalte,
das nenn ich mal... Boah, Alter!
Please, lautere Einspieler!
... auch im Ersten geben gilt. Erkennst du Fehler früh
und verbesserst diese, wird dein Leben deutlich
angenehmer und entspannter.
Ich finde, unsere Funktion sieht schon deutlich besser aus,
und ich kann mich auch daran machen,
die Meme-Funktionalität hinzuzufügen.
Gesagt, getan, doch mittlerweile, hm,
schon ein bisschen unübersichtlich.
Er sollte, er sollte sich auch mal ein keck WS-Service
probieren.
Ich mach meine Funktion jetzt eigentlich alles. Den Nutzer abrufen,
die Nachricht personalisieren,
und dann noch ein Meme versenden.
Das wird mir auf den ersten Blick gar nicht mehr so ersichtlich.
Ich muss jetzt relativ viel Code lesen
und verstehen, um überhaupt herauszufinden,
was mein Programm eigentlich macht.
Und kommen neue Entwickler aufs Projekt,
haben die eine relativ lange Einarbeitungszeit,
um überhaupt produktiv zu werden.
Außerdem könnten andere kritisieren,
dass meine Codequalität einfach schlecht ist.
Damit das aber nicht passiert,
refactoren wir unseren Code wieder ein wenig
und schauen, dass unsere einzelnen,
separaten Abläufe auch ihre eigene Funktion bekommen.
Was meine ich damit genau?
Nun gut, einerseits können wir das Name herausfinden aus...
Ja, da kann man sich jetzt, da muss ich
ehrlich sagen, da kann man sich jetzt ein bisschen drüber
streiten. Solange das nämlich
alles nur an einer Stelle benutzt wird,
ist es halt fraglich, ob man die Lesbarkeit
wirklich so viel verbessert,
wenn man das dann auch aufsplittet.
Also was auszulagern in eine extra Funktion
oder Methode ist ja sinnvoll,
wenn man das mehrfach braucht.
Aber wenn man diese Logik
genau an einer Stelle braucht,
ja auch wenn es vielleicht
drei verschiedene Bereiche sind,
wie man das einteilen kann,
ob so sinnvoll ist das aufzusplitten,
dass man dann durch drei verschiedene Funktionen
hin und her tappen muss,
um zu wissen, was passiert.
Kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten?
Also ich persönlich finde es nicht verkehrt,
eine etwas längere Funktion zu haben,
wo der ganze Code logisch
an der Stelle steht, wo er gebraucht wird,
wenn es die einzige Stelle ist,
wo er gebraucht wird.
Und andererseits auch das
Meme generieren auslagern.
Oder direkt neues NPM-Package draus machen.
Dass jede Funktion eine eigene
kleine definierte Aufgabe hat.
Benennst du deine Funktion dann auch noch gut,
dann lass ich dich heute Abend sogar in Ruhe schlafen gehen.
Ansonsten pass lieber auf.
Das ist ein Vorteil,
dass dein Code deutlich einfacher testbar ist.
Und welches?
Das ist doch ein Titel,
den er mit ChatGPT erstellt hat, oder?
Der hat ja mit dem Video jetzt gar nichts zu tun gehabt.
Kleine, klar definierte
Aufgaben runterbrechen
und so deutlich schneller und einfacher lösen.
Das Refactoring brauchst du aber nicht,
wenn du von Anfang an guten Code schreibst.
Damit das der Fall ist,
vermeide diese drei Fehler
und spare extrem viel Zeit.
Oh, man hat doch grad schon
Python.
Cheatbaited.
Don't tell your boss the computer trick.
Okay, Shorts.
Shorts sind meistens extrem,
Extremely Pains Champ.
Don't tell your boss about this website.
If you're super tired at work
and want to procrastinate, just go here.
Then you can pick the operating system you have.
Let me go to Windows 10.
And now if I put it in full screen by pressing...
Das ist ja geil,
Alter.
Das ist ja geil.
Ja, genial.
Okay, Sekunde.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt mal unter Linux.
Oh, hier.
Fake...
Nee, was war das?
Was war das?
Don't tell your boss about this website.
Blue, danke schön für den Samt.
Fakeupdate.net
Haben die schon...
Ist das Windows 11?
Was davon ist Windows 11?
Das hier, hä?
Das ist eigentlich extrem nice.
Wisst ihr, was auch cool wäre,
wenn man einen Timer einstellen könnte,
so nach dem Motto,
das ist enorm praktisch.
Ich glaube, das kann ich in Zukunft nochmal benutzen.
Mein PC ist schon auf Englisch gestellt.
Ja, so genau
guckt da doch keiner hin.
Meister. Gute Idee.
Sehr gute Idee.
Prankupdate-Screen.
Excellent.
Feifett-Idee.
Wieder was gelernt.
Ach, man kann sogar die Sprache ändern.
Ja.
Fakeupdate.net
Ach, hier. Select language.
Deutsch.
Wie?
Es sah aber unter Windows XP nicht so aus.
Aber das ist eine gute Idee.
Finde ich sehr nice.
Nein.
Du hattest doch auch mal so eine Seite mit Bash.
Hä?
Meinst du den Hacker-Typer?
Meinst du den?
Just Hacker, man.
So.
Excellent.
So war das richtig.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob das gut ist,
und dass Coolkunk das nicht checkt,
dass das Getippe im Hintergrund ist.
So.
Was auch noch cool ist, ist Hollywood.
Falls ich das installiert habe.
Ne.
Will ich jetzt auch nicht installieren,
weil es so viele Abhängigkeiten hat.
Hollywood macht auch so Fake-Shit.
Ich kann es installieren.
VM installieren für Hollywood.
Sehr gute Idee.
Wir könnten es auch im Container laufen lassen.
Das ist auch sehr nice.
Wenn man will,
dass er wieder übelst krasse Hacker-Man aussieht.
Aber ich werde es jetzt wieder deinstallieren.
Alles wieder, alles wieder entfernen.
Hat bestimmt 100.000 Dateien angelegt.
Bei mir.
Fuck, man.
Ich glaube, das war das einzige.
Das hätte ich tatsächlich in der VM gestartet.
Siehste, dafür wäre eine Test-VM gut gewesen.
Oder alternativ,
man hätte es auch einfach in einem Docker-Container starten können.
Wir hätten auch einfach sagen können,
Docker run.
Ein Linux-Image.
Docker run Manjaro oder sowas.
Gibt es da irgendwas?
Arch?
Weiß ich nicht.
Haben die ein offizielles Image?
Arch, by the way.
Nee.
Arch latest gibt es nicht.
Manjaro?
Auch nicht.
Ja, mit minus minus recursive schon.
Aber halt nicht,
wenn die Programme schon Konfig-Dateien angelegt haben.
Dann nicht.
Arch-Linux latest.
Ah, yes.
Haben wir hier irgendwas?
Das haben wir natürlich kein Helper drauf.
Muss man erst mal updaten.
Das ist natürlich doof.
Das muss man auch im Package Manager und so noch installieren dafür.
Jetzt darf man es auch nicht als root machen.
Ist schon doof.
Ey, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Bis du da einen Container aufgesetzt hast,
bist du wahrscheinlich schneller.
Gibt es hier irgendein fertiges Arch-Linux mit
schon installiertem Arch-User-Repo-Helper?
Das wird er sich wahrscheinlich beim Installieren irgendwo merken.
Intern.
Für welches Programm du das installiert hast als Abhängigkeit.
Wahrscheinlich wird er sich das intern merken.
Naja.
Habe ich übrigens noch Snapshots hier am Start?
Alter, wofür?
Erst mal alle Snapshots deleten wieder.
So, haben wir noch irgendwas, was wir uns angucken können?
Oh, es ist 12.18 Uhr, Leute.
Ich muss... Ich muss essen.
Okay, komm, wir gucken uns jetzt noch das
Docker an. Ob Docker oder Kubernetes
besser für das Homelab ist.
Alter, die Snapshots brauchen eine ganze Weile.
Okay.
Docker vs Kubernetes.
What's better in a Homelab?
Also wie gesagt, mein Fazit ist...
Es hängt davon ab,
was man machen will.
Hört doch auf mit den ganzen Chat-GPT-Videos.
Es ist so langweilig mittlerweile.
...
Schon 1,3G
aufgebraucht.
1,1G.
Äh, 1T, nicht G.
Aufgebraucht.
Alter, wofür brauchen die
VM jetzt bitte schön so lang?
Ich wollte jetzt schnell die Snapshots löschen und dann
ist gut. Aber nee.
Anscheinend.
Ah, jetzt. Okay, er hat's geschafft.
Alles klar. Und dann noch mal eine
Sache, damit ich's nicht vergesse.
Ähm, Storage.
Gibt's nix. Okay.
Ich hab letztens
noch so 20GB USB-Platten
angelegt.
Storage. Ah, hier, hier.
Da muss alles weg.
Ja. Volumes.
Delete.
Delete. Yes.
Downloads interessieren
mich nicht wirklich.
Äh,
warum auch immer der VM
Champ da drinne steht.
Man weiß es nicht genau.
Okay. Gut.
Okay, erzählen wir uns mal an.
Docker versus Kubernetes.
Was ist besser für das Homelab?
Projects became bigger and more
complex.
Okay, was?
Hab mal überlegt, meine Docker
Compose zu K3S zu überführen,
um es zu lernen. Aber Compose ist
sogar allein schon, kann ich als
Gewass dahin. Aber das kannst du in
Kubernetes auch alles machen.
Es ist halt eine riesen Lernkurve.
Kubernetes. Ja, ich merke das ja
selber. Ich bin ja jetzt nämlich
selbst nicht der, der, der krasseste
Kubernetes Profi auf
diesem Planeten. Ich lerne da
auch permanent neu neues Zeug.
Letztens erst mal Metal LB
angeguckt, dass man endlich den
Kubernetes Load Balancer lokal
gescheit verwenden kann, wenn man
will. Also das hat eine riesen
Lernkurve. An sich finde ich das
Handling, wenn man halt öfters
was dran ändert, wenn man einmal
den Service konfiguriert und den
dann für drei, vier Monate laufen
lässt und dann vielleicht mal das
Image aktualisiert. Da ist Docker
Compose ungeschlagen, easy, einmal
erstellt und fertig.
Ja, wenn man öfters mal was
ändert oder vielleicht auch mal
neue Apps hinzufügt.
Eventuell das Ganze auch zu Hause,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer
irgendwie hochverfügbar machen
will oder so. Da ist das, da ist
das, aber auch Single Node
technisch ist das vielleicht sinnvoll,
aber es ist halt ein Riesenaufwand,
das mit Kubernetes zu machen.
Also die Lernkurve. Kubernetes ist
an selbst, an sich gar nicht mal so
sehr, aber alles was drumherum, was
da dran hängt, ist halt so ein
Riesending. So, gucken wir uns mal
an. Was erzählt er denn?
Docker versus Kubernetes. Du bist
gerade reingekommen, verstehst? Ja,
du bist ja gerade zum ungünstigen
Zeitpunkt.
Reingekommen. Die, die Normie-Videos
sind schon durch für heute. So,
gucken wir uns mal an. Docker versus
What's Better. Also.
I wanted to go the next logical
step and decided to create
a high available Kubernetes
cluster with K3S and run some
apps there as well.
But now, since I'm running Kubernetes
along with... Es ist halt total overkill für daheim,
aber gut. Docker for about a year
or so in my home lab.
I need to be honest. There were
moments where it just made
me crazy.
And I already wanted to throw it
out the window. Verstehe ich. Die Kubernetes-Learn-Kurve ist richtig heftig. Gerade am Anfang. Du wirst
zugeschissen mit
zigtausend Begriffen
und Abkürzungen und
Produktnamen und
es ist wirklich wir.
Not just once. Ich meine, es fängt
ja allein schon damit an,
es fängt ja allein schon damit an, dass es
bestimmt sieben Varianten
gibt, Kubernetes-Lokal ausprobieren
zu nehmen. Du hast Kind, du hast
Minikube, du hast Ranger,
Desktop, du hast K3S,
K0S,
ähm, was gibt's denn sonst noch alles?
Ja, dann kannst du
Talos OS oder sowas verwenden, wenn man
einfach nur das Image direkt auf den Raspberry Pi
hauen will.
Allein schon das pure
Wie fang ich einfach an, um es mir mal kurz
anzugucken, ist schon kompliziert.
Was ist Kubernetes?
Kubernetes.
Du weißt, was das ist. Du warst sogar im Stream
dabei.
Gbait-Versuche hier im Chat finden statt.
Egal, weiter.
I was dealing with all sorts of issues with the
cluster replication.
Warst du nicht? Falls du es nicht warst, Kubernetes
ist quasi ein Cluster für Docker.
Ob's mal, wenn man es in einem Satz sagen will.
Geklustertes Docker.
Storage, networking, it was a real headache.
I mean, it's crazy how many things you need to master
to just get started with Kubernetes.
Ja, ja.
And that all raises up the question, how useful is
Kubernetes really in a homelapse?
Is it all worth it?
Eigentlich, also wenn man mal ehrlich ist, wenig, wenig.
Aber zum Lernen, ja, zum Lernen ist es sinnvoll, weil
man durch das Selbst, durch das Selbstbasteln und sozusagen
von Grund auf Selbstbasteln einfach viel lernt.
Später wirst du wahrscheinlich keinen Kubernetes-Cluster
betreiben, sondern irgendeine Managed-Lösung benutzen, wo zu
mindest so diese Kubernetes-API und das ETCD und so was in
der Richtung, wo das managed ist.
Das ist ja bei allen, auch beispielsweise der Standard
Google Kubernetes, nee, Kubernetes Engine, Google
Kubernetes Engine Standard, so heißt's, ist das ja auch
so, dass du dich da nicht mehr drum kümmern musst.
Aber es schadet trotzdem nicht, einfach mal so die
Grundlagen gesehen zu haben, zum Beispiel mal Cluster zu
installieren, einen Loadbalancer in YAML zu definieren und sich zu
fragen, warum funktioniert der nicht?
Ja, der funktioniert nicht, weil das darauf ausgelegt ist,
dass der Cloud-Provider das unterstützt und lokal, läufst du
lokal und nicht in irgendeiner Cloud, das heißt, du musst dich
selbst drum kümmern, dass das so ist und da musst du, ja, also
es ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht gemacht zu haben, finde ich.
In the end, or might it be better to just continue using
Docker only?
Einfach, einfach, das ist das beste Tool für den besten Zweck.
Check out some of the responses I got on YouTube and Twitter,
when I asked you about what are you using in your HOME Lab.
Docker was always the clear favorite.
Macht ja auch Sinn.
Docker ist ja auch sinnvoll für so vieles zusätzliche, wo Kubernetes
alleine nicht, wo Kubernetes keinen Sinn macht.
Zum Beispiel, wir haben es doch eben gesehen hier in meiner VM.
Ja, wir haben noch eben repos-vmchamp.
Allein schon das Bilden von der Anwendung hier, das passiert in einem Docker-Container,
lokal. Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn,
das hier in einem Kubernetes zu machen.
Wozu?
Wozu sollte ich diesen Container
zum lokalen Bilden testen?
Also testweise bilden von Software.
Wozu, um alles zu nennen, sollte ich das
in einem Kubernetes-Cluster machen?
In einem Kubernetes-Cluster läuft die Software am Ende,
wenn sie fertig gebildet ist und in den Docker-Image
verpackt wurde.
Aber man kann
es einfach für unterschiedliche Sachen verwenden.
I still believe
it has a place in a homelab.
There are some situations where it just
makes so many...
Das habe ich nicht gesehen.
Wundert mich aber nicht.
Kubernetes-Cluster selbst administrieren
ist viel,
viel komplizierter und
anspruchsvoller, als es auf den ersten Blick
aussehen mag.
Ihr seht übrigens ArgoCD im Hintergrund, auch eine
eine nice Geschichte
für Kubernetes.
Weil die coolen Leute
applyen keine Kubernetes-Maschinen.
Manifests, YAML-Manifests
mehr von Hand. Die pushen das in den
Git-Repo und ArgoCD applyt das dann.
And if you are wondering
what you should use in your homelab
Docker, Kubernetes or
maybe both, let's try to find that out.
I will tell you based on my own experience.
Also Docker als erstes für lokale
Entwicklung und sonst was und wenn man dann Anwendungszwecke
für lokales Kubernetes hat,
warum nicht?
But you need to keep in mind when you're planning
to run Kubernetes in your homelab, let's explore
some situations where it makes
a lot of sense and also talk about
some other situations where it
might be better.
Jetzt kommt erst mal Advertisement.
This video is supported by Teleport,
a free and open source access proxy
that helps you to securely authenticate
to all your IT infrastructure
like Linux servers, databases.
Man könnte auch einfach SSH-Keys nehmen lokal.
Kubernetes Clusters, Web
Applications or so.
How I'm going to start this?
Well, first I think I don't need to
tell you what containerization is.
I've made several videos about it
and I guess most of you guys are already
using Docker, but just to summarize
some of the pros and cons of it.
Docker is just great for running containers
on a single host.
It's allowing you to run multiple isolated
applications on a single machine.
Gerade um Software zu bauen, Sachen mal kurz auszuholen.
Guck mal, wir haben GitEA letztens ausgesprochen
oder ShitEA oder wie auch immer man es ausspricht.
GitEA.
Gitti, Gitti, wie auch immer.
Zumindest haben wir das einfach im Docker-Container gestartet.
Easy, up, run, geht drauf.
It's very simple, very straightforward
and you get a lot of free.
Ich würde die YAMLs, naja du musst ja
Moment, Moment, das, das, das
das eine erspart dir
das andere nicht.
Du musst, auch wenn du Argo CD verwendest
die YAMLs selbst definieren.
Das ist bei
beidem gleich. Der Unterschied ist
nur, dass du die YAMLs
mit kubectl applyen kannst
oder aber die gleichen YAML-Files
in den Repo pushen und Argo CD
saugt die sich aus dem Repo und
applyt die. Also im Prinzip macht Argo CD
ja nur, in Anführungsstrichen nur
ein kubectl apply für dich.
Macht schon noch ein bisschen mehr, aber
im Prinzip übernimmt Argo CD
das kubectl apply für dich.
Die YAML-Files, die du schreiben musst
sind auch genau die gleichen. Du musst sogar ein bisschen
mehr YAML-Files schreiben, damit
Argo CD erkennt, dass das eine Anwendung ist,
die es verwalten soll. Das macht eigentlich
keinen Unterschied, was du da anlegen musst.
Ich frage, ob du es von Hand applyst
oder nachvollziehbar von Argo CD
applyen lässt.
Also bis so weit gäbe ich ihm recht, ja.
Lokaler Bind,
jetzt wird es aber übertrieben.
Was ist denn das für eine
super fancy Shell, die er da,
Terminal besser gesagt,
was er da im Hintergrund hat?
Okay, Portainer
fand ich schon immer Schrott. Meine persönliche
Meinung.
CLI beste.
CLI beste. Portainer braucht
kein Vent.
Du kannst mit anderen
Tools wie Docker Compose oder Portainer
deinen Workflow noch stärker
verbessern. Es ist nichts
damit falsch. Aber die meisten von euch
werden wahrscheinlich auch sagen,
dass es eine große
Schmerz ist, all deine Projekte
mit Docker zu managen,
insbesondere wenn du planst,
dass... Dafür ist ja auch, und das muss man
jetzt mal ganz klar sagen, dafür war Docker
ursprünglich ja auch nie gedacht. Okay,
immer schwierig jetzt irgendwie zu sagen,
wo man an der Entwicklung nicht beteiligt war.
Aber der ursprüngliche Gedanke, meines
Wissens nach zumindest,
für Docker, war nicht,
um Docker auf irgendeinem Server laufen
zu lassen und darin Container auszuführen,
sondern für lokale Entwicklung, für
reproduzierbare Software-Builds
zum Beispiel, ja.
Um das Problem zu lösen,
es läuft auf meiner Kiste und bei dir nicht.
Dafür war Docker
ursprünglich mal gedacht. Und ist es heute
auch immer noch das Beste für.
Wie man zum Beispiel an dem Build
vom VM-Champ hier sieht,
ja. Dafür ist Docker wunderbar.
Dass man dann damit angefangen hat,
irgendwelche
Server-Anwendungen dauerhaft laufen
zu lassen,
da hat man es eigentlich schon leicht
zweckentfremd. Ich meine, es funktioniert dafür gut,
keine Frage. Gerade mit dem Reverse-Proxy davor,
wenn man nur einmal im Monat
drei Anwendungen neu starten muss,
ist das schon verkehrt.
Und wir haben hier auch schon teilweise rumgebastelt
mit GitHub Actions Deploy,
Kubernetes, äh, kein Kubernetes,
Docker-Compose-File und starte das neu.
Das war aber eher sehr, sehr
haarig, wie das Ganze funktioniert hat,
ja. Hätte ich mich damals schon
ein bisschen mehr mit Kubernetes beschäftigt, wäre das
der bessere Anwendungszweck dafür gewesen, anstatt
irgendwelche komischen Compose-Files
über GitHub Actions zu synchen,
über SSH und Restarten und so.
Ja. Aber gut,
man lernt ja mit der Zeit.
Dafür ist halt Kubernetes gut.
Sobald es mehr als ein Host ist
und du das Ganze vielleicht
auch ein bisschen dynamischer haben willst,
ähm,
weil ein Container laufen,
mal zwei, mal drei, mal vier,
mal vier, mal fünf, mal sechs,
mal zehn, mal acht, mal neun,
mal zehn, mal neun,
mal neun, mal neun,
Container laufen, mal zwei, mal drei
von der gleichen Anwendung und sowas,
dann ist es mit Docker halt schon ein bisschen doof.
Hat jemand von euch mal
die Ehre gehabt, mit Docker Swarm zu arbeiten?
Ich habe da immer einen großen Bogen drum gemacht
und habe es jetzt auch nicht vor mir anzugucken.
Erstens, weil es irgendwie dead ist
und es gibt Kubernetes, was sich durchgesetzt hat
durch die Bank.
Ja, Credentials,
Secret Management,
Secret Management ist unter Kubernetes
auch ein bisschen, ein bisschen eklig.
Ja.
Ach ja.
Also alles das, was du in einem Homelab
eigentlich nicht brauchst.
Was man normalerweise im Homelab auch nicht braucht.
Ja.
Genau.
Und vor allem, wenn man was lernen will,
ist es sehr, sehr cool, weil
bisschen Kubernetes-Skills sind heute
nicht verkehrt.
Und eigentlich ist es nicht so hart,
wie es die meisten glauben.
Ich habe bereits ein Tutorial gemacht.
Das stimmt.
Der Einstieg,
das ist ein bisschen das Fatale auch an Kubernetes.
auch wenn man sich mal so ein Getting-Started-Tutorial
angeguckt hat,
dann denkt man sich,
ist doch eigentlich ganz,
ganz übersichtlich,
ja.
Da machst du ein Deployment mit irgendeinem Image,
haust einen
Ingressor vor.
Das hast du alles in jedem Tag
angeguckt und denkst dir so,
ja, jetzt weißt du Bescheid.
Jetzt kannst du eigentlich auch Kubernetes verwenden.
Aber dann stellst du fest,
oh shit.
Dann kommst du vom Hundertste ins Tausendste
und es gibt 3000 Sachen,
mit denen du dich noch beschäftigen musst.
Und dann fängt es an auszuarten.
Am ersten Tag Kubernetes
denkst du dir noch so,
ja, ist doch eigentlich halb so wild.
Ist doch ganz übersichtlich.
Und dann hast du dich dann
beschäftigt,
so dir die restlichen erweiterten Basics anzugucken.
Auch die ganzen Projekte,
die es dazu gibt.
Von Argo CD,
bis wie du ein ordentliches Prometheus Monitoring machst.
External Secrets synchen kannst
und solche Geschichten.
Zertifikate ausstellen kannst und sowas.
Das ist ja alles nicht direkt in Kubernetes eingebaut,
sondern
sind Third-Party Sachen,
die aber auch irgendwo essentiell sind.
Ja, dann kannst du dich dann mit Custom Resources
oder mit deinem YAML Zeug definieren kannst,
was Kubernetes standardmäßig
gar nicht unterstützt.
Also, am ersten Tag
denkst du, easy ist doch relativ einfach.
Und dann die nächsten drei Monate
bist du damit beschäftigt, dir die erweiterten Basics
anzugucken, dass du das Ding überhaupt
gescheit betreiben kannst.
Und dann gibt es richtig
coole Sachen noch,
die schon sehr advanced sind.
Ich habe mal von Crossplane gehört.
Ich weiß, ich wechsle jetzt.
Habt ihr schon mal was von
Crossplane für Kubernetes gehört?
Das ist quasi,
ich versuch's mal so zu beschreiben,
das ist quasi so eine Art Terraform,
nur dass es
über Kubernetes läuft.
Also, der benutzt quasi Kubernetes Manifests
zum Definieren
von Ressourcen, die nicht zwangsläufig
Kubernetes Ressourcen sind.
Klingt jetzt total abgedreht, aber was man
damit machen kann, ist eigentlich mega nice.
Zum Beispiel,
aber das ist jetzt schon wirklich
advancedes Topic.
Zum Beispiel, es gibt ja ein Problem.
Mal angenommen,
du hast eine Anwendung und du hast
da jetzt ein Kubernetes Manifest für erstellt,
für die Anwendung.
Die Anwendung besteht aus Container Image
und einem
Loadbalancer zum Beispiel.
Deployment, Container Image und Loadbalancer.
Du hast deine Anwendung definiert für Kubernetes.
Jetzt braucht die Anwendung
allerdings eine Datenbank.
Was machst du denn da jetzt?
Das ist gar nicht so einfach,
weil die Datenbank hat in der Regel
mit Kubernetes nichts zu tun.
Es sei denn, du lässt es auch in Kubernetes laufen.
Was machst du denn dann?
Du hast eine Anwendung, du willst sie deployen in Kubernetes.
Die braucht aber eine Datenbank,
um ihre Daten zu speichern.
Was machst du dann? Eigentlich nichts.
Das kannst du auf Kubernetes Ebene nicht lösen.
Du kannst deine Anwendung in Kubernetes deployen
und dann musst du zusätzlich
das Web Interface von deinem
Cloud Provider, die in der Datenbank
zusammenklicken oder über Terraform
zusätzlich eine Datenbank zusammenklicken
und dann hat dein Kubernetes Deployment
nicht so wirklich was
mit deinem Terraform Provisioning der Datenbank
oder der VM zu tun eventuell sogar.
Crossplane
versucht das zu fixen,
indem du dort
beispielsweise das Anlegen einer
Google
Postgres Datenbank
auch in Kubernetes Manifest
definieren kannst.
Das heißt, du kannst deine Kubernetes Anwendung definieren
mit dem eingebauten
Kubernetes
Namespaces und APIs.
Du kannst allerdings zusätzlich noch
eine Datenbank definieren,
die dann in Google Cloud Provisioned wird.
Das heißt, du machst dann ein Deployment,
also du applyst dann
dieses Manifest auf deinen Kubernetes Cluster,
er legt die Kubernetes Ressourcen an,
aber gleichzeitig
sorgt Crossplane dafür, dass für deine Kubernetes
Anwendung auch noch in Google
eine Datenbank Provisioned wird.
Du hast das quasi dann alles zusammen
als Kubernetes Manifest, aber es
managt auch Ressourcen außerhalb
des Kubernetes Clusters.
Eigentlich was richtig geiles, aber mega
pfeifert. Deswegen sag ich euch, ohne Scheiß,
Kubernetes ist ein komplettes Fass
ohne Bohnen, wenn man sich damit
angefangen hat zu beschäftigen.
MicroCades!
Okay,
K8S, muss man Cades
aussprechen, aber Cades klingt einfach
falsch irgendwie.
Ich hab die Aussprache jetzt schon
von manchen gehört, aber Cades
ist einfach irgendwie ein bisschen...
Es hört sich falsch an.
Übrigens, es gibt ja
für Kubernetes gibt es ja hier
dieses Kommandozeilen-Tool,
Cube... Alter, ich kann ja immer schreiben, Leute.
Cubectl.
Ja, bla bla bla, so.
Wie kann ich mir das manche Leute aussprechen?
Wie sprecht ihr das aus?
Habe ich nicht installiert.
Wie spricht
ihr Cubectl
aus?
Sprecht ihr es Cubectl aus?
Sprecht ihr es Cubecontrol aus?
Oder
sprecht ihr es wie manche
Cubecutl aus?
Cubecutl ist das allerbeste, Mann.
Cubecutl.
Das Terminal, was er nutzt, heißt
Warp und ist in Rust.
Ein Rust-Terminal.
Blazingly fast.
Written in Rust. Auf geht's.
Warp. Def. Zeig mal her.
Ah, das kenn ich.
Das kenn ich. Das habe ich mir schon angeguckt.
Das ist das Terminal, wo man ein Login
braucht. Da war es bei mir schon
gestorben. Wenn mein Terminal
ein Cloud-Service braucht, dann
ist vorbei. Du musst dich
einloggen. Du musst dich einloggen,
dass du dein Terminal verwenden kannst.
Nope.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ja,
das gibt es nicht.
Warp. Ich zeige es euch mal.
Warp.
Term.
Kann man gar nicht sehen.
Ist das sogar
macOS-only zurzeit?
Noch schlimmer.
Du musst dich
einloggen dafür, dass du das verwenden kannst.
Ganz im Ernsthaft. Wenn ich mich einlogge,
dass ich mein Terminal benutzen kann, dann
hört es bei mir schon auf.
Ich sehe es nicht ein,
dass ich mich einloggen muss.
Also online registrieren muss
bei einem Service, um mein lokales
Terminal zu verwenden. Irgendwann ist es auch mal gut.
Westterm ist auch in Rust.
Westterm ist auch das beste Terminal, was ich
die letzten Jahre über gefunden habe.
Nachdem ich es jetzt ungefähr
ein halbes Jahr verwende, halte ich Westterm
auch tatsächlich für das beste
allround Terminal,
was es zurzeit gibt.
Was ist, wenn das Internet ausfällt?
Ja, dann wird sich deine Session wahrscheinlich
schon speichern. Aber dass man überhaupt
einen Account anlegen muss, was man das
überhaupt braucht für einen Terminal, ist doch schon
hängen geblieben.
Westterm.
Das da.
Das da. Beste.
Also das ist das Terminal, was ich hier
auch gerade verwende.
Ich versuche es mal ganz kurz für euch
auf den Punkt zu bringen.
Warum?
Warum Westterm?
Das erste coole ist, Westterm benutzt die GPU
zum Rendern, was ziemlich egal ist,
weil, glaube ich, niemand irgendwie am
Output-Limit vom Terminal bisher Probleme
mit hatte.
Es wird gerne damit geworben,
GPU rendert Terminal. Ehrlich gesagt ist es
scheißegal, ob das Terminal GPU rendert
ist oder nicht, weil
die Output-Geschwindigkeit
vom Terminal ist nie wirklich
das Problem.
Ich wüsste gar nicht, wofür
man das braucht.
Aber du findest, was das
wirklich coole an Westterm ist.
Das erste ist, es unterstützt quasi
alles,
es unterstützt quasi alles, was
TMAX kann out of the box.
Du kannst horizontal splitten,
du kannst, ah, falscher Knopf.
Du kannst vertikal splitten,
du kannst die
Panels wechseln,
wie du willst.
Du kannst einzelne
einzelne kannst du maximieren
und klein machen.
Und dann kannst du TMAX
mehr lokal.
Was ich persönlich sehr praktisch finde,
weil TMAX in TMAX halt
ein bisschen eklig zu benutzen ist.
TMAX auf dem Server ist das Beste,
was du machen kannst, aber TMAX lokal
und zusätzlich im Server, da hast du
TMAX in TMAX in TMAX teilweise
und musst dann STRG B B B machen,
um dort auf dem Server was...
Das ist doof. Es ist praktisch,
dass du lokal kein TMAX mehr brauchst.
Und dann hast du auch keine
TMAX mehr.
Und dann kannst du TMAX
teilweise komplett copy-pasted
über alle Zeilen hier, weil es ja nicht weiß,
dass das unterschiedliche
Panels sind im Terminal.
So kannst du es hier
quasi kopieren.
Du hast im Prinzip eine TMAX
Funktionalität eingebaut.
Das ist schon mal sehr praktisch.
Finde ich persönlich nice.
Du hast auch mehrere Tabs.
Kannst du auch machen, kein Problem.
Was so Terminal
Management angeht, ist
gut. Ist eingebaut.
Das nächste coole ist, du kannst
es quasi nahezu customizen, wie du willst.
Entweder nimmst du die Default
Config, aber die Default Config ist wirklich
kacke. Das ist glaube ich der größte Kritikpunkt an
Westterm, dass die Default
Config nicht sonderlich gut ist.
Aber du kannst das
Terminal so gut konfigurieren,
wie kein anderes Terminal.
Also keins, was ich kenne.
Du hast nämlich eine
Config,
die du in Lua
programmieren kannst.
Also du kannst nicht nur einfach
Config machen, wie man das so kennt.
Enable Scrollbar, Scrolllines,
Fancy Tapper. Also du kannst nicht nur
Config machen an sich.
Du hast eine komplette Programmiersprache
in der Config.
Und du kannst es komplett konfigurieren,
wie du willst.
Meine Config ist veröffentlicht.
Github, Woblords, Dotfiles.
Passt.
Da.
Da ist alles drin.
Jo.
Und ansonsten hat es bestimmt noch mehr coole Sachen.
Achso!
Bildersupport hat es.
Du kannst sagen Westterm,
ImageCat
und jetzt zum Beispiel ein Gif abspielen
im Terminal. Direkt im Terminal.
Das ist auch nice, oder?
Oder Wetter.
Kannst direkt Wetterimages...
Das ist jetzt unsinnig.
Ja, aber ich wollte es ja bloß mal als Beispiel zeigen.
ImageCat.
Gifs abspielen im Terminal.
Ist das nicht nice?
Und man kann das auch
ein bisschen erweitern.
Dass man irgendwann sagen kann
ImageCat
und dann
zeigt er alle Bilder an, die im aktuellen
Verzeichnis drin sind.
Unter anderem auch
Gachirole. Ganz essentiell.
Das brauchen wir.
Alle Bilder, die in meinem Downloadverzeichnis
drin sind, hat er jetzt angezeigt auf dem Terminal.
Alles auf dem Terminal.
Und nur Bilder.
Das ist übrigens ein kleines Skript, was ich um
Westterm ImageCat drum herum
gebaut habe.
Ja, siehste.
Da habe ich mal irgendwie diese WLAN
Firmware ausgepackt
und schon habe ich da
30.000 Bilder hier im Downloadverzeichnis drin.
Man kann sogar SVGs und so.
Also es ist ein cooles Ding.
Also Westterm und das beste ist,
Westterm gibt es auch für Windows.
Windows, Mac und Linux.
Also super, super Kombination.
Ist das Plugins?
Ne, das ist eingebaut.
Gibt es einen Vim-Mode,
um hochzuscrollen und Texte kopieren
ohne Maus? Äh, ja.
Das ist Default in Vim. Guck.
Vim RC. Scrollen
mit Tastatur oder alternativ kannst du
auch hier scrollen mit der Maus.
Und markieren kannst du entweder
so mit der Maus oder
du drückst V für Visual Mode.
Das geht in jedem Vim gleich.
Und dann kannst du hier selecten
und kopieren.
Ach ja.
Falls du in das System Clipboard
möchtest du in das System Clipboard kopieren,
dann sieht das ein bisschen anders aus.
System Clipboard ist tatsächlich
das einfachste. Du machst das mit dem Terminal
oder du markierst die Zeile und drückst.
Pass auf.
Ich zeige euch jetzt. Hier ist meine Zwischenablage drin.
Und jetzt ist gleich Syntax
on in meiner Zwischenablage drin.
Falls ich Vim mit Clipboard
Extensions habe. Du kannst es auch markieren
in Vim. Und dann drückst du
lacht jetzt nicht, aber
es ist wirklich so.
Und dann drückst du
doppelte Anführungszeichen
plus
Y.
Und dann wirst du sehen, es funktioniert nicht,
weil mein Vim anscheinend Clipboard nicht aktiviert hat.
Aber okay. Du musst
wirklich Anführungszeichen
plus Y drücken.
Was nicht geht, weil ich es nicht in meinem Vim
aktiviert habe. Dann kannst du es in System
Clipboard
yanken. Wenn du es
konfiguriert hast, was ich anscheinend gar nicht
konfiguriert habe.
Vim System Clipboard.
Vim Requires plus Clipboard Feature.
Echo has Clipboard.
Habe ich Clipboard überhaupt?
Null. Siehst du mal.
Mein Vim hat kein Clipboard Support.
Was ist das denn? Warum habe ich
kein Clipboard Support?
Weil
ich Vim installiert habe und nicht
G-Vim. Alles klar. Wir können auch
einfach Neo-Vim installieren. Da ist es
wahrscheinlich enabled.
Scheiß drauf. Brauche ich eh nicht.
Du brauchst ein Vim mit Clipboard Support. Dann
funktioniert das Ganze. Und dann
kannst du so
machen oder so machen,
um es ins Clipboard
zu kopieren, das Select. Aber das
Wichtigste ist, was du
brauchst zu markieren,
ist
Macro mit X-Copy geht wahrscheinlich noch.
V. V ist Whistle Mode.
Groß V ist
Line Select Whistle Mode.
Und Shift V ist
Rectangular Select
Whistle Mode.
So sieht's aus. Ich guck jetzt das Kubernetes
Video fertig.
Wieder viel zu lange
geschwätzt. Wo sind wir überhaupt stehen geblieben?
Where Kubernetes
is bad. Alles klar.
Das ist so, wie ich es gemacht habe.
Und ich dachte, das ist großartig.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Sorry, Leute.
Ich meine, Westerm,
ich kann in T-Max mit Ctrl-B
scrollen. Ja, das geht auch.
Das geht auch. Das benutze ich aber
nicht. Weil
in Westerm finde ich persönlich
das Copy-Pasten mit der Maus
und dem Maus-Select viel
angenehmer. Ja, Westerm
hat einen Selection und einen Search
Mode. Da kannst du deine Scrollback
History selecten und searchen.
Habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Hatte es. Hatte es. Habe ich aber noch nie benutzt.
Okay.
Also Secret
Management in Kubernetes ist ein bisschen
eklig.
Das dachte ich mir. Weil so einfach
ist es meistens nicht.
Kubernetes isn't a magic solution
that solves all your problems with the snap
of your fingers. It introduces a new
level of complexity and it
will take time to learn
how to set it up and manage it. Oh ja.
Ja, ohne Scheiß. Das ist
nicht ohne. Die Lernkurve ist mega
steil. Was heißt denn Lernkurve
auf Englisch?
Learning Curve. Okay, da hätte ich selbst drauf kommen können.
In Kubernetes, da gibt's
bestimmt,
da gibt es bestimmt Meme-Bilder dazu.
Learning Curve of Kubernetes.
Kubernetes.
Ja.
Das war klar, dass es dazu irgendwelche
Bildschirme gibt.
Ja.
Was?
Value of Kubernetes.
Size of.
Kann ich überhaupt nicht lesen.
Ach, Size of Org.
Also es ist klar, dass es da schon irgendwie
Kubernetes Learning Curve Memes
gibt für. Das ist auch
wirklich heftig.
Er prasselt so viel auf dich ein.
Ich küsse dein Herz, Bruder.
Event und Update
Battlefield. Ich hoffe, das
Event heißt nicht, ich küsse dein Herz, Bruder.
So, wo sind wir, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
So, wir gucken uns jetzt das restliche
Video auch noch an, man. Ich hab jetzt
für sieben Minuten Video eine halbe Stunde
geschwätzt wieder.
Over the time I had tons and tons of problems
with it, even though I would claim to have a
pretty solid knowledge about Linux and
containers, but Kubernetes takes all this
to a new level.
There are a lot of moving parts and a very specific
architecture that you need to familiarize
yourself with. What is a config
map? What is a storage class?
What is an ingress controller?
What is the difference between a deployment
and a state... Und welche Plattform unterstützt
welche Storage Class und sowas?
All this matters in Kubernetes and it
requires a deep understanding of networking,
security and storage,
which can be difficult for even
IT professionals. Ja. So that's
why many people say that Kubernetes
is difficult to understand and
I would totally agree, it is.
And it gets even worse when something
inside the cluster itself
is broken. For instance, I had
this situation once that one of the
K3S servers went out of disk
space and that somehow
broke the entire ADCD database,
so the core database where all
the resources of Kubernetes are stored in.
And even after increasing the disk
space, the ADCD database didn't
want to come up again. And finally
after troubleshooting for hours and
hours, I just decided to restore
all the stuff from a snapshot.
I think that was the moment
when I lost it. Es gibt
eine lustige Serie,
also was ist lustig, lustig, lustig, ich meine
es ist keine Sitcom oder so. Es gibt eine Serie
von irgendeinem Typ auf YouTube, da geht
es darum, die Leute bekommen,
also der lädt sich verschiedene Gäste ein
und die bekommen als Aufgabe
pro Folge
den Kubernetes Cluster zu fixen.
Und die brauchen dann
teilweise zwei Stunden, um den Kubernetes Cluster
zu fixen. Ich weiß nicht,
wie das hieß.
Das ist so eine Serie
von irgend so einem YouTuber.
Von irgend so einem, also
nicht großen, aber von irgend so einem...
Keine Ahnung, wie diese Serie
heißt. Habe ich letztens gefunden,
da gibt es irgendwie schon 85 Folgen
oder so, wo der immer Gäste einlädt
und die Gäste müssen dann den
kaputt gefrickelten
Kubernetes Cluster fixen. Das ist halt
die Challenge quasi. Schaffe in
eineinhalb Stunden, oder mach in eineinhalb Stunden,
dass der Kubernetes Cluster wieder geht.
Allein schon, dass man sowas
als mindestens 85
Folgen produzieren kann
dafür, fix den Kubernetes Cluster,
kann man sich vorstellen, da kann einiges kaputt
gehen.
So that Kubernetes can provide a high
level of fault tolerance to your
containers and ports, it's important to
know that this is only true for
applications that are designed to run
multiple instances.
For applications that aren't...
Deswegen machen die coolen Leute ja
heute auch nur 12-Faktor-Apps.
Nee, hieß das überhaupt so?
Leute, wie hieß der?
12-Faktor-Applications. Ja, genau.
Die coolen Leute machen
12-Faktor-Apps.
Sie sind noch cooler als Julien Bam,
der hatte nur 7-Faktor-Authentifizierung
und das ist eine 12-Faktor-App.
Da geht's übrigens nicht um
Authentifizierung bei, sondern quasi
um Methoden,
wie man eine
Anwendung programmieren sollte,
dass sie sich gut eignet im
Cloud-Umfeld, im Kubernetes-Umfeld
zu laufen.
Macht keine Datenbank in
Kubernetes, Leute.
Spart euch den Stress.
Wenn ihr eh schon bei einem Cloud-Anbieter seid,
benutzt einfach dem seine Managed-Datenbank
und seid froh.
Freut euch des Lebens und versucht keine
Datenbank selbst im Kubernetes-Cluster zu
betreiben.
Nee, so einfach ist es nicht.
You still need to
consider setting up a database
replication and configure the
correct storage backend for WordPress.
So, while Kubernetes
does provide the features
to help you solve these complex problems
like high availability or replication,
it is still up to you
Das glaube ich dir, Captain Seeker.
Das ist auch abartig. Also ich hatte
glücklicherweise noch nicht die Ehre
und ich werde auch, wo ich es mitentscheiden
kann oder Ratschläge wenigstens geben
darf, mich dagegen auswirken,
Datenbanken
und großartig persistente Sachen
in Docker, äh, nicht in Docker, in Kubernetes zu
betreiben, wenn man es eh auf einer
Managed, wohlgemerkt, wenn man es auf einer
Managed-Cloud-Plattform macht,
die auch Managed-Datenbanken anbietet,
dann macht es nämlich aus meiner Sicht kaum
einen Sinn,
das überhaupt im
Cluster zu betreiben.
Lokal mag es anders aussehen.
Das stimmt.
Es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll,
Kubernetes sich ein bisschen damit zu beschäftigen,
weil im Admin-Umfeld,
im DevOps-Umfeld, auch im
Entwicklungsumfeld,
heute ist das einfach die Technik,
die sich durchgesetzt hat, um
Container, für Container-Orchestrierung
und dementsprechend
sind Skills da drinne,
und auch für einen Entwickler ist es sinnvoll,
äh, Deployment-Manifest
schreiben zu können, weil der Trend
geht ja dahin, dass
man eine, eine
Plattform bereitgestellt bekommt,
also Kubernetes-Cluster bereitgestellt
bekommt, und sich dann selbst um
Updates und Deployments
kümmert. Dass es nicht mehr so ist, wie die
Entwickler programmieren irgendwo was, und dann
äh, kümmern sich in Zukunft andere drum.
Ne, es wird eine Plattform bereitgestellt,
worauf das läuft, und die Entwickler machen
selbst ihr Deployment.
Manifest und Updates
davon, da geht ja der Trend
durchaus hin. Und insofern
ist das, ist das, ist das sinnvoll,
ja, sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Simple.
That's by the way the reason why I'm
still running my databases
not inside a Kubernetes cluster,
but on the second Docker
server in my home lab. And I also
still have a few other
applications on my first Docker
server, where I just wanna have it
simple and straightforward.
So my goal is not to replace Docker
entirely with Kubernetes in my home lab.
I think there are still valuable
reasons to use Docker in certain
scenarios. Ich frag mich immer, was die Leute
eigentlich lokal alles laufen haben.
Ich mein, ich hab ein paar Container bei mir laufen,
äh, zwei VMs,
und fertig. Das war's!
Ich wüsste gar nicht, was ich mit dem lokalen
Kubernetes-Cluster machen soll.
Also a few amazing
things that you can only do
with Kubernetes. Außer zum Lernen.
Dafür ist es sinnvoll.
Yes, there is a steep learning
curve and the complexity can be
a real challenge to overcome,
but once you learn the basics and
you got familiar with some of the processes
and how to work with Kubernetes,
you will have access to a whole new
set of tools and a new
infrastructure that helps you solve
these complex problems. We've
already talked about adding additional
servers in your home lab, high availability
and credential management.
These are the known limitations of
Docker and this is just
so much better organized in Kubernetes.
But there are also many other cool things
that you can do with this platform and I quickly
want to show you something. For example,
I'm using a tool that is called
ArgoCD. ArgoCD
ist wirklich extrem nice. To deploy
my applications in Kubernetes.
This is a program for managing GitOps
deployments and it provides a lot
of automation. Sieht kompliziert
aus, aber das ist
nicht so, als müsst ihr das hier
konfigurieren. Das macht ArgoCD für euch.
ArgoCD erzeugt
unter anderem eine Übersicht, wie
eure Anwendungen
miteinander zusammenhängen, beziehungsweise
wie eure Deployments miteinander zusammenhängen.
Ihr erstellt einfach nur einen
Deployment-Yaml-File und
das, was unter der Haube
angelegt wird im Cluster, das
visualisiert euch ArgoCD.
Dann kann man sich das Ganze angucken.
Es ist eine coole Sache. Vor allem,
dass man nicht mehr selbst applies, sondern
es nur noch ins Git-Repo eincheckt und
ArgoCD ist applied und dementsprechend
alles nachvollziehbar ist, hat
was. Hat was. Mir gefällt der
Ansatz. Man kann auch
Flux verwenden anstatt ArgoCD.
Aber mit Flux habe ich keine Erfahrung
bisher gesammelt.
Sorry, dass ich immer so oft
pausieren muss. Da sieht man die
Möglichkeiten, die
so eine YAML-basierte,
Git-basierte
Infrastrukturadministration
bietet. Guck mal, hier
aktualisiert er sein Image.
Das musst du ja erst mal mitbekommen, dass
das Image eine neue Version hat.
Du kannst aber Tools laufen lassen
über dein Git-Repo, die checken,
ob eines deiner Images
outdated ist und
sagen dir dann Bescheid, so nach dem Motto
hier gibt es ein neues
Image von und wenn du ein gescheites Tool
verwendest, dann macht es dir sogar ein Pull-Request auf
und aktualisiert das an der Stelle
für dich. Dann bekommst du es mit.
Es gibt schon
coole Möglichkeiten.
... changes to the files in my Git-Repository
where I have defined
all these resources, then I
commit these changes and push it
to the repo and ArgoCD
will automatically make these changes
happening on the cluster and
visualize all the different options.
I don't need to restart anything,
I don't need to open any config files,
it just works fully automatic.
You also get
other tools like Helm to deploy
an even complex application
stack with versioning support
in Kubernetes or CertManager
that allows you to automate the management
of SSLs. Also ihr merkt schon,
das ist wirklich ein Fass ohne Boden.
Und CertManager und External Sequence,
das ist fast noch erweiterte Basics.
Das geht noch deutlich abgedreht.
Ich bin ja Team EngineX,
was das angeht.
... discover services,
configure encryption
and perform routing of incoming
requests to your cluster.
And let's not forget about storage.
Kubernetes also provides a variety
of storage options from...
Chat, was sagt ihr im
Homelab beziehungsweise...
Egal, ich frage einfach.
Was sagt ihr? EngineX, Traffic,
Cudi, was ist der Reverse-Proxy
eurer Wahl?
Also ich mag Cudi für einfache Sachen
im Kubernetes-Umfeld EngineX.
Traffic
benutze ich eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Okay, hauptsächlich EngineX.
EngineX mit UI oder ohne?
Ohne. Ich wusste nicht mal, dass sie ein gutes UI
haben. Haben die...
Haben die ein UI?
Ach, aber nur
in Third-Party-Geschichten, oder? Haben die
einen eingebaut?
Der EngineX-Proxy-Manager ist kein
EngineX-UI. EngineX-Proxy-Manager
ist für...
Zertifikatverwaltung und sowas. Mit UI meine ich
so Statistiken anzeigen lassen und sowas.
Das braucht kein Mensch.
Alter, wie das einfach mal...
Okay.
Das ist tatsächlich schon mal ganz interessant,
hier Netzwerk-Statistiken zu...
Also ohne UI. Ganz ehrlich,
wozu auch? Visualisierung
würde ich eh über Prometheus-Metriken
und in Grafana machen. Also da brauchen die
Dinger eigentlich kein extra Dashboard.
Das ist auch
the way aus meiner Sicht.
Ja, Metriken absaugen und
dann in Grafana mit dem ganzen restlichen
Kram visualisieren. Braucht man kein extra Dashboard
dafür.
Leute, bei Kubernetes,
im Kubernetes-Umfeld ist es echt so,
ihr lernt jeden Tag von einem neuen,
coolen Projekt. Und wenn
ihr dann auf GitHub guckt, hat es 8000 Sterne.
This is just a fraction of what is all possible
in Kubernetes. You get access
to tons and tons of tools and options
to address complex
processes with containers.
Sure, it takes time to learn
how this all works and how these tools
interplay with each other, but
once you have come to a point where
you... Na, das ist gar nicht immer so
sehr, dass die Tools end of life sind.
Ihr müsst halt gucken, was ihr verwendet. Also wenn das
irgendwas ist, was ein Cloud
Dingsbums Foundation
Projekt ist, dann sind die Chancen schon mal
besser. Ja, oder wenn das ordentlich
maintained ist. Ich glaube, wenn man sich ein bisschen
umguckt, geht das tatsächlich
halbwegs.
Simplify, nachdem man es erst mal ein halbes
Jahr studiert hat, natürlich.
Das stimmt.
I would say it was
absolutely worth my time. Ja, auf
jeden Fall. Let's not underestimate how
much valuable these skills are that
you are learning. Richtig, richtig.
Ja, scheiß drauf, ob es sich fürs
Homelab jetzt eignet oder nicht. Wichtig ist,
dass du was gelernt hast, was dir dann
am Endeffekt auch was bringt.
Es ist ja egal, ob dir das für daheim
was bringt. Also wenn du in der IT arbeitest,
Kubernetes Skills bringen dir auf jeden Fall was.
Kubernetes Cluster on your own, you can
develop a deep understanding of how
all the platform works and how to
troubleshoot all the issues that may arise.
And this is what professional companies
are looking for. Kubernetes
is becoming increasingly popular. Das stimmt.
And probably the go-to
standard in tech industry when it comes
to container orchestration. Kubernetes.
And if you can gain hands-on experience
with it in your Homelab,
you're developing some really useful skills.
Das stimmt, da hat er recht.
So, what can you learn from all this?
So ist es.
In a simple Homelab with just one single
Cover, Kubernetes would be an absolute
overkill. And if you have no intentions
to learn this technology,
you're happy with Docker,
I think there's a very minimal benefit
you would get from using Kubernetes.
But if you're willing to invest some
time into learning new tech skills
and you have a bigger Homelab with
many projects and containers,
I think Kubernetes will make
so many things easier for you in
the long run. And it's
absolutely worth your time as an
IT guy. Yes, it can be challenging
to get started. I totally get it.
But you will also gain a valuable
skill set that's in high demand
in the IT industry.
That's perhaps the best argument
to get started with it.
Of course you can follow my channel
and watch more exciting videos about
Kubernetes and Docker. I'm continuing
to make more content for you in the future.
Ja, naja, so sieht's aus.
Was ist eigentlich aus diesen ganzen
anderen Container-Orchestrierungen
geworden? So Mesos ist das erste,
was mir jetzt noch im Hinterkopf einfällt.
Das ist doch komplett alles auf dem
absteigenden Ast, seit Kubernetes da so
auf der Überholspur ist, oder?
Ich glaube, es ist alles, alles
deadge. Was ist eine gute lokale
IP-Camp für Home Assistant?
Ich kann dir zeigen, welche ich habe.
Da musst du aber ein bisschen drauf
gucken, weil die haben auch welche,
die sind Cloud-only. Ich habe
Reolink-Kameras. Ein paar, auch
Outdoor und sowas, sowas hier zum
Beispiel. Alter, ich bin so
nervös!
Ich bin so nervös!
Ist das teuer geworden? Das hat noch 40 Euro
gekostet oder so vor einem Jahr.
Ja, so ein Shit.
Die Dinger sind jetzt nicht qualitativ
super krass.
Also,
die musst du auch ab und zu mal rebooten.
Kannst du automatisiert
einstellen, dass die sich einmal die Woche
rebooten, dann hast du damit keine Probleme.
Aber der Preis, Preis-Leistung ist okay.
Und die kannst du rein lokal betreiben.
Die kannst du einrichten,
lokal übers Netzwerk,
ohne Cloud, ohne
alles. Und
dann auch deine WLAN-Credentials
und so eingeben. Musst aber gucken, dass
du eine findest. Und die streamen
dann auch nicht nach China. Kannst ja ein extra
WLAN-Netzwerk packen. Muss man die flashen? Nein.
Die machen, die haben ein lokales
Webinterface, RTSP-Stream,
ohne alles.
Du kannst die auch ohne Hersteller-App konfigurieren,
übers Netzwerk.
Du stöpselst die das erste Mal an,
ans Netzwerk, konfigurierst
über das Webinterface, gibst dann dort dein
WLAN-Passwort ein und alles und dann
stöpselst das ab und machst Strom dran,
das lockt sich ins WLAN ein. Das ist eigentlich ganz cool gemacht.
Und du kannst es auch natürlich in einem abgeschotteten Netzwerk
machen, wenn du erst gar nicht willst, dass die jemals
an dein internes Netzwerk
kommt, die China-Chinesen-Kamera.
Also die sind ganz okay, die Teile.
Die sind relativ günstig, sind jetzt nicht die
krasseste Qualität.
Mir ist auch schon eine kaputt gegangen.
Und es ist
aber Preis-Leistung schon
in Ordnung.
Das liegt aber eher
nicht an Reolink, sondern wie man
den in Home Assistant reinbringt.
Also ich mache mittlerweile das alles über WebRTC
und
sodass das Home Assistant
quasi per WebRTC
drauf zugreift. Also es läuft
immer, der RTSP-Stream läuft permanent
zu einem Streaming-Server und der Streaming-Server
stellt es dann per WebRTC bereit und
Home Assistant greift drauf zu.
Das geht halbwegs.
Das geht so.
Ich möchte jetzt noch eine Sache kurz beantworten,
die vorhin im Stream gefragt wurde und zwar
ob das
Logo hier
Copyright
copyright-frei und
so ist.
Das Logo habe ich nicht selbst designed.
Ich kann sowas nicht.
Ich habe tatsächlich den Namecheap
Logo-Generator verwendet.
Dafür.
Guck.
Your Brand. Cute. Chat.
Oh. Choose.
Style hier.
Das ist mega cute hier.
Perfekt.
Sehr gut.
Excellent. Ganz toll.
Farbdinger.
Farbtöne. Der soll unbedingt in
cute pink sein.
Slogan.
Cute as fuck.
So.
Dann kann man sich paar Icons aussuchen.
Weiß nicht, was es zu cute für Icons gibt.
Excellent.
Genau das. Das brauchen wir.
Uwu.
Jetzt kann man drei Icons
picken.
Und dann kickt man sowas.
Und es sieht eigentlich ganz nice aus.
Man kann es noch ein bisschen
customizen.
Wie man das haben will.
Man kann zum Beispiel dann auch sagen.
Ah nee. Geh mal weg.
Ich will das doch nicht so haben.
Sondern zum Beispiel
so oder so.
So will ich es haben.
Und dann sieht das tatsächlich.
Ohne Scheiß. Dann sieht das noch halbwegs.
Guck mal. Das sieht durchaus
brauchbar aus.
Das Logo und das Zeug.
Ich mein. Hey. Das ist jetzt nichts wo ich professionelles
Business vielleicht mit aufmachen würde.
Man kann es hier unten dann auch runterladen.
Wenn man fertig ist.
Irgendwo.
Oder man kann es einfach screenshoten.
An der Stelle. Ach okay.
Man muss es sein. Es kostet aber nichts.
Es kostet nichts. Und ich hatte bei dem eh schon
einen Account. Man kann sich auch gleich noch die
Domain zusätzlich registrieren lassen.
cutechat.co
Ich muss sagen.
Ich finde es ganz nice.
Für so simple Sachen wie
irgendein Github Projekt.
Wo du nichts großartiges mit vor hast.
Danke Leute für die ganzen
Github Stars.
Übrigens. Wie findet ihr eigentlich
die Optik bis hier hin.
Wie findet ihr die Optik von meiner
von meiner Github
Github Readme.
So und jetzt kommt das Reveal.
Jetzt kommt das Reveal.
Ich hab die nur geklaut.
Und zwar habe ich die von unserem
Modge geklaut.
Nicht Max FPS. Sirius Max
WTF.
Ich hab die von unserem Modge geklaut.
Guckt mal.
Ihr erkennt vielleicht
gewisse
gewisse Ähnlichkeiten.
Ich weiß nicht.
Vielleicht hat er sie ja auch geklaut.
Ich hab das von unserem
Modge geklaut.
Und übrigens diese Badges.
Das Badgeservice ist auch mega nice.
Ja.
Okay Leute. 4 Stunden Aufwachstream.
Das ging ja deutlich länger.
Als sonst immer.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Ich hab übertrieben Hunger.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis dann vielleicht.
Vielleicht bin ich nachher am Start.
Und wir erweitern den VM Champ noch ein paar Kleinigkeiten.
Wir haben lange schon kein Programmierstream mehr gemacht.
Wo man was sinnvolles macht.
Was gibt's zum Essen?
Ähm.
Ich muss mal überlegen.
Es gibt Reste von gestern.
Was gab's denn gestern?
Es ist nicht Nudel mit Lachs.
Sondern.
Ich glaube es ist Nudel mit Tomatensauce.
Ja.
So Bolognese Style.
Tomatensauce, Hackfleisch, Spaghetti.
Diesmal nicht Nudel mit Lachs.
Nudel mit Tomatensauce.
Okay.
Wir sehen uns vielleicht später.
Bis dann.
Tschüss.